hello everyone welcome to simply loans
youtube channel in this session we will
be learning about advanced java
developer fill course but before we
begin make sure that you have subscribed
to our youtube channel and don't forget
to hit that bell icon to never miss an
update from simply learn
now without further ado let's get
started with our agenda for today's
discussion
so at first we'll begin with
introduction to java enterprise edition
followed by that we will understand the
fundamentals of exceptions and how to
handle them next we will learn about the
java collections followed by that we
will enter into java servlet tutorial
next we will understand the fundamentals
of zam and how to install it on our
windows system
followed by that we will learn lambda
expressions and learn more about them
using some real time examples next we
will learn about enumeration in java
followed by that we will learn
annotations in java serialization in
java next we will get into
multiprocessing in java and we will
learn about it by implementing some
practical programs based on
multi-threading in java next we will
learn about synchronization in java and
then the autoboxing in java followed by
that we will learn input output streams
in java java database connections
generics in java string handling in java
java.lang library and java.util library
followed by that we will learn
networking in java in the next segment
we will learn about images in java
concurrency utilities regular
expressions in java non-blocking input
output in java java beans java api then
we will learn the most important
framework in java that is the spring
framework in java next we will enter the
spring model view control then we will
understand spring and restful
application programming interface
followed by that to make things more
interesting we will go through a
springboard project then we will learn
some testing fundamentals using junit
testing tutorial and finally we will go
through some most updated java project
ideas then to help you crack your java
interviews like a pro we will go through
some java interview questions i hope i
made myself clear with the agenda now
let's quickly begin with our first topic
that is what exactly is java enterprise
edition
the java ee stands for java enterprise
edition which was earlier known as j2ee
and is currently known as jar kataka ee
the java enterprise edition provides a
platform for developers with enterprise
features such as distributed computing
and web services
now let's move further and understand
why exactly we needed java enterprise
edition
we needed java enterprise edition for
four major reasons to have powerful api
support to reduce development time to
reduce application complexity and
finally to improve the application
performance so followed by the need for
java enterprise edition we will move
ahead and understand the java enterprise
specifications so in the java enterprise
specifications we are going to discuss
the four major specifications used by
enterprise developers so the first one
being the enterprise specification
followed by that we have a web
specification then we have web server
specification and finally some other
miscellaneous specifications we shall
discuss each one of them in detail
firstly we will move ahead with
enterprise specification so in
enterprise specification we have the
first one to discuss that is the context
dependency injection
the context dependency injection
provides a container to inject
dependencies as in swing
next we have java enterprise java bean
the enterprise java bean is a set of
lightweight apis that an object
container possesses in order to provide
transactions remote procedure calls and
concurrency control
followed by java bean we have java
persistent apis so the java persistent
api are the specifications of object
relational mapping between relational
database tables and java classes
next we have the java transaction api
it consists of java interfaces and
annotations to establish interaction
between java transaction support offered
by java enterprise edition the apis in
the abstract from low level detail to
the interfaces are also considered as
low level followed by java transaction
api we have the java servlet
the java servlet specifications define
how you can manage http request either
in a synchronous or asynchronous way
so followed by java transaction api
which is one of the enterprise
specifications we will move ahead into
the java web specifications
so the first one in the java web
specification is the java servlet
so this specification defines how you
can manage the http request either in a
synchronous or asynchronous way it is
low level and other specifications
completely depend on it
so followed by java servlet we have the
java web socket
so the java web socket is a computer
communication protocol and this api
provides a set of apis to facilitate web
socket connections
followed by websocket we have the java
server faces
so the java server faces is a service
which helps in building graphical user
interface out of the components so
followed by java server faces we have
the unified expression language the
unified expression language is a simple
language which was designed to
facilitate web application developers so
followed by the web specification now we
will enter the web server specification
out of which we have the first one which
is the restful web service so the java
restful api web service provides
services having representational state
transfer schema
next we have the json processing
java api for json processing is a set of
specifications to manage the information
provided in a json format followed by
json processing we have json binding so
the java api for json binding is a set
of specifications that provide for
binding or passing a json file into java
classes
next we have the xml binding so xml
binding simply allows for binding of xml
into java objects for example soap is an
xml based protocol to access web
services over http this api allows you
to create soap web services so followed
by the web service specifications of
java enterprise edition we finally enter
into the other miscellaneous
specifications of java enterprise
edition
sort of that the first one is the
validation so the validation package
consists of various interfaces and
annotations for declarative validation
support offered by bean validation api
in java followed by validation we have
the patch applications so the batch
applications provide the means to run
long-running background tasks which
involve large volume of data and which
need to be periodically executed
followed by batch applications we have
java enterprise connector architecture
so the java enterprise edition connector
is a java based technological solution
for connecting java service to
enterprise information system so with
this we will enter into our next step
where we will learn the system
requirements to install java enterprise
edition
so the basic requirements to install
java enterprise edition into your local
system are you should be having the java
virtual machine from the standard 6
edition or more followed by that your
local system should be having at least 1
gb of ram capacity
next your system should be having at
least 250 gb rom space available and
finally you should be having the java
development kit installed into your
local system
now next we will understand how to
install java enterprise edition into
your local system
so in short these are the steps you need
to follow to install java enterprise
edition into your local system first you
need to browse into the oracle official
java site then go to java standard
edition development kit followed by that
accept the license terms download the
jdk file run the jdk file as an
administrator in your local system then
set up the java environment i know this
looks a little bit complex but don't
worry i will drop a link in the
description box below which will explain
you in a much detailed way how to
install java into your local system
please check that to have a better
understanding of how to install and set
up java in your local system
so followed by this we will learn the
differences between the java standard
edition and java enterprise edition
so the first difference between the
standard edition and the enterprise
edition is the standard edition provides
basic functionalities like defining
classes and objects whereas java
enterprise edition mainly focuses on
high-end and corporate type of java
applications
the second difference between the both
is java standard edition comes with only
the standard specifications which will
be used by a beginner and similarly on
the other hand java enterprise edition
comes with some advanced specifications
which support web applications and
servlets
the third difference between the both is
the java standard edition comes with
features like class libraries and
deployment environments whereas the java
enterprise edition has structured
application with the clients business
and enterprise layers
the fourth difference between the both
is
the java standard edition is used for
desktop and mobile application
developments whereas on the other hand
the java enterprise edition is used
mainly for development of web
applications
the fifth the difference between the
both is the java standard edition is
preferred and used by beginners and on
the other hand the java enterprise
edition is preferred and used by experts
in java field
the sixth difference between the both is
the java standard edition does not have
authentication whereas on the other hand
there are strict rules and regulations
to be followed when using java
enterprise edition related to
authentication
now let us begin with what is an
exception
so an exception is defined as an event
that arises due to an unexpected input
or logical failure in the program
this may not be considered merely as an
error but it surely does impact the
normal functioning of the program
segment
now these types of exceptions are
resolved by the most efficient mechanism
called exception handling
exception handling is not any rocket
science but a simple mechanism that
drives the compiler to the next
statement by making the compiler
understand that the input obtained or
the malfunction that arise is just an
unexpected or an unnecessary event which
can be ignored by sending the user with
a relevant message about the exception
arrows
for a better understanding let us go
through a small example
so as you can see on our screen we have
typed in a program so according to this
program we are going to access a file
called data.txt from the c drive so this
particular data.txt is not really
existing in the c drive so when we run
this program we will face an exception
that says file is not found so let's try
to run this program and see
so as expected so when we run this
program we get that this particular file
what you're looking for which is
data.txt is not found
or in other words it is not present in
the specified location
so this is how the exceptions work in
java now followed by this we will move
ahead into our next topic where we will
understand the meaning of an error
so what exactly is an error
so here we are trying to learn about the
error just to eliminate the ambiguity
between an exception and an error also
further we will discuss the major
differences between them but now let us
go through the term error first
unlike an exception an error poses a
serious potential threat to the program
or sometimes it is even capable enough
to collapse an entire software
so basically an error is occurred due to
syntax error or some logical error while
coding
so we have a sound understanding of an
exception and an error now let us move
further and learn the differences
between the both
error versus exception
so some of the major differences between
an error and an exception are
an error is classified under unchecked
type whereas on the other hand an
exception is classified under both
checked and unchecked
the next difference is if a program
encounters an error then it turns out to
be completely irrecoverable until the
error is resolved whereas in the case of
an exception
if the program encounters an exception
then the program is easily recoverable
followed by that the third difference is
an error belongs to the package called
java.lang.error
on the other hand an exception belongs
to the class java.lang.exception
the fourth difference says that an error
can be encountered only during the
program's run time whereas on the other
hand an exception can be expected both
during the run time as well as the
compile time
finally we will mention an example for
both an error and an exception
we can consider the input and output
error as an example for error and on the
other hand we can consider divide by
zero exception as an example for
exception
so with the differences discussed we
will now move ahead and have a look at
the exception hierarchy in java
the hierarchy of errors and exceptions
is really simple
there is one root class called the
throwable now the throwable class is
basically inherited from object which
comes from the superior route called
java.lang
now the throwable class is inherited by
two child classes which are none other
than the error and an exception
further an error is inherited by
different types of errors for example
jvm or java virtual machine error memory
error
and also in some cases some of the
errors are caused by the incompatibility
of the ide or the framework which are
you are using
next up is the exception
now the exception is inherited by few
more exceptions which are mentioned as
below the exceptions can be input output
exception sql exception class not found
exception runtime exception and many
more
further the runtime exception is
inherited by some more
which are the automatic exception
number format exception etc
now that we have a good understanding of
the exception hierarchy let us move
ahead and check the differences between
checked and unchecked exceptions
so the first one which is the checked
exceptions
these are really simple exceptions and
can be defined as follows
an exception that pops up during the
compile time is called as the checked
exception
it is not serious and is completely
ignorable
followed by the checked exceptions we
have the unchecked exceptions
on the other hand the unchecked
exceptions are defined as an exception
that pops up during the run time is
called as the unchecked exception
it is considered as serious and is
caused by logical errors
so to understand checked exceptions in a
much better way we shall go through an
example
so this particular example is based on
checked exceptions
so basically we have a text document
called data.txt
in the location documents username users
c drive
so this particular data file has five
lines so we are going to access the
starting three lines of this particular
file and basically when we try to run
this program we will face some of the
major exceptions which are unhandled
exception type input output
and again the same exception
and here
file not sound exception
so these exceptions are errors
so to understand checked exceptions in a
much better way we shall go through an
example
so this particular code segment here is
trying to read a document from c drive
which is data.pxt
so this particular data.txt has five
lines of text so what we are going to do
here is try to type in a for loop and
try to read the first three lines of
this particular document so basically
when we run this program
we will face some of the exceptions
called file not found exception input
output exception and another input
output exception
so we can resolve this particular
program with small modifications to the
program and then if you run this program
then we can find our lines
so the lines in the data dot txt file
were hello welcome to simply learn we
are an e-learning company our
certification is recognized by major
mncs end role and upskill
so this particular example was for
checked exceptions
now
we will also go through an example for
unchecked exceptions to learn it in a
much better way
so this particular example is based on
unchecked exceptions this particular
program is really simple we have an
integer type array and inside that we
have 10 elements which are 1 2 3 four
five six seven eight nine and ten
so what we're going to do is we're going
to access the 11th element of the array
which is not really present so this
should throw an exception
so array index out of bound exception is
one of the example for unchecked
exceptions
so with this we will move ahead into our
next topic
now we know what exactly are checked and
unchecked exceptions moving further we
will slowly dive into the process of
exception handling in the process of
exception handling we have
five major keywords
so we will learn each one of them as
follows
so the first one is try keyword
the try keyword is used to specify the
exception block
in a program when you specifically type
the exception that you might expect to
face in your program then you describe
it using the keyword try
followed by that the solution for that
exception will be defined in the catch
block so the catch block is used to
specify the solution
finally the finally is a keyword which
has the executable code which is
completely mandatory for a program to
execute
followed by finally we have the throw
keyword the throw keyword basically
throws the exception when it is found
during the run time
followed by that we have the throws the
throws keyword is used to declare the
exception so basically this is where you
declare the kind of exception you are
going to expect in your program
sometimes you might
try to type in your user defined
exception or sometimes you might type in
the exception that is default in its way
or in other words it might be system
defined
now that we have a good understanding of
the implementation of the exception
handling in java
let us move further and solve some of
the most frequently faced exceptions in
java
so with this we enter into our seventh
topic which is common exceptions faced
in java
so the first one is the array index out
of bound
so if you try to store a value in an
array or try to access an element in an
array which has an address exceeding the
address maximum location value then this
particular exception is thrown
so to understand this particular
exception let us go through a practical
example
so as you can see on our screen we have
an array of integer data type so we are
going to store the values 10 20 30 40
and 50 in five different locations of
the array which is
0 1 2 3 and four
now we are going to provide the address
of the required element so during that
process we are going to specify
one location which is more than the
maximum location of the array so here
the maximum location of the array is 4
and if we try to provide the location 5
then this program should throw us an
exception
so let's try to run this program and see
the output
so as you can see we have our array here
now
the program is requesting us to provide
the address of the element required so
what if we provide file
so now it should throw an exception
so this exception is the array index out
of bound exception
now let us try to run this program again
and specify the proper address
so for this time let's provide 4 and see
if we get the output
so as you can see at the address
location we have the element 50 as we
have defined here
now our program is running perfectly all
right
now let's move ahead into the next type
of exception
which is none other than our
null pointer exception
if you try to perform an operation on a
null value this particular exception is
thrown
so might be a little ambiguous to
understand this particular exception in
a perfect way let us go through a
practical example
so here on your screen you can see that
we have a program and inside the program
we have a string called sdr which stores
a text called simply
followed by that we have another string
type which stores a null value which is
abc as you can see abc is equals to null
now here we are going to access the
value of abc so here the string abc has
a null value and we are trying to access
it so this particular code segment
should throw an exception called null
pointer exception now let's try to
execute this code
as you can see it has thrown an
exception called the null pointer
exception so whenever in java if you try
to access the null values then the null
pointer exception is wrong
followed by this we have the next type
of the common exception
which is the number format
if you try to store a value with wrong
formatting then this particular
exception is thrown
now to understand this in a much better
way let us try to execute a sample
program
so here on the screen we have a sample
where we are trying to cast a string
into integer so this kind of operation
should throw an exception
so as you can see the program has been
successfully compiled and we have our
exception here which says number format
exception
followed by this we have another most
commonly faced exception which is the
arithmetic expression
if you try to divide a number by 0 this
particular exception is thrown now let
us go through a practical example
now you can see we have a sample program
on our screen where we have two
particular numbers n one is equals to
zero and n two is equals to hundred
so here what we are trying to do is we
are going to divide the number 100 by 0
which is practically not possible so
when we try to execute this particular
program then we should be getting an
exception that says you cannot divide a
number by zero
so there you have your personalized
message which says the divider cannot be
zero try a different number
so this is how the automatic exceptions
work so with this we have come to our
last topic
which is the best practices to be
followed while working with exceptions
in java
so the first one is use exceptions
conservatively
so exceptions have proven that they can
be costly if used recklessly or
unnecessarily
so it's better to use boolean values to
indicate successful implementation of
smaller operations for example if you
specify a particular operation and it
successfully gets executed then you can
just notify the user by specifying a
boolean value which can be 1 or in the
case of failure you can just specify the
number zero
next after that we have
the customized exceptions
it is a very good practice of
customizing your exceptions in the
design time rather than planning them on
the go
so in other words we can consider this
as if you're planning to design a
software then in that particular stage
itself you must also evaluate the kind
of exceptions you might face on the
process of designing
so tomorrow if you completely design a
software and suddenly an exception is
popped in your head then designing or
including that particular exception in
your finished software might be
difficult so it's better you start
planning your exceptions
followed by that we have exception login
keep track of the exceptions and this
process comes handy as the user
understands why exactly a particular
exception has popped up
followed by that we have early through
and early fail an exception should be
thrown as early as possible and should
be resolved in the same pace
and then we have the closing resources
since exceptions halt the complete
program we must make sure that the
system resources are shut so as to save
the resources
what exactly is a java collection
a java collection can be generally
defined as a collective unit of objects
in the form of a group
for example a group of numbers of
integer data type etc moving forward we
enter into our next topic where we face
the java collections framework this will
help us understand java collections in a
little more detailed way
a java collection framework represents a
unified architecture for storing and
manipulating a group of objects its
architecture includes the following
an interface a class and the java
collections api
to understand these in a much better way
we shall now go through the java
collections hierarchy the utility
package java.util contains all the
classes and interfaces that are required
by a collection framework
the collection framework contains an
interface named as an iterable interface
which provides the iterator to iterate
through all the collections
this interface can be extended by the
main collection interface
which acts as the root for the
collection framework
all the collections extend this
collection interface thereby extending
the properties of the iterator and the
methods of this interface
the following figure illustrates the
hierarchy of collection framework out of
the complexities we have the interface
and the classes as the major part of the
collections
now let us understand each one of them
at one step at a time as you can see on
the screen we have the iterable class
which is implemented by the collection
class and this particular collection
class is further implemented by list
queue and set and moving ahead we have
the following classes which have
implemented the list queue and set
classes in the list we have arraylist
linked list vector stack and on the
other hand on the queue we have priority
queue dq and array dq and finally on the
set we have the hash set
lint hash set sorted set reset etc now
moving further we will enter our first
java collection which is none other than
the interface so the first one is an
interface an interface can have methods
and variables but the methods declared
in an interface are by default abstract
that is
only the method signature is available
not the body
interfaces specify what a class must do
and not how it must do
it is a blueprint of a class now a java
collection is a foundation to the java
collections framework note that all the
collection interfaces are generic for
example public interface collection is
the syntax for the generics and when we
declare the collection we should use it
to specify the type of object which it
can contain
it helps in reducing runtime errors by
type checking the objects at compile
time to keep the number of core
collections interface manageable the
java platform doesn't provide separate
interfaces for each variant of each
collection type if an unsupported
operation is invoked a collection
implementation throws an unsupported
operation exception
now under the collection interface we
have many interfaces that we should use
for data manipulation
a few of the major ones are set
interface list interface dq interface q
interface map interface sorted set
interface
sorted map interface
no worry those are a lot of interfaces
but we will discuss each one of them in
a detailed way along with a practical
example for a better understanding
so the first one in the docket is the
set interface
a set is a collection that cannot
contain any duplicate elements
this interface model is the mathematical
set abstraction and is used to represent
sets such as a deck of cards
the java platform contains three general
purpose set implementations
the hash set tree set and
linked hash set the set interface does
not allow random access to an element in
the collection you can use an iterator
for each loop to traverse elements of a
set
now for a better understanding let us go
through a practical example i have
prepared a code document for all the
programs that i am going to explain to
just save time
you can always have access to it all you
need to do is just ask for it in the
comment section below so you can see on
my screen we have an example for set
interface
in this particular example we are going
to store the elements 21 23 43
53 22 and 65
so let's try to execute this program and
see the output
so you can see the elements stored in
the set interface are 65 21 53 22 and 23
so the sorted set is here which is the
21 22 23 43 53 and 65 and the first
element being 21 and the last element
being 65
so this is how the set interface
practically works now let's move ahead
into our next type of interface which is
none other than the list interface so
what exactly is a list interface the
list interface is an ordered collection
that can contain duplicate elements you
can access any element from its index
the list is more likely an
array with dynamic length the list is
one of the most used collection types
and array list and linked list are the
implementation classes of the list
interface
the list interface provides useful
methods to add an element at a specific
index to remove and replace elements
based on the index and to get a sub list
using the index
for a better understanding let's check
out an example
so this particular program is based on
list interface so we are going to add in
three names which are david john and
stacy into our list and also we have a
fourth edition
which is stacy again
just to check if the statement is true
it says list interface also allows
duplicate elements unlike the set
interface
so let's try to run this program and see
the output
so you can see the program got
successfully executed and the names
david john and stacy are added into the
list
now let's come back to our program and
remove this comment and try to run again
and check if the fourth element which is
the duplicate of the third stacey will
be added into the list or not so as you
can see the program got successfully
executed and the fourth element which is
stacy the duplication of the first one
got successfully inserted into the list
so this is how the list interface works
now let's move ahead into our next type
of interface which is the queue
interface so what exactly is a queue
interface q is a collection used to hold
multiple elements prior to processing
besides basic collection operations a
queue provides additional insertion
extraction and inspection operations
cues typically but do not necessarily
order elements in the fifo or first in
first out manner
among the exceptions are priority queues
which order elements according to a
supplied comparator
or the elements in natural ordering
whatever the ordering used the head of
the queue is the element that would be
removed by a call to remove or poll in a
first and first out queue
all new elements are inserted at the
tail of the cube
now for a better understanding let's go
through a practical example
so as you can see the program on my
screen is an example for q interface
so in this particular queue we are going
to store the names of fruits apple mango
grapes and banana and apple being the
head of the cube and banana being the
tail of the cube
now let's try to execute this program
and see the output so we are also going
to count the size of the queue which is
four basically in the first after that
we are going to remove the element
grapes from the queue
so the command is q dot remove the
element name so after that the grapes
element has been removed from our queue
we have the latest size of the queue as
three
now after that we are also going to
check if the element apple is included
in the queue or not
so for that statement
yes the element apple is included in the
queue and the result is true so this is
how the queues work and let's move
further and in the next phase we have
the dq interface
so what exactly is a dq interface
so a linear collection that supports
element insertion and removal at both
the ends is called as a dq interface
the name dq is short for double ended q
and is usually pronounced as dec most dq
implementations place no fixed limits on
the number of elements they may contain
but this interface supports capacity
restricted dqs as well as those with no
fixed size limit this interface defines
methods to access the elements at both
the ends of the dq
methods are provided to insert remove
and examine the element for a better
understanding let's check out an example
so you can see on my screen we have a
program for dq interface so here we are
going to add in some elements into our
dq and then also try to remove the first
element and print the updated dq now
let's try to execute this program and
see the output
so as you can see
the program got successfully executed
and the elements which we try to push
into the dq
52 10 and 21
52 is being the first element and the 21
is being the last element so we try to
remove the first element which is the 52
so after that the updated dequeue is
having two elements which are 10 and 21
so this is how the queues work now let's
move ahead and learn our next type of
interface which is the map interface so
what exactly is a map interface
a java map is an object that maps keys
along with its values a map cannot
contain duplicate keys each key
can map to at most one value
the java platform contains three general
purpose map implementations
which are the hash map tree map and
linked hash map
the basic operations of a map are
contains key contains value size and is
empty for a better understanding let us
check out an example so this particular
example on my screen is an example
for map interface here we are going to
add three elements and map them as one
as cricket two as hockey and three as
archery
now let us execute this program and see
the output
so you can see the program got
successfully executed and the elements
are
mapped with their keys and the element
cricket is mapped with the key one and
similarly hockey with k2 and r3 with k3
so this is how the map interfaces work
now let's move further into our next
type of interface which is the sorted
set interface
so what exactly is a sorted set
interface so a sorted set is a set that
maintains its elements in ascending
order
several additional operations are
provided to take advantage of the
ordering
sorted sets are usually used for
naturally ordered sets such as word list
and membership roles
for a better understanding let's check
out an example based on sorted set
interface
so you can see
the program on my screen is an example
for sorted set interface
so here we are going to add in bob sean
and jennifer into our set and we are
going to print the same
let's try to execute this program and
see the output
so you can see the program was
successfully executed and we have our
elements printed in the sorted set and
you can see the
names are been arranged in the form of
ascending order according to the
alphabets which have started in the
first position so this is exactly how
the sort set interface works
so the last one in the interfaces is the
sorted map interface a map that
maintains its mapping in an ascendant
key order
this is the map analog of sorted set the
certain maps are used for naturally
audited collections of key value pairs
such as dictionaries and telephone
directories
now for a better understanding let's
check out an example based on
map interface or sorted map interface so
you can see the program on my screen is
an example for sorted map interface so
here we are going to add in the elements
john molly aaron and daisy into the map
interface now along with the names we
also have their aggregates which is 76.5
for john 87.3 for molly and 78.2 for
aaron and for daisy we have 73.4 now
finally we're going to fetch the data of
molly which is the aggregate of molly
now let's try to execute this program
and see the output
so you can see the program got
successfully executed and knowledge
aggregate is 87.3
so this is how the map interfaces work
now let's move ahead into our next topic
which is the java collection classes
so now that we have finished the java
collection interfaces let us have a
quick understanding of java interface
methods so the first method is the add
method the add method is used to add an
object to the collection and next is the
ease nt method this method returns to
true if the collection contains no
elements followed by that we have the
clear method and this method is used to
remove all the elements from the
collection
followed by that we have the remove
method this method is used to remove the
given object from the collection if
there are duplicate values then this
method removes the first occurrence of
the object next to the remove method we
have the size method so the size method
is used to return the number of elements
in the collection so after the size
method we have the stream method the
stream method is used to return a
sequential stream
with this collection as its source so
the next method we have is the two array
method
so the two array method is used to
return an array containing all the
elements in this collection
followed by that we have the hashcode
method this method is used to return the
hashcode value for this collection
next
the equals method
the equals method is used to compare the
specified object with the remaining
elements in the collection followed by
that we have the iterator method so the
iterator method is used as an iterator
over the elements of the particular
collection and finally we have the
contains method
so the contains method returns true if a
specified element is existing in the
collection and false if it is not
present so with this we finish the
collection interface and collection
interface methods now we will move ahead
into our next topic which is none other
than the java collection classes so what
exactly is a class a class is a user
defined blueprint or prototype from
which objects are created it represents
a set of properties or methods that are
common to all the objects of one type
now we'll start up with the first one
which is the hash set class so the java
hash set is the basic implementation of
the set interface that is backed up by
the hashmap it makes no guarantee for
the iteration order
of the set and permits null elements as
well
so this class offers constant time
performance for basic operations such as
add remove contains and size assuming
the hash function
disperses the elements properly among
the buckets we can set the initial
capacity and load factor for this
collection
the load factor is a measure of how full
the hashmap is allowed to get before its
capacity is automatically increased for
a better understanding let's go through
an example
so on my screen you can see a program
which is an example for hash set classes
so inside this we are going to store
some names which are the names of the
manufacturers of bikes along with null
values
so we have added in two null values to
just check if it allows two null values
at once
so basically it only should allow one
null value so let's check out how does
it perform
so you can see the program was
successfully executed and the null value
is stored only once that too in the
first location
so this is how the hash set classes work
moving further we will deal with the
next type of class which is the tree set
class
so a tree set class is a navigable set
implementation based on a tree map the
elements are ordered using their natural
ordering or by a comparator provided at
set creation time depending on which
constructor is being used this
implementation provides guaranteed log
stein cost for the basic operations such
as add remove and contains
note that the ordering maintained by a
set whether or not an explicit
comparator is provided must be
consistent with equals if it is to
correctly implement the set interface
now to understand in a much better way
let us go through an example now we are
going to add in some numbers into the
tree set using the add method now let's
execute this code and see the output
so you can see the numbers are added
into the tree set and the numbers are
ordered in ascending order
which is 0 18 88 748
983 8476
now let's move further into our next
type of class
which is
the arraylist class
so add a list in java is a resizable
array that is an implementation of list
interface that allows null elements so
in this class we have three types of
arrays which are one-dimensional arrays
two-dimensional arrays and
three-dimensional arrays now let's check
out the one-dimensional array
so
a one-dimensional array looks similar to
this where we have the array index
and the element present in the array so
here our indexes are a0 1 2 3 and 4 and
the elements which are shown here to
understand one-dimensional arrays in a
much better way let's go through a
sample program
so you can see the program written on my
screen is an example for one dimensional
array and we are going to store the
elements 10 20 and 30 into my array a
so you can see the program has been
successfully executed and the elements
have been added into my one-dimensional
array
moving further we will discuss the
two-dimensional arrays the
two-dimensional arrays are completely
similar to one-dimensional array but the
only difference is the index numbers
earlier we had index number but now we
have index numbers
now using these index numbers we can
represent the elements in a matrix form
so to understand this in a much better
way let's go through a sample code
so you can see this particular program
in my screen is an example for
two-dimensional arrays so here we are
going to add in elements one two three
and four in the matrix form and we are
going to use two for loops to print that
now let's execute this program and see
the output
so you can see we have the elements 1 2
3 and 4 and the elements are printed in
the matrix form
at the array index location zero zero we
have one zero one we have two and one
zero we have three and one one we have
four so this is how the two dimensional
arrays work and finally let's deal with
the third type of array which is the
multi-dimensional or three-dimensional
array
so you can see the three-dimensional
array is completely similar or a little
bit similar to the two-dimensional array
but the only difference is we have a
third vector here
so next up we have the linked list
linked list also come under java
collection classes
there are three types of linked lists
which are single linked list doubly
linked list and circular linked list
now let's check out each one of those so
the first one is the singly linked list
so you can see in a singly linked list
each memory segment is divided into two
parts so the first half of the memory
location is given for the element and
the second half of the memory location
is dedicated for the address so this
particular address is used to point to
the next element or the next memory
allocation which stores the second
element similarly the third so this is
how the singly linked list works so the
last memory allocation is called as tale
and the last address will not store
nothing but null which indicates the end
of the singly linked list
now to understand single linked list in
a much better way let's try to execute a
sample program
so you can see the program on my screen
is an example for singly linked list now
we are going to add in the elements one
two three and four in the form of a
singly linked list now let's try to
execute this program and see the output
so you can see the program got
successfully executed and the elements
are one two three and four now let's
move further and try to learn the next
type of linked list which is the doubly
linked list
so the doubly linked list is completely
similar to that of the singly linked
list but the only difference is we have
two address locations so the first
address location of the head stores null
and the last address location of the
tail stores null which
indicate the start and end of the doubly
linked list respectively
so here in the second memory location
you have two addresses so the first
address points to the previous element
and the next address points to the next
element so to understand doubly linked
lists in a much better way let's try to
execute a sample program
so as you can see the program on my
screen is an example for doubly linked
list and we have the node which has the
data and previous address next address
now let's try to execute this program
and see the output and the elements that
we are going to store in this particular
doubly linked list are one two three
four and five
so as you can see the program got
successfully executed and the notes are
one two three and four and five
so this is how the doubly linked list
work and now let's check out the third
type of linked list which is the
circular linked list so there are
similarities between the previous linked
list and the circular linked list
so the circular linked list makes it
circular based on the last address
location
so this particular address location
points to the first element back again
so this is how it becomes a circular
linked list so to understand this in a
much better way let's check out an
example for it
so you can see
the program on my screen is an example
for circular linked list
now let's try to execute this and see
the output so you can see we have
successfully included one two three four
five six and seven and eight into our
circular linked list and they are
printed on the screen so this is how the
circular linked list work so moving
further we will try to understand the
next type of classes in java collections
which is the hashmap class so hash table
is based on the implementation of map
interface
this implementation provides all the
optional
map operations and permits null values
and the null key hash map class is
roughly equivalent to hash table except
that it is unsynchronized and permits
null this class makes no guarantee for
the order of the map now for a better
understanding let's go through a sample
program
so this particular
program on my screen is an example for
hashmap class so here we are trying to
load the data which is the name of the
manufacturer and their bike so let's
execute this program and see the output
so you can see the program got
successfully executed and we have the
manufacturer and their mate bikes now
moving further we will deal with the
next type of class in java collection
which is the tree map class so the tree
map is based on navigable map
implementation the map is sorted
according to the natural ordering of its
case or by a comparator provided at map
creation time
depending on the constructor used
now let's check out an example for
better understanding
so you can see the program written on my
screen is an example for tree map class
so we have the roll numbers and the
names of students here now let's try to
execute this program and see the output
so the program got successfully executed
and the result has been printed on the
output console
so we have the role numbers of the
students and their names amber
james wallet and reynolds along with
their respective ids
so now with this we complete the java
collections classes now we move into our
next topic which is the collection api
algorithms
so the first one is sorting
sorting does the job of ascending and
descending numbers based on the
algorithm written by the user for a
simple example we shall consider the
bubble sort algorithm for this one so
you can see on my screen we have an
example for bubble sort algorithm so we
have the elements 289 39 48 6 28 1 2 and
33 which are ordered in
an orderly manner let's try to execute
this program and order them
so you can see array before bubble sort
is 289 38 48 similarly 33 and after the
bubble sort we have the sorted array
which is 1 2 6 28 33 39 48 and 289 so
this is how the bubble sort works now
let's move further and understand the
next type of api which is the shuffling
algorithm so the shuffling algorithms
are designed to destroy the current
arrangements they are employed on
creating randomness in the list so for a
better understanding let's check out an
example
so you can see the program written on my
screen is an example for shuffle
algorithm so we have an array which has
the elements completely sorted in
ascending order which is 10 to 100.
now when we run the shuffle algorithm
these elements will be completely
shuffled according to a random order now
let's try to execute this program and
see the output so you can see the
elements which were in an ascending
order are now completely in disorder so
this is how the shuffling algorithm
works now let's move further and
understand the next type of algorithm
which is the searching algorithm
searching algorithm is employed to
search an element in the list or array
based on the type of searching mechanism
used now for example let's use the
binary search
now you can see a program on my screen
which is an example for binary search so
we have the elements 1 2 3 4 and 5 in
our array now what we are going to do is
search for the element or the key
element 2 in our array using the binary
search algorithm
now let's execute this program and see
the output now you can see the program
got successfully executed and the output
says the element which you're looking
for is found in the index location one
so this is how the binary search
algorithm works now let's move further
and understand the next type of
algorithm which is the composition
algorithm so the definition says the
frequency and disjoint algorithms test
some aspect of composition of one or
more collections so the frequency counts
the number of times the specified
element occurs in the specified
collection
so the disjoint determines whether two
collections are disjoint that is whether
they contain no element in common or not
now to understand it in a much better
way let's go through an example so you
can see on my screen there is an example
for composition
now let's run this program and see the
output
so you can see the program was
successfully executed and
the elements are completely disjoint now
moving further we will enter into our
next topic which is based on the
benefits of
java collections so there are various
benefits of java collections out of
those the major benefits are software or
code reusability so the java collections
enable code reusability to save time
followed by that the ease of designing
apis so the next two ease of designing
apis we have the simplicity in learning
and using apis and finally increased
speed in programming
so these were the major benefits of java
collections what exactly is a servlet
now imagine you are searching for some
information on the internet
you open your local browser and start
typing it this question from you to the
internet is called as request
so further this request is sent to the
cloud or in technical terms your browser
sends your request to the respective
server responsible for storing for that
particular information and helps you
with it when requested now the server
gets triggered with your request and in
written it helps you back with the
information you have requested for this
answer from the server is called the
response
so this is how the request and response
work in a server for this process to
happen so smoothly and effectively we
need a servlet digging a little deep
into the server we find the component
responsible for such an effective job it
is called the servlet container that
holds java based web application and a
set of individual components called as
servlets now we are close to our answer
so this particular java based component
takes care of web requests and response
to sum it up with the form of a
definition
we can define it as follows
a servlet is a java program that runs on
the java enabled web server or
application server
they are used to handle the request
obtained from the web server process the
request produce the response and then
send a response back to the web server
now hoping that it was a clear
explanation can we move ahead with the
next topic
so the next topic we have is
so how does the servlet work in reality
or more practically or in depth what's
the life cycle of a servlet
so the life cycle of a servlet in real
time has the following stages
these stages are the ones that a java
servlet actually follows in real life to
get our work done so the stages are in
it service
and
the crud operations which are the get
post put delete and finally
destroy now let us understand each one
of them in a bit more detail
the first one is the init process
the init method is called only once it
is called only when the servlet is
created and not for all the requests
afterwards so it is used for the
one-time initializations just as with
the init method of applets the servlet
is normally created when a user first
invokes a url corresponding to the
servlet but you can also specify the
servlet is loaded when the server first
started when a user invokes a servlet a
single instance of each servlet gets
created with each user request resulting
in a new thread that is handed over to
the do get or do post as appropriate
the init method simply creates or loads
some data that will be used throughout
the lifecycle of a servlet followed by
the init method we have the service
method
so what is service method
surface method is the main method to
perform the actual task the servlet
container that is the web server calls
the service method to handle request
from the client or the browser and to
write the formatted response back to the
client each time the server receives a
request from the servlet the server
spawns a new thread and calls service
the service method checks the http
service type and accordingly performs
the crud operations which are the get
post put delete etc and calls do get do
post do put do delete etc methods as
appropriate
the service method is called by the
container and service method invokes do
get do post do put and do delete etc
methods as appropriate so you have
nothing to do with service method but
you overwrite either with do get do post
and other types depending on what type
of request you receive from the client
so this is how the init and service
methods work now digging a little deeper
we have the do get do post do delete and
do put methods
so first we will discuss about do get
method so what exactly does a do get
method do a get request results from a
normal request from a url or an html
form that has no method specified and it
should be hardly by do get method
followed by doget we have do post
a do post request results from a html
form that specifies list post as the
method and it should be handled by do
post method similar to to get and do
post the do put and do delete options
are usually used to update and delete
the data
when asked by the client
so to sum up these do get do post do put
do delete we can consider them as crud
operations so do get basically gets the
information what you're looking for do
post method usually post the information
or provides you with the response from
the server and followed by that we have
the do put which is usually used to
update the data which is present on your
server and finally delete which is used
to delete an existing data on your
server so this can be considered as crud
operations
and finally we arrive at the last method
which is the destroy method the destroy
method is called only once at the end of
the life cycle of a servlet this method
gives your servlet a chance to close
database connections halt background
threads right cookie list or hit
accounts to the disk and performs other
such cleanup activities
so with this we finish up the lifecycle
of a servlet now we shall understand its
architecture
basically the architecture of a servlet
can be understood by reverse engineering
the life cycle of a servlet so this is
how the servlet execution takes place
when a client or a browser makes a
request to the web browser
so the servlet architecture includes the
following first one servlet interface
to write a servlet we need to implement
the servlet interface servlet interface
can be implemented directly or
indirectly by extending generic servlet
or http servlet class
followed by that the next part is
request handling methods as we have
discussed before there are mainly three
methods defined in servlet interface
which are init
service and destroy and inside service
we have do put do post do get and do
delete methods the first time a servlet
is invoked the init method is called it
is called only once during the life
cycle of a servlet so we can put all
your initialization code here the
service method is used for handling the
client request as the client request
reaches the container it creates a
thread of servlet object and request and
response object are also created
these request and response objects are
then passed as parameter to the service
method which then processes the client
request the service method in turn calls
the do get do post methods if the user
has extended the class from http servlet
and lastly the creation of instances
this is based on the load of the servlet
so with this we have finished the
architecture of servlet moving further
we shall quickly discuss the features of
servlets and then enter into the
practical mode
so the following are the features of
java servlets the first feature is java
servlets are portable in nature as i
have mentioned above the servlets use
java as programming language
since java is a platform independent
programming language the same holds true
for servlets for example you can create
a servlet on windows operating system
that uses glassfish as a web server and
then later run it on any operating
system like unix linux and apache tomcat
web server this feature makes tablet
portable and this is the main advantage
of servlet over cgi we shall discuss all
the differences of cgi versus servlet in
the next section for now we will discuss
the features followed by the first
feature we will now enter into the
second feature which says java servlets
are efficient and scalable once a server
is deployed and loaded onto a web server
it can instantly start fulfilling the
request of the clients
the web server invokes servlet using
lightweight thread so multiple client
requests can be fulfilled by servlet at
the same time using the multi-threading
feature of java
compared to cgi where the server has to
initiate a new process for every client
request the servlet is truly efficient
and scalable the next and the final
feature of java servlets is they are
robust and highly secure by inheriting
the top features of java such as garbage
collector exception handling java
security manager etc the servlet is less
prone to memory management issues and
memory leaks
this makes the development of web
applications and servlets secure and
less error prone so these were the
important features of java servlets now
let us enter the practical mode
so we are in the practical mode right
now there were two parts in the
practical mode the first one was to set
up the environment for java servlets and
the second one was to execute a basic
program
so this document has the following steps
to follow
that is the prerequisites before
executing a java servlet program
so we have these prerequisites where we
have to set up java home
and java path followed by that we need
to set up the home and path for jre
which is the java runtime environment
and finally catalina home and path so
catalina home and path is nothing but
the tomcat server home and path
now we will set up these things by using
the environment variables now i'm using
a windows operating system so i'll be
using the control panel to enter the
environment variables
there you go you have edit environment
variables
so inside that just select environment
variables and inside this you can see
that i have already set up the
environment variables for catalina home
java home and jre home so now let us
just select java home and edit it so
that we can see how did i set it
so you can see i have named the variable
name as java home and inside the
variable value i have a location so this
location is nothing but the java jdk
location in my local system
now followed by that we have jre home so
similar to java whom we have set up the
jre home as variable name is equals to
jre home
and the variable value is the location
of gre folder in my local system so i
have my jre folder in my local system at
c drive program files java jre
and similarly the catalina home which is
inside my program files apache software
foundation and tomcat 8.5
so similarly we'll also check up the
path variables so inside system
variables you can see the path just
edited so then you can see the path
variable set for
java
jre and tomcat
now just select ok
ok and finally another ok
now your prerequisites have been set up
so this is how you set them so in case
if you have doubts about the tomcat
version to download then i'll help you
with that just open google
and type in tomcat download
so now you have entered apache tomcat
official site and since i'm using a
windows operating system i'll be
selecting the 32-bit or 64-bit windows
service installer version
and after this gets downloaded you need
to set up the home and path variables
for catalina server
so once after the environment is set up
you need to follow four stages to create
a servlet program which are creating a
dynamic web project create a servlet add
servlet api jar file and run the servlet
so to create a dynamic web project you
need to select new and inside that you
have
the option of other just select other
and inside that you'll be finding web
so select web and inside that you need
to select the dynamic web project and
select next
so you just need to name to your dynamic
web project so i'll be
naming a server
then select next
and inside that you have a source folder
and now you can select finish
now there you go java eclipse will ask
you for opening this particular in java
ee perspective
then just select open perspective
now basically java will set up
everything you need here
and there you go you can see
server folder here which has already set
up everything you need
now what you need to do is set up a new
servlet so right click this
and select new
and inside that you can see the option
of servlet just select it
now you can see a new dialog box and
here you need to set up the class name
for now let's just type in hello and go
to next
now again next
and in here you have a lot of options
so for now we are just executing a basic
program so let's just select do get
method
now let's just finish it and there you
go your servlet has been ready so this
is the basic template created by eclipse
for you now next we need to add in the
build path so for that you need to right
click the server
and then
select build path
and here configure build path
from here you can add the external
library select the external libraries
option and you can see i have the tomcat
libraries here just select all and open
and that's how you add all the required
libraries of tomcat server now apply and
close
now the last step is to execute the
project now just to save time i have
already typed in the program
which is over here
now let's try to execute this
this program will just provide us a
simple output which is none other than
hello world
now the server i have choose this tomcat
server
let's finish it
so there you go the message has been
displayed successfully hello welcome to
simply learn
now we'll move ahead with our next topic
now that we are done with the
environment setup and the basic example
let us now discuss the advantages and
disadvantages of using java servlets
so first we will discuss the advantages
the following are the advantages of
using servlets in java
servlet is convenient in modifying
regular html
we can write the servlet code into jsp
so let's include the feature of
multi-threading of java
we can make use of exception handling of
java
servlets have a separate layer for
business logic in the application and
finally it is easy for developers to
show and process the information so
these were the advantages of using
servlets in java moving ahead we will
discuss the disadvantages of using
servlets
so following are the disadvantages of
using servlets in java
designing a servlet is considered as a
little complicated
so let's often slow down the application
business logic of servlet is difficult
to understand we need a jre which is the
java runtime environment on the server
to run our servlets and finally the data
connectivity is a little complicated so
these were the major disadvantages of
using servlets and java
moving ahead we will understand cgi why
are we learning cgi because even cgi is
similar to servlets and it also does the
web interactive job similar to servlets
so thought you should know about some
basics of it so let's understand its
definition and architecture real quick
so the cgi or common gateway interface
is a standard for writing programs that
can interact through a web server with a
client running on web browser these
programs allow a web developer to
deliver dynamic information usually in
the form of an html via the browser a
cgi program can be written in any
language including java that can be
executed by your web server cgi programs
are commonly used to add search engines
guest book applications database query
engines interactive user forums and
other interactive applications to
websites in very basic terms a cgi
program must interpret the information
sent to it process the information in
the same way and generate response that
will be sent back to the client
most of the input of cgi program is
passed into through environment
variables so with this we will move
ahead into the architecture of common
gateway interface
so you can see the architecture of
common gateway interface is completely
similar to servlet normally the request
is sent in the form of an http request
so this particular http request is
divided amongst the cgi shells and it
will be processed by the cgi shells
based on the program provided and the
response is sent to the user now moving
ahead we shall understand the
differences between the common gateway
interfaces and
the servlet so the first difference is
the common gateway interface scripts are
executable codes written in native
operating system while on the other hand
the servlets are written and run using
the java virtual machine
the next difference is the common
gateway interface performance is
considered to be low compared to
servlets on the other hand servlets are
having high performance compared to
cgi's
the third difference is
for a common gateway interface it is
hard to switch between different
platforms that is the operating system
platforms
when we come into servlets the servers
are considered to be completely platform
independent
followed by that the common gateway
interface scripts are directly executed
so on the other hand servlets are
translated into bytecode because the
servlets are executed using the java
virtual machine and in java virtual
machine whatever the code you transfer
it will be converted into bytecode first
then executed and the last difference is
the common gateway interface is not
portable and on the other hand we have
the java servlets to be completely
portable so these are the major
differences between the common gateway
interface and java servlets now let us
understand the java servlets requests
and responses so first we will deal with
the request phase in request we have
various types the first one is being the
http request the http object is used to
represent the http request to a browser
that the user sends to the web
application thus anything the browser
sends is accessible through the http
request followed by the http request we
have the request parameter
the request parameters are the
parameters that are sent from the web
browser along with the request the
request parameters are typically sent as
a part of the url or as a part of the
body of an http request followed by the
request parameter we have the request
header the request headers are the name
value pairs sent by the browser along
with the http request the request
headers contain the information about
the web browser software being used what
type of files that the web browser can
receive etc followed by the request
header we have the input stream if the
browser sends an http post request
request parameters and other potential
data is sent to the server in the http
request body it doesn't have the request
parameters that is sent in http request
body it could be pretty much as the data
like file or soap request the next one
is a request session the session object
can hold information about a given user
between the request so if you have set
an object into the session object during
one request it will be available for you
to read during any subsequent request
within the same session time scope
followed by the request session we have
the servlet context the servlet context
contains the metadata related to the
application followed by servlet context
we will enter the response phase in the
response phase we will deal with the
first one which is the http response the
http response object is used to
represent the http response to your
request a web application sends back a
response page to the user as a response
to the http request from the browser
sent to your web application
followed by the http response we have
the write html to initiate the process
of sending the html back to the browser
you need to retrieve the print writer
from the http response object this can
be done using the right html followed by
the right html we have the response
header similar to http request the http
response includes headers as well these
are responsible for all the data written
in the response followed by response
header we have content type the content
type header is responsible to tell the
browser about the type of content you
are sending in the return
followed by content type we have the
content length the content length header
is responsible for telling you about the
number of bytes your server is sending
you in return followed by content length
we have redirection redirecting will
help you to redirect yourself to the
different web page from the current one
so these were the http requests and
responses in java servlets now we will
enter the next part where we will deal
with the session tracking and cookies so
first we will understand session
tracking session simply means a
particular time of interval session
tracking is a way to maintain state or
data belonging to a user it is also
known as session management and servlets
http protocol is stateless so we need to
maintain state using session tracking
techniques each time the user requests
to the server the server reads the
request as a new request so we need to
maintain the state of a user to
recognize a particular user you can
understand this in a better way by
looking at the picture showed on the
presentation each time you send a
request you will be receiving a response
from the server as well as this
particular request will be recorded as a
state in order to recognize you as a
particular user now after session
tracking we will enter into cookies
cookie is a small piece of information
that is persisted between multiple
client requests a cookie has a name a
single value and optional attributes
such as comment path and domain
qualifiers a maximum age and a version
number by default each request is
considered as a new request in cookie
technique we add a cookie with response
from the servlet so cookie is stored in
cache of a browser after that if the
request is sent by the user the cookie
is added with a request by default thus
we recognize the user as an old user
there are two types of cookies they are
non-persistent cookie and persistent
cooking let's understand non-persistent
cookie first a non-persistent cookie is
valid for a single session only it is
removed each time when the user closes
the browser
now let us understand the persistent
cookie the persistent cookie is valid
for multiple sessions it is not removed
each time when the user closes the
browser it is only removed when the user
logs out or signs out from the browser
what exactly is zam
well zam is a one-stop open-source
cross-platform solution for multiple
needs in general it is considered as a
bundle of software utilities that
include an apache server mysql database
support for php and support for perl
this simple and lightweight solution
works on windows linux and mac hence the
cross platform part
now that we have a quick briefing about
xampp let us get started with the
installation procedure
so installing xampp is really simple all
you need to do is just google download
samp and you'll see the first link and
just click onto it which will redirect
you into the apache website here you can
see multiple varieties of samp the first
one is for windows second is for linux
and the third one is for mac
now we will select the windows version
so here we have the 7.2 version 7.3 and
7.4 so i would suggest you to go with
the latest version that is the 7.4
you just need to click on the download
button and there you go
you can see on the bottom left corner
that your software is getting downloaded
now this might take a while so i have
downloaded it on my local system
previously so let's get back to that and
start our installation procedure just to
save time
so i might want to cancel this
so let's get back to the download
section and there you go you can see the
zamp software which is downloaded here
so all you need to do is just run it
so just provide the permission yes
ignore this warning and just select ok
you can start the visit by clicking next
so here you can see multiple options for
server programming languages etc so you
have the varieties of servers such as
apache mysql filezilla etc tomcat you
never know which one you might need in
the future so i would suggest you to
just select all
and same goes for the programming
languages
just select next
so now you can see the next dialog box
where you're asked to select the
location for your software
so it would be better if you select the
default location that is c drive
just select next
and here you're asked to select the
different languages for your control
panel
so
let us select english
english is a default option here now
let's click next
again and next
and now your software is ready to get
installed
no worry about this new web page which
has popped up in your screen
now let's get back to our setup file
now let's just select next to start with
the installation
and there you go you can see that xampp
is getting installed into your local
system
now this might take up a little while
all we need to do is just wait
anytime now the installation will be
finished
so there you go the installation is
completely finished now you can just
click on the finish button and the
process will be finished
and there you go you can see your samp
control panel on your screen let's
maximize this for a better view
yeah that's good now you can see the
modules on your control panel which are
the apache server mysql database
filezilla server mercury server tomcat
server
you can start any one of these let's get
started with apache first to start that
all you need to do is just select the
start button
and you can see the apache has just got
started
and you can see the first one was
attempting the apache app to get started
and then you can see the apache app
status change to running now you can see
the process ids of apache server as well
as the port number which is 80. now you
have an option of configuring your port
numbers
because what if in future you may need
to start tomcat and apache server
parallely but in different port numbers
so
to make sure that they don't interfere
with each other you can configure them
on different port numbers to do so all
you need to do is just open config
and inside config choose the first
option that is apache httpd.conf
just scroll to the bottom
and now you can see the port number here
so just
let us change it to 3000
similarly here
and now select the file option and save
it
now let's try to restart our apache
server stop it
and then again restart it
and there you go you can see the change
of the port number to 3000 and the
process ids which are 9620 and 9868
so this is how you install xam server
and this is the complete procedure to
install xampp server into your windows
operating system
what is a lambda expression
now lambda expressions were not there
along with java since the beginning
there were an update to java since its
eighth version
lambda expressions are basically an
advanced method of writing methods to be
simple
these lambda expressions can be used
inside a previously written method this
approach reduces the code length and
improvises performance to a greater
extent
so we can define it as follows
a lambda expression is a short block of
code that takes in parameters and
returns a value
lambda expressions are similar to
methods but they do not need a name and
they can be implemented right inside the
body of any method now your very first
question is we had methods then why do
we need a lambda expression that could
replace the conventional method
so that's exactly where we understand
the need for lambda expressions
now lambda expressions are having some
impeccable features they are capable of
converting huge block of code into a
tiny argument now how cool is that now
coming back into methods
when we need to create a method we need
to make sure that it belongs to a
certain class no matter that we can
create a method without having to belong
to any class but that would be just
excess lines of codes lying in your
project
but when it comes to lambda expressions
a lambda function can be created without
belonging to any class
and finally
land by expressions can be passed around
as if it was an object and can be
executed on demand
now how do they work and what is the
functional interface these will be the
next questions before that we shall
understand the syntax of lambda
expressions
then slowly we will move ahead into the
functional interface
so followed by the need of lambda
expressions we enter the syntax of
lambda expressions
now the syntax of lambda expressions is
something which is shown on the screen
right now
now you might be wondering if lambda
expressions have three different
syntaxes no it's actually based on the
number of parameters we use
so the first syntax belongs to the first
type where we have absolutely zero
parameters
the second one is preferred when we had
one single parameter and the last one
is preferred when we had multiple
parameters
now do not worry about the number of
parameters used we shall execute
examples based on each and every type of
them to have a better understanding of
each type
now we enter the most important topic of
today's discussion which is the
functional interface
in lambda expressions functional
interface serves as a data type for the
lambda expressions
it is represented by the annotation
called
functional interface it mainly consists
of an unimplemented abstract method
and when an interface is represented
using functional interface annotation or
basically a functional interface can
never have more than
one unimplemented abstract method inside
it if you try to declare more than one
then automatically we will face a
compiler error so the functional
interface can be defined as follows a
functional interface in java is an
interface that contains only a single
unimplemented abstract method
a functional interface can contain
default and static methods which do not
have an implementation in addition to a
single unimplemented method
now that we have a theoretical
understanding of a functional interface
let us get into the practical mode where
we will try to execute some different
examples based on functional interfaces
and lambda expressions i hope so far
everything was clear now let's begin
with the practical session
now we are in the practical mode and we
are on eclipse now let's quickly create
a project
let's name our project as lambda
just finish it
and done
now we are having a lambda project over
here and this is our source file
now let's quickly create a new package
so by default the name of the package is
same as the name of
project lambda so it's okay not a
problem let's just finish it
now let's create a new class
yeah
so we have our
class here now let's quickly execute the
code
as you can see this particular program
on my screen is an example for a button
click operation so what exactly this
program will do is it'll create a button
on my screen and when i press that
particular button i'll be displaying a
message called hello world welcome to
simply learn on my console so this
particular line on my screen is an
example for lambda expression where we
are trying to execute a printf statement
using the lambda expression syntax now
let's quickly try to execute this
program and see the output
so you can see that i've got the
button over here
on my top left corner of the screen if i
just try to press this button called
click me
i'll be printing a message on my console
which is hello world welcome to simply
learn
let's try that again
yeah that's how it works
now let's stop this button
let's stop this program and continue
with the next example
so this particular example is based on
both functional interface and also the
lambda expression
so you can see this particular code
segment is represented using the
annotation called functional interface
so this is what i was talking about
the functional interface annotation
which represents a code segment that has
only one unimplemented abstract method
now let's try to quickly execute this
program so this particular
code or program is nothing complicated
it's just trying to print the area of a
circle we already have a pi value and
we'll just calculate the value of the
area of the given circle with a certain
radius so the radius will be taken as an
input from this particular code segment
here
now let's quickly try to execute this
so you can see the program got executed
and the console is asking for an input
for radius now let's type in some random
input
let's input 15 as the radius now we
should be getting the area of
the circle with radius 15
so which is around
706.83 units
i did not mention the
units here let's consider as centimeters
so this is the square centimeter area of
the particular circle with radius 15.
now let's continue with the next type of
program now let us try to execute the
next example which is based on
the both function interface and a lambda
expression that has zero parameters so
we discussed this before lambda
expressions are three types with zero
parameters
single parameter and multiple parameters
so this example is based on zero
parameters it doesn't have any
parameters it's just printing one single
message
that is hello world welcome to simply
learn that's all nothing more than that
now after this we'll try to execute
another example which is based on single
parameter now let's quickly run this
program and see the message
so there you go on the console we have
the message hello world welcome to
simply learn
now let's move ahead and try to execute
the next type which is the single
parameter one
so now you can see on my screen we have
another program which is based on
single parameter
so what we're trying to do is here just
we are sending a string of data which is
the name of a city and we are just
running through regex and then we'll
find if the data given is valid or not
so the city name that we are passing
here is new york now let's just quickly
execute this program
and there you go we have the output
the value returned from lambda is true
so the function that is info dot matches
worked perfectly now let's quickly get
into the next type of example where we
have multiple parameters
so as you can see on my screen we have a
small and simple example for multiple
parameters lambda expression so the
multiple parameters that we will be
passing here are the values of x and y
and
these x and y will be multiplicated with
each other so that we'll be getting a
product of these two numbers now we have
the
functional interface which has one
unimplemented method which is the float
multiplication now let's quickly try to
execute this and see the output
so the value is passed by 100 200 and
205 so the respective
product of those two
or
those four numbers has been given here
so the product of 2 and 5 is 10 and the
product of 100 and 200 is to
20 000
so that's how the program for multiple
parameters in a lambda expression work
now let's try to continue with our next
example where we will try to print
multiple elements present in a list or
an array using for each loop
as you can see on my screen we have a
small little simple program which is a
list and inside the list we have a set
of
names of fruits and we're just going to
print these names of this rules using
the for each loop and inside the forage
loop the control will run through a
lambda expression which is simple print
statement
now let's try to quickly
run this program and see the output
so you can see the program would
successfully executed and the names of
the roots have been printed here
now let's try to execute one last
program based on lambda expressions
where we will try to use filter
operation over a collection
so as you can see we have our
last program on my screen so in this
particular program we have three
variables which is the id of the bike
and the manufacturer name and on-road
price of that particular bike so what
we're going to do is we have three
particular variables here which is
yamaha bajaj and hero and the cost of
all the three bikes are different so
what we're going to do is apply the
filter operation and filter out the
bytes
with on dot cost which is greater than
80 000. so this is how it should do now
let's try to quickly run this program
so you can see the program got
successfully executed and the bikes
having price greater than 80 000 i've
been printed on my output console here
so with this let's continue with our
next topic
so let us move ahead and learn the major
differences between the lambda
expressions and the methods
so the first difference between the
lambda expression and the method is the
lambda expression doesn't specifically
need a name but whereas for a method
name is mandatory and the next
difference is lambda expressions may or
may not include parameters we have
already executed an example
based on zero parameters and the third
difference is in a lambda expression it
does not have to return a type but in
the method it specifically needs to have
a return type and the last difference
between the both is lambda expression
includes a body as the main code segment
whereas on the other hand for a method
code body is just another code segment
of the program so these were the major
differences between a lambda expression
and a method let us now enter into the
next part where we will understand the
lambda expressions in the form of an
object
so as discussed in the features before
java lambda expression is essentially an
object you can assign a lambda
expression to a variable and pass it
around just as a normal object
moving ahead we have
variable captures
a java lambda expression is capable of
accessing variable stick lead outside
the lambda function under
certain circumstances
java lambdas can capture the following
variables they are the local variables
instance variables and static variables
each of these variable captures will be
explained as follows first we will
understand the local variables
java lambda can capture the value of
local variable declared outside the
lambda body now look at this lambda
expression that implements java
lambda interface right now this lambda
expression is only referencing to the
parameter value passed to it but we can
change it
as you can see the lambda body now
references local variables str which is
declared outside the lambda body this is
possible if and only if the variable
being referenced is effectively final
meaning it does not change at value
after being assigned if the stl value
had its value changed later then the
compiler would complain about the
reference to it from inside the lambda
body
moving ahead we have the instance
variable capture
a lambda expression can also capture an
instance variable in the object that
creates the lambda here is an example
for that
notice that the reference to this dot
val inside the lambda body
this captures the name of the instance
variable of the enclosing company id
object
it is even possible to change the value
of the instance variable after its
capture and the value will be reflected
inside the lambda
the semantics of this is actually one of
the areas where java landlords differ
from anonymous implementations of
interfaces an anonymous interface
implementation can have its own instance
variables that are referred via this
interface
however a lambda cannot have its own
instance variables so this always points
to the enclosing object
next we have the last type of variable
capture which is the static variable
capture
a lambda expression can also capture the
static variables
the static variables are reachable from
everywhere in java application provided
the static variable is accessible that
is scoped as public
here is an example that creates a lambda
which references the static variable
inside the lambda body the value of a
static variable is also allowed to
change after the lambda has captured it
again the above class design is built
nonsensical
don't think too much about that
the class primarily serves to show you
that the lambda can access static
variables
followed by the variable captures we
have the method references
so method reference is used to refer
method of functional interface it is
compact and easy form of lambda
expression each time when you are using
lambda expressions just to
refer a method you can replace your
lambda expression with a method
reference
so there are three types of method
references available in java lambda
expressions those are reference to a
static method reference to an instance
method reference to a constructor
now with this we shall wind up our
session by our last topic which is the
best practices to be followed by using a
lambda expression
so these are the few best practices to
be followed while using lambda
expressions the first one is prefer
using standard functional interfaces
functional interfaces which are gathered
in
java.util.function package satisfy most
developers needs in providing target
types for lambda expressions and each
method references
each of these interfaces is general and
abstract making them easy to adapt to
almost any lambda expressions
developers should explore this package
before creating a new functional
interface
followed by that we have use of
functional interface annotation
annotate your function interface with
functional interface annotation at first
this annotation seems to be useless even
without it your interface will be
treated as functional as long as it has
just one abstract method but imagine a
big project with several interfaces it's
hard to control everything manually
an interface which was designed to be
functional could accidentally be changed
by adding
of another abstract method rendering it
usable as a functional interface but by
using the function interface annotation
the compiler will trigger an error in
response to any attempt to break the
predefined structure of functional
interface so it is also very handy tool
to make your application architecture
easier to understand for other
developers so followed by that the next
best practice that you can follow is to
not overuse default methods and
functional interfaces we can easily add
default methods to the functional
interface this is acceptable to the
functional interface contract as long as
there is only one abstract method
declaration
so followed by that the next best
practice that you can follow is to
instantiate functional interfaces with
lambda expressions the compiler will
allow you to use an inner class to
instantiate a functional interface
however this can lead to very verbose
code so you should prefer using lambda
expressions
and the final best practice that you
could follow is avoid overloading
methods with functional interfaces as
parameters let's get started with string
handling in java string class is very
versatile in java and it provides lot of
handy functions which can help you
manipulate strings in multiple ways for
example if you want to trim a string or
if you want to append a string to
another string or if you want to find a
particular character at a particular
index or if you have an index and you
want to see what character is present at
that particular index or if you want to
do any other kind of pattern matching in
the string so string is very versatile
in that in that context and today we
will have a look at some of those
methods so i've just opened the javadocs
api for string and you can see in the
method summary you will find a long list
of methods we will go through some of
these methods for example if i just show
you a snapshot of what i'm talking about
it has a careat method so you provide a
index and integer index and this
particular method will tell you which
character is present at that particular
index in the string remember string is
basically a zero based character array
zero index based character array
similarly you can also call code point
at which is going to return the
character in the unicode code point at a
specified index
similarly compared to method can be used
to compare two strings with each other
compared to ignore cases also there
which can compare two strings ignoring
whether they are in uppercase or
lowercase you can use concat method to
join two strings together you can use
the contains method to find if a
particular character or a particular
sequence of character exists in a
particular
string or not you can do a content
matching you can do copy you can also
see if a particular string ends with a
particular character or a sequence of
characters so there are tons of
different methods available here and
please do check out the api because like
i said this is going to come very handy
when you start writing real time
projects or the real life projects so
with that knowledge let's go to our ide
and let's have a look at some of these
examples in action so here also you can
obviously have a look at the string
class
from the ide itself just write string
and hit control and you will see an
underline and a hyperlink so just click
on this and you in the string class will
be opened and you can actually read on
about the documentation of the whole
string class but we are not going to do
that we are going to have a look at some
real life examples of how we can use
different methods of the string class so
here i've created two strings str1 and
str2 str1 is holding a string which says
john is studying and str2 is holding a
string which says in college now the
first utility function which i'm going
to talk about is the length method so if
you want to find out what is the length
of this particular string then you can
just call the length method on the
string and that is going to return the
length of the current string let's see
that in action let me comment the rest
of the code and let's see this one in
action so if i run this program i get
the value 16. so if you count this 1 2 3
4 space is also counted 5 6 7 8 9 10 11
12 13 14 15 16. so you get the exact
length of the string when you call the
length method similarly another method
is concat method and concat method is
used to concatenate two strings together
concatenation basically means joining
two strings together so if you want to
join the string one and string two then
just call str1 dot concat with the
string you want to append or you want to
concat so the concat method on the left
heights left hand side of the string is
going to get concatenated with the
argument which you pass in the concat
method so let's see that in action now
and let's see the result as well because
i'm storing the result of concatenation
into a new variable and printing that
variable so i get this whole text here
and you see the studying in just got
merged there was no space in between
because there is no space here if you
just put it like this and if you rerun
this you will see the proper space as
well while concatenation one of the
things which i also want to call out is
strings are immutable in nature when i
say immutable it it means that once you
have created this str1 holding this
value then st and then this particular
object's value pointing to str1 cannot
be changed you cannot mutate the strings
if you try changing str's value java is
going to create a new object and point
str1 to that object but the object which
was created initially is not going to be
overwritten so remember that concept
that whenever you're doing manipulations
on the string the previous string object
still remains there it doesn't get
overwritten or it doesn't get modified
whenever you modify a string you get a
new object that's the property of string
so we saw the concatenation let's move
ahead this also format method format
method is used to dynamically populate
some parts of the string for example if
you have a long list of students and if
you want to print the name of students
then what you can do here is that you
can change as you can assign those names
to certain variables and you can point
or refer those variables in the string
with the percentage syntax percentage s
syntax basically so the string dot
format method is used to supply dynamic
values inside a static string so in this
case this part of the string is static
where i'm saying the name of the student
is
then in the next string remember plus
also can concatenate it it is also doing
the exact same thing as the concat
method you can it's just a shorthand so
i'm creating first string then i'm
creating second string but here i'm
writing percentage s i will come to that
and then i've created one more string
where i'm using percentage b so what
happens that java format method supports
certain special type of references for
example if you want to dynamically place
a string you can use percentage s if you
want to dynamically place an integer
value you can write percentage d in the
format method similarly you can also
write other percentage f for a float
value and there are more other similar
placeholders which are available in the
format method so do check out the format
method documentation if you want to know
what all percentage types or variable
types can be dynamically placed inside
the format method here i'm just using
percentage s and percentage d and then
once you have created the first part of
the format method which is string with
with dynamic placeholders till this
particular point then you put a comma
and you start providing the values
remember the sequence of the values have
to be exactly the same way in which you
have used them here so if percentage s
is coming first then you have to supply
a string value if percentage d is coming
after that after the string value you
have to provide an integer value if
there was another percentage s after
percentage d in the same string then
after 21 you had to provide another
string value so that's the
contract which format method needs to
honor and if i run this particular
program and if i say if i try to see the
output let's try to see the output as
well and for the output i need to store
this uh whole string dot formats output
into a variable so let's say i say
string
r and then i can print r and see what
comes out so that's it let's run the
program now and now you will see this
line the name of the student is john
comma and the age is variable is 21. i
think it's coming because i've just
wrote variable is here but if you if you
remove this and if you say the age is
percentage d then you'll get a nice
human readable output without any extra
formatting so the name of the student is
john and the age is 21 and that there
was a comma that's why you still see the
comma but this is the basic idea with
using the format method now another
method which i want to talk about is the
cad at method let me comment the
previous output so that we can follow
along so i'm just going to comment all
of this which we have covered already
and let's focus on the care at method so
caret method can be used to find the
character present at a particular index
in a string so whatever index you
specify in the caret method the
character present at that particular
index will be returned so when i say
str1 dot care at 5 remember strings are
0 based indexed character arrays so 0 1
2 three four five at five i is present
so this carat method should return i so
if i run this particular program yes i
see the output as i now let's move ahead
uh with next example or the next api
call the next api call is that usage of
equals method where i can see if the two
strings are equal or not so here i'm
saying str1.equals str2 if both strings
are same it is going to return true
otherwise it is going to return false so
if i run this i get the output as both
strings are different it goes in the
else block because str1 and str2 are
different they are holding different
values so here the exact content of the
string is going to be matched the next
one is the index of method so index of
method can be used just for the reverse
functionality of care add in carat we
were supplying the index and getting the
character here we can supply the
character and get the index of it so
what what is going to happen that you
write the string dot index off and then
you supply the character where which for
which you want to find the index of so i
supply y here and if i run this
particular program for this line the
output is 12 let's see if the output is
correct so here if you try to find what
is sitting at the index number 12 in
this string so again 0 1 2 3 4 5
6 7 8 9 10 11 12. so yes y is present at
the 12th index and that's the output i
get what if you provide a character
which is not present in this particular
string that says z which is not there
and see what the output is in that case
you will get the output as minus one so
if the character is not present in the
string you will get the output as minus
one another thing what if the
character is
present more than once in the string for
example i is present more than one time
in the string so if i write i here
whether i get the index of this i or
this i let's see so i'm going to run
this program again and i get the value 5
so 5 is basically this i because this i
is definitely not 5 it's far far further
index so the first match of the index is
going to be returned in terms of the
index of method okay so that was about
the index of let's look at the next one
which is the replace in replace it's as
the name suggests you can replace a
character or a sequence of characters in
a string by calling the replace method
on the string on which you want to do
the manipulation and remember you're
doing the manipulation here so the
previous object is not going to get
overwritten but a new object is going to
get created so what i want to replace is
with r so in this particular string i
see an occurrence of s here so this s
should be replaced with r if the replace
functionality works as i just explained
so let's run this program and yes i can
say instead of s i see r being replaced
there and that's the usage of the
replace method next one is the split
method where if you want to split the
string into multiple elements so you
just call the split method and you
provide the separator here i'm
separating the string whenever there is
a space i'm basically breaking up the
string into multiple sub strings that's
what i'm doing here or multiple strings
i would just call it as so whatever
separator you provide whenever the
string is going to encounter that
separator it is going to split one part
of it so in on providing the separator
space it means in this particular case
i'm going to get three items the first
break up is going to go going to happen
here so the john part of it will go out
and this will go out in a separate
string then again between is and
studying i have another space so there
will be another break here so i should
get three elements if i call the split
method one element will be holding the
value john the second element will be
holding the value is and the third
element will be holding the value as
studying and then i'm printing all the
elements of the of the array remember
that split method returns a string array
so that's what i'm using here to store
the output of the split method and then
i'm just using the streams api to
iterate over this string array
outputting or printing the each element
of the array so let's run this program
okay so i can see three different
outputs through this
system.out.println first john then is
then studying like i said split method
is going to create a three element size
array of strings because i'm separating
it based on the space the last utility
function which i want to talk about so
this is the last one but i'm skipping
some of some more due to the interest of
the time but like i said do check out
the documentation to read or understand
more about other string utility methods
which i'm not covering here in this
session so the last one i'm going to
talk about is the substring method and
substring is basically going to take a
mini string out of the long string so
what if you want to trim the string what
if you have a long string and you only
want to get a part of the string so you
can specify the starting point we can
specify that you can specify the end
point and whatever string characters are
present between the starting index and
the end index will be taken out from the
string and you can store that output
into a new string and print that so here
i'm calling the substring method
providing the starting index as 1 and
the ending index is 5. let's run this
program and interpret the output so i'm
getting the output as o h n so what is
happening here let's go back to the str1
so i said start with 1 remember string
is a 0 based index so it starts with
zero one it starts with o because o is
present at the first index and then i'm
going up till five so one gets printed
whatever character is present at one
index get printed second index get
printed third index gets printed fourth
index gets printed which is just a space
and then the fifth index is i which is
not printed here so it means that when
you call the string substring method
then the end index position will not be
printed it starts from the beginning
index and it will go till index mine end
index minus one position in terms of
printing because if you select this
you'll see an extra bar here because the
space is also getting printed so it is
printing everything before the fifth
index it will not include the fifth
index character remember that when you
use the substring functionality that the
end index is not included in the
substring if you want to include that
you need to increase the index by one so
for example if you want to print i as
well then you have to write it as
index six and if you run this then you
will also see i now yep so that is how
this
substring functionality works let's get
started with java.lang package so
java.lang package is one of the most
core and fundamental packages in java
which is provided out of the box to the
developer you never explicitly import
this package in your java program
because you don't need to java provides
this automatically the moment you create
a file with java extension or and you
have you are running that particular
program inside or on a jdk you get the
java.lang package automatically for
example when we were when we were
running the string handling demo i was
using the string class but i never
imported the string class you can see
there is no import for string because
string class is also part of the
java.lang package it's automatically
imported for you you never need to
explicitly import the package or any
classes of that package so this is going
to be more of a theoretical lecture
where we will just have a look at or a
quick overview of all the java.lang
package classes and other utilities you
don't need to remember all the classes
and utilities but this is just to give
you a sense of what all it contains so
in terms of the interfaces it has the
appendable interface autoclave auto
closable care sequence clonable
comparable if you remember we also used
comparable when we were writing the
comparable
implementation to compare different
objects in a collection so this also
comes automatically as part of the
java.lang package iterable runnable
again we use this in the in the
threading example so this also comes
automatically to you you never need to
import the enable class from the
java.lang package when we move to the
classes all the data type classes which
you can think of in terms of boolean
byte character class class loader
compiler enums even float integer long
math so all the classes which we were
using the the data type classes which we
were using in different examples are
also part of the java.lang package okay
so this is a long long list it also has
a thread class so whenever you are
creating thread you again never imported
thread class but it still just worked
fine because there was
this was also coming as part of the
java.lang package there are also bunch
of enumerations which it provides in
terms of unicode thread state etc it
also provides exception classes like
arithmetic exception or the different
runtime exceptions which we dealt with
like array index out of bound array
store class cast class not supported the
root exception class so a lot of
exception classes also come as part of
the java.lang package it also provides
some error classes if you remember when
we talked about the exception framework
you have the error types and you have
the exception types so it also provides
some error classes if you want to use
that you don't you never need to import
any of these classes and you will
automatically get them from the
java.lang package similarly it also
provides some annotations as well like
functional interfaces or you remember we
use this annotation a lot the add the
rate override annotation but we never
imported the override class or the
override annotation because it's part of
the java.lang package so this basically
tells us that there are a lot of
different classes utilities enums errors
exceptions data types which are provided
out of the box from the java.lang
package which makes our life so much
easier whenever we want to work with
java because we don't need to import the
very basic classes which
which we use very frequently and another
very important package is the java.util
package we have been using the java.util
package in all of the collections
examples and tutorials we walk through
in this whole tutorial series so let me
just open the java.util package for you
so if i go here to java.util
and
i will be able to see the java.util
packages different classes etc yes so
here is here it is the java.util package
and remember java.util package is not
imported automatically you have to
explicitly import the java.util package
to use the classes of it so it so that's
the difference between java.lang package
and java.util package that you cannot
you can use
the classes coming from the java.lang
package without explicitly importing
those glasses or importing the
java.blank package but java.util package
is something which you have to
explicitly import in your java program
to make it work or even make it compile
so what java.util provides first of all
the collections framework the whole
collections framework comes from the
java.util package so for example all the
interfaces which we use while we work
with the collections framework classes
interfaces like collection list set map
you can see the map interface you can
see the list interface with the generics
so all the interfaces which we use from
in the collections framework are present
in the java.util package similarly when
we talk about the classes
all the concrete classes implementation
of the collections framework in terms of
error list linked list hash map hash set
preset tree map you will see all of
those classes here here we are covering
all the this is showing all the classes
summaries so you see some abstract
classes and you will also see some
concrete classes as you move further
down in this particular list so you see
hash map you see hash set hash table
linked hash map linked asset linked list
we used all of these classes while we
were going through the collections
framework tutorials so it provides all
of these and lot of other classes like
the scanner class which we covered in
the java project for taking the inputs
from the command line from the user uh
stack class again from the collection
some time classes and it also provides
bunch of enumerations like the locale
basically setting the language
categories for a particular program it
also provides some exceptions which we
used while we were working with the
collections framework so most of these
exceptions are or some of these
exceptions are related to the collection
classes for example the concurrent
modification exception gets thrown uh
whenever you your the whole execution
detects concurrent modification of an
object when such modification is not
allowed you will see other different
types of exceptions like illegal format
etc in this particular exception section
of this particular package then it also
provides just one error class as well so
this is what the java.util uh package
contains and just to refresh your memory
whenever we ran any collection demo we
always imported the java.ut classes you
can see this is all coming from
java.util so this is something which you
have to import without which your
program will not even compile so that's
also one of the difference between the
java.lang package and the java.util
package and that's pretty much all i
want to cover in this particular session
so
we basically did a quick tour of the
java.lang package and the java.util
package and like i said it's impossible
to cover all of that for all of the
classes and enums and interfaces and
errors and exceptions
with all the examples so i would suggest
you to just keep this in mind about the
java.lang package and java.util package
i told you the basic construct that
java.lang contains all the types the
class and the variable types or the data
types we dealt with and java.util
majorly contains all the collection
classes uh that's that's the that's the
basic uh thing which you need to
remember whenever you work with java and
your java.lang package never needs to be
imported but java.util package needs to
be imported always whenever you use the
util classes let's get started with
networking in java so when we talk about
the networking in java java has a whole
dedicated package called java.net
package which has all the different
classes which you need to have to write
a networking program in java so we'll
you will see bunch of classes with two
classes most important ones which are
inet 4 address and inet 6 address so as
you can see you can understand that inet
4 address is the class which can be used
to represent the ipv4 addresses and inet
6 address class can be used to represent
ipv6 addresses and then you can learn
about sockets it also has socket classes
it has lot of interfaces the with the
prominent one being the networking
interface there are some high level apis
for example the uri class is there which
can be used to represent a universal
resource identifier as specified in the
rfc and this is just an identifier this
doesn't provide the means to access the
resource if you want to access the
resource then you need to use url which
is the class representing the universal
resource locator which is a slightly
older concept than uri but with url you
can hold the address as well as access
the address url connection is also one
of the class which is created from the
url class to set up a communication link
with the url and similarly http url is
for an http connection and you have
protocol handlers there are a lot of
interesting classes which
you can explore if you want to learn
more about what all networking support
java provides but when we talk about the
basic ones like ipv4 address the url uri
classes these are the ones which
generally most developers interact with
if you want to write a socket
programming uh
socket program that's used you can still
do that with the classes and interfaces
support provided by java so you can see
bunch of interfaces here cookie policy
socket option then in terms of classes
you can see again content handler cookie
manager http cookie i net four and i
need six address with the classes which
i talk about it also has a generic class
but i would always recommend to use one
of these if you know what address you're
dealing with uh the url connection the
jar url connection class proxy class
some bunch of socket classes uri url
classes and some enums and exceptions as
well which are related to networking
connections for example malformed url if
the url itself is is not correct then
you get a malformed url exception socket
exception if there's a socket timeout
exception then also you have a dedicated
exception for that so there are a bunch
of different exceptions classes enums
and interfaces available which you can
have a look at if you want to dig deeper
into it so i've also prepared a demo
where we will be using some of these
functionalities of these of this
particular package so let's jump to the
ide and see what i've built so here i
have created a class called networking
demo and what we are trying to do that
we will provide the simply launch url
and we will try to get bunch of
information about how this website is
hosted so you just create a simple
string variable and you can type any
string you can write
any favorite website of your choice here
and then we create the inet address
class and like i said you always use the
concrete implementation of the init
address class which is in this case i
net 4 address so i use the get by name
and we supply the url to get an inet
address object and what does inet
address contains it contains all the
information in terms of the internet
address on which that particular website
is hosted so you will see lot of
different functionality in this class
let's explore some of the functionality
and methods which are provided by the
inet address class so once you do this
you will get an inet address object if
the url is correct if the url is
incorrect you will get a malformed url
exception anyways if you want to just
see the address of
the ip address where this particular
website is hosted you can call the get
address method and if you want to see
the host address method then you can
call the get host address now you might
be wondering what is the difference
between get address and get host address
so let's get first that out let me
comment the rest of the code and let's
first focus on this particular part so
let me comment the local address part as
well we will come to that in a while and
i can just remove this comment so we are
printing the get address and the get
host address and let's see what values
do we get and how do we see if it's a
different value so this explains right
when we call init address dot get
address we just get all the values as we
know that when we deal with ipv4 address
the address has four values something
dot something dot something dot
something if you want to verify it just
go to your own laptop and you will be
able to see some address like
192.168.something or something so that
uh so ipv4 address has four sections and
all the four sections will have some
values so if you use the get address
method and you try to convert this into
a string it basically will return an
array the get address method will return
an array which will look like this but
if you want to see it exactly in the
format in which the real world
networking protocols understand it then
use the get host address which is going
to show it exactly in the way in which
we write the ip address where we write
some integer dot some integer dot some
integer dot sum integer so that's the
difference between get address method
and get host address method same value
different representation the next
function which i'm going to talk about
is about local address and the local
address or the method name is is any
local address so this method is going to
tell me if there is a wildcard address
which is associated with this particular
host you can also see what this method
is doing from the documentation so if
you go to the documentation and if you
search for this particular method in the
inet 4 address class you will see it
says utility routine to check if the
inet address is a wild card address the
result will be a boolean which will
indicate if it has a wildcard address or
not so let's run this program and
understand if it has a wildcard address
no there is no wildcard address
associated for this particular website
similarly there is another method which
we can explore which is is link local
address so let's search for the
documentation of it first so this is the
class if you search it it will just show
you the exact class which is present
with the method and this method
provides basically a check to see if the
inet address is a link to a local
address within the domain of the website
so the result again will be a boolean if
it says true it means there is a link to
the local address and if it returns
false it means the address is not a link
local unicast address so let's see the
output of this in with respect to the
simply learn website so if i run this
program now i again get false so there
is no wildcard address attached or
associated with the website and it does
not point to a local unicast address
either is there a loopback mechanism now
these all are networking concepts and uh
since this is not a networking session
so i will not go deeper into what what a
loopback address
means in detail but to get to give you
an understanding of where it present and
how you can use this in java is what we
are going to focus on so if you want you
can always read about what is a loopback
address but if you want to know if the
url which you are pointing to is uh the
address which is returned by that
website has a loopback address or not
then you can use the is loopback address
method and this again returns true or
false based on whether it has a loopback
address or it does not have a loopback
address so if i run this particular
program we get the output false again so
no it the simplylink website does not
even also have a loopback address the
last one or the second last one which i
want to explore is the site local
address method so let's see what does
this method do let me just remove this
extra commented lines
so let's look at the documentation of
this method so this is a utility routine
to check if the init address is a site
local address the result is a boolean
indicating if the init address is a site
local address or false if the address is
not a cyclical site local unicast
address again this concept is again
a networking special concept for similar
to the loopback address so this is just
basically
showing if the site also has a
basically a local unicast address
associated with it or not so if you want
to see the site local address output i
have enabled that code and if you run
this particular program we get false for
that as well yes that means that the the
simple website is built with pretty good
practices there is no loopback address
there is no site local address which we
don't need for for this particular
website in this case
the last one is just a simple thing just
to see the hash code it's not much of a
relevance mostly the programs but just
to tell you that this is also available
so you can also see the hashcode which
is contained by the inet address object
so we covered bunch of functionality in
this particular example we had a look at
the java.net package it has an inet 4
address class and i net 6 address class
lot of networking exceptions and
interfaces support as well and the
simple way to use it is to you point it
to a website call the get by name call
the get host address and you will get
the ip address in the exact format in
which the networking world deals with it
similarly you can call the get address
to just get an array of it just as we
saw here and then there are a lot of
utility functions available in the inet
address class like is any local is link
local is loop back is site local and
there are actually more if you look at
this class you will find more methods
here
in terms of what like for example it
also has multicast address this is
basically to check if the init address
is an ip multicast address so there are
a lot of different methods here there
are some mc methods as well which will
check which are specially created for
the multicast address scenarios so a
utility routine to check if the
multicast address has a global scope if
it has a local scope or sorry it has a
node scope basically or it has a link
scope or it has a side scope so there
are a lot of different methods available
for the multicast as well which you can
have a look at and we already covered
the get address the get host address and
the hash code address classes there are
some url classes as well like i
mentioned url ui classes are also very
important classes which you might need
to use whenever you are you are building
a connection with a particular
application based on their url if you
are doing socket programming there are
socket classes available which you can
also use while using the networking
concepts in java so you can build a
pretty decent and robust application
using the networking classes and the
networking support provided by java to
build a
networking application let's get started
with image handling in java so
we deal with images on a daily basis and
you will often be required to deal with
image handling in java programs as well
where you might need to re read an image
or write an image or load an image into
memory and do other kind of
manipulations on the images so java does
provide support for image handling as
well and
you can pretty much load up any type of
image be it a gif image or be a png or
be it a jpeg image basically it converts
into a java 2d image to render it and it
basically creates a byte representation
of the image to serve and save the
contents so in this section we are going
to talk about the image handling aspects
of java and to do that uh there are
broadly two classes which java provides
as you can see in this official
documentation the first one is
java.awt.imageclass
and the second one is
java.awt.image.bufferedimageclass
which extends the image class so this is
basically the superclass as you can see
here which you can use to represent any
kind of graphical image as a 2d array of
pixels and buffered image is a concrete
implementation of the image class which
you can use to construct instances of
the class and buffered images is sort of
the i would say the de facto standard or
the go-to class whenever you are dealing
with any kind of image rendering uh
tasks in a java program and we will also
have a look at how we can use the
buffered image class to basically read
and a sample image and also write a
sample image to a file system so
you can read more about this in the
documentation and
these are there are also bunch of
documentations available in terms of how
you can read it how you can load it into
the program how you can draw an image
how you can create and save the image
etc and like i mentioned we will be
covering some aspects of it in today's
demo as well so this was a very brief
theoretical introduction about image
handling and like i always mention if
you want to know more about this do
check out the official documentation of
of java where you can learn more about
the image handling classes and utilities
so with that let's move to the
demonstration part so i have prepared a
demo here which talks about image
handling so i have created a class
called image handling demo which has a
public static void main method and i'm
just giving some some sample uh
dimensions for the image in terms of
width and height here and then as i
mentioned that we will be using the
buffered image class so i'm creating an
a reference for the buffered image it's
currently assigned to null so basically
there's nothing and then i am calling
the method read from file so like i
mentioned you can you mostly will be
dealing with reading from an image or
writing to an image so here we will look
at both of the aspects as to how you can
load an image from your file system into
a java program and then write it back to
the file system from your java program
so let's first look at the read from
file method which will tell us how we
can read a java file so i provide some
sample dimensions these dimensions will
vary based on your use case and i supply
the buffered image object inside that i
have created a try block and in the try
block the first thing you need to do for
image handling is to basically create a
file object because image is also
technically just a file right so you
provide the file image path here at this
particular location so let's go to the
sample image path this is the
destination path and let me open the
sample image path as well which is
somewhere in the c drive so this is the
image which we are loading this is the
path which i have mentioned which is c
sample dot jpg so let's first have a
look at the image as well as to what
this image contains so this image is
basically from a from a clinical trial
and
showing some blood sample or some
vaccine bottles which is probably the
very uh popular image nowadays because
we are living in this pandemic world so
this is the sample image which i have
chosen to read and then i will load this
into the java program and then we'll try
to write it back to the file system to a
destination location so this is where my
image is present in the c drive named
with sample.jpg and this is what i've
supplied here so you just need to supply
it in double quotes remember when you're
dealing with windows file system you
always have to use double forward
slashes which is different if you're
working with on a mac machine or you're
working on a linux system where only
this will work fine so that's a bit
awkward thing which which windows has
and you have to respect the operating
systems restrictions or way of doing
things so once you have loaded the file
or created the
sample.jpg file object then the next
thing we are going to do is we are going
to create an object of the buffered
image remember we just created a
reference we did not create an object
yet of the buffered image class and now
is the time to do that so we supply the
width we supply the height and then we
supply the type of the image let's go to
the constructor of this image to see
what this image type means so this image
type can be basically the type of the
created image which comes from the color
space so whether it's an rgb image or a
rgb image or bgr image or a bite gray
image there are multiple different types
of images in the media space and
whatever type of image you have you need
to basically supply that image type in
this particular argument so in my case
it was an argb image so i supplied that
particular if you click on this you will
see that currently it's inside java an
8-bit rgba image basically has a static
constant which is denoted by 2. you can
read more about this inside the buffered
image class documentation is as well so
once i've supplied that my buffered
image object is ready which has all the
details dimensions and the types of the
image now the next thing is that you
need to fill this image object with the
file so you basically need to read the
file and store the output of this read
operation into the buffered image object
then what will happen that along with
this information whatever is present
here will also be added to the same
buffered image object so to read a
image or simple a file java provides an
i o utility which is called image i o
and there is a read method available
which is a static method on this
particular class as you can see i'm
calling the class dot method name here
and then you supply the sample file name
once you have done that then it will
basically be reading the whole image
into a 2d byte array and copying that
over into this buffered image object
once that is done if this particular
line is successfully executed then you
will get this message which will say
reading complete and it will try to
print some hash code of the image object
and after that if if there's any
exception in this block for example this
particular line may raise an exception
or this particular line may raise an
exception if the file does not exist
then you need to have the i o exception
caught remember i o is a checked
exception so if you are using these
operations file new file and
imageio.read you need to catch the i o
exception because it's a checked
exception so either you need to catch it
or you need to re-throw it these are the
only two options you have with the
checked exception so once we have done
all of that if everything goes fine if
everything is happy till line 35 then we
just return the image object and our
read from file operation will be done
going back to the main method once the
read operation is done the next thing
i'm going to do is writing this image
object to a new destination file so
let's see what is happening in this
write to file method because this is the
method which is responsible for writing
this image to a new destination location
so i've created a public static void
void method inside the same class where
the public static void main method is
present as you know that static methods
can only call other static methods
that's why this has this had to be
static and i'm supplying the same image
object which was returned from the read
operation that goes in as the argument
of this particular method and again i'm
using a file object and this time i'm
providing a destination location where i
would like to write this image so this
is the destination location i've chosen
which is f drive java tutorials folder
and the image should be stored with the
name out dot jpg so this is the location
there's already already an out.jpg here
so let me just remove it so that we can
observe the output so we create the file
object after that we again use the image
i o utility
we call our static method static utility
method called write we supply the whole
image object we supply the image type
extension and we supply the output
location again if i take you to the
signature of this you take the rendered
image you take the format name which is
jpg and the output location so these are
the three things which you need to
supply once you call the right method on
the image io utility class image io is a
very handy class and do remember this
class whenever you are dealing with the
image handling operations it will
provide lot of static convenience
methods so we write this file
write this image object to a file to a
destination location and if everything
goes fine in these two lines we will get
this message which will say writing
complete if anything goes wrong we again
catch the i exception and the exception
will be printed here that's all is
happening in this particular program
where we are reading from file and we
are writing to the file reading it from
here and writing it on this particular
location so let's run this program and
see if we are able to read from file
successfully and also write it to the
specified location so run as java
application it's a slightly memory heavy
operation so it takes a bit of time
because the whole image needs to be
loaded into memory be very careful about
that it might eat up your large portion
of your ram if the image is too heavy so
here it says reading complete and then
it prints the hash code details of this
particular object and then it also
executed the write to file method and it
said writing complete so just to
show you the reference back again this
is what we read sample.jpg and c drive
and if i go to the f drive java
tutorials where i provided the output
location i do see an out.jpg here which
which was not there earlier and if i
double click on this it's exactly the
same image so java was able to read the
image and render the exact same image by
converting that 2d byte array
representation back to an image exactly
the same for there's no change in this
image so this was a very short
enlightening tutorial for you to show
you how you can use image handling
classes for example the image io class
and the buffered image class to do basic
image handling operations obviously you
can do more complex operations with it
as well but for the demonstration
purpose i've just kept it simple let's
get started with concurrency utilities
in java now concurrency is a huge topic
and it's not possible to cover this into
a 10 or 15 minutes tutorials so treat
this particular session as an
introductory session where i will talk
about some of the most relevant classes
which you need to know when you talk
about concurrency we have been talking
about this whole concept of concurrency
programming throughout the thread
tutorials as well and the basic idea is
that you would like to do multiple
things at the same time that's the basic
idea now in that context java does
provide lot of utilities and packages
especially the
java.util.concurrentpackage is one of
the most popular package which you need
to use whenever you are dealing with
concurrency programming paradigms in
java so with that let's have a look at
what does this
java.util.concurrent package contains so
broadly it contains lot of utility
classes which can be very useful for you
when you are writing the concurrent
programming code apart from that it will
also provide some basic ideas around the
locking functionality and the atomic
packages as well when we talk about
locks again we discussed about locks
when we talked about the whole sync
thread synchronization concept as well
and it basically marries very well with
the whole concept of locks and atomic
packages as well atomic is again a
different topic which is used for thread
safe types basically but whenever you
will hear about concurrency utilities be
it in your discussions or be it in your
interviews you will be seeing a
discussion happening around executors
you will hear these terms like executors
executor service future completable
future callable all of these you will
hear the name of all of these classes
quite frequently so we these classes
were first introduced in java 8 and have
been there since then to support the
concurrency programming paradigm so i
will talk about these three classes
broadly in today's session and we'll now
have a look at a demonstration of these
three classes as well uh let's first
talk about executor technically it's an
it's an interface it's not a class
though i said that it's a class but it's
basically an interface an executor is
basically a very simple interface which
will help you define the sub systems
which you want to which you would like
to create with the help of threads may
be including thread pools or if you want
to do a disk reading and writing
operation in an asynchronous way or you
want to create some sequence of task
frameworks as well so executor will
provide you a very lightweight framework
to do all of that especially around
thread pooling and asynchronous i o is
is where it shines most because in your
computer you have limited resources and
you would like to
dedicate a certain pool of threads for a
particular task or for a particular
executor object so with that and the
second class which we would like to know
about is executor service an executor
service will provide a more asynchronous
task execution framework and this is
probably the class which you will be
using whenever you're dealing with
asynchronous programming in java
asynchronous programming basically means
that you submitted a particular task but
you did not wait for it to be completed
you did not hang your process or your
thread for that particular task to be
completed it's very simple it's very uh
easy to relate this to a real life for
example if you are
you know there are times when you do two
things at the same time for example uh
let's take a very very simple example if
you're just boiling milk on on your gas
stove so you put the milk on the gas
stove and then you move out for a couple
of minutes to do some something else for
example maybe checking your mobile for
new emails or or doing some other work
doing maybe just doing some laundry so
uh you are doing you you submitted the
milk boiling task then you moved away
from that task because you know that
this particular task is going to take
some time and you utilize your time
somewhere else that's what we mean by
asynchronous programming and executor
service will provide you with constructs
to create a similar behavior in your
java program as well so remember about
executor and executor service
we will look at the implementations
later where we can talk about that
another interesting class which i would
love which i would like to talk about is
future if we have it here yeah so future
is another class which we will be
looking at and future is basically uh to
fetch the result of the submitted task
again taking the same knife example of
the milk boiling example so
it would be great right if if there is
some mechanism or some alarm which just
sets off the moment the milk is is is
boiling and it's about to be spilled out
it would be great to know that in that
in advance via some alarm or something
so future provides that kind of a
carrier or that kind of a holder where
you submitted a particular task you
moved your threads to something else you
did something else and then you can
check with the future object and future
object will tell the status of their
submitted task whether it is completed
or whether it's still in progress once
it is complete then you can fetch the
result of that submitted task based on
with the future object so that's the
concept of future so remember executor
service and future they will work quite
hand in hand because executor service
will be used to submit the task and
future will be able to fetch the result
of that particular task asynchronously
so that was about a quick theory you can
read more about it in the documentation
you can see an executor service future
class what does what does this basically
in this class do uh but to have a look
at or or get a greater sense of this
let's have a look at our demonstration
of it to understand these classes better
so let's move to uh the eclipse ide to
look at an example let me close all the
classes and just open a relevant one so
yeah so let's first deal with the
executor interface itself so if i just
minimize this one here i've created a
main class and i've created a public
static void main method and you see two
static methods here executor invoke an
executor service invoke i'm basically
showing you how you can use executor and
executor service so if you're just using
executor then how you would do that is
basically you are going to create a
reference of the executor and then the
executor needs a basically an an
executor object because it's an executor
reference so you need to supply an
executor object so either you can supply
an inner class right here or you can
call you can create a executor type of
class which i've created here which is
called caller class so i've created a
class called caller which implements the
executor type and execu the moment you
write implements executed it will force
you to override the execute method and
inside the execute method you are going
to run your own thread so this is how
the current thread or the executor's own
thread will be running so once you have
done the initialization then you can
call the execute method on the executor
class remember you got this object so
you can call the executor execute method
on the executor object here and inside
this you can provide this particular
lambda function implementation which is
going to ask you what exactly you want
to do when i run this particular thread
so when i run this thread when java runs
this particular thread what do you want
java to do that's something which you
will provide here so this is how you can
use it's a very simple example like i
said uh
this if i build a more complex example
it will take a lot of time and lot of
other concepts to cover so treat this as
an introductory session and if you can
basically try to run a very simple
example of this writing whatever complex
logic you want to write while the thread
is running and put that into this
execute similarly if you if you want to
use executor service for doing the
asynchronous operations then it will
follow the same way but there are some
differences along the way as well so
this is the method which is showing the
executor service implementation or the
way of using executor service so again i
create a reference of executor service
and then here you see i'm saying
executors dot new fixed thread pool with
a size of 10. so that's the power of
executor service it is going to create a
pool of threads dedicated to itself to
do the tasks whichever are written
inside here so whatever you write here
these thread pool will be utilized to
execute that particular task you can
assign the size of the thread pool based
on how many threads you need there are
multiple static utility methods like
there is one new fixed thread pool which
i've used but if you just do control
enter you will see cached thread pool a
single thread execution a new work
steering pool so like i mentioned there
are a lot of classes interesting classes
here which you can use for simplicity
i've just used a fixed thread pool here
once you get the executor service object
then here you called execute but here
you will be calling the submit method
and then the drill goes exactly the same
way that you write the lambda function
implementation inside here basically the
functional interface implementation and
you provide your own implementation code
which you would like to run whenever you
call the run method whenever this
executor service calls the run method on
that particular thread you can actually
go to the submit method and you will see
it accepts a runnable it basically
accepts a thread object so whatever you
write inside this particular code will
be the public void run implementation of
that particular thread class if you
don't
if you don't remember how threnable
works please go back to my threading
tutorial and watch that where i
explained the runnable interface and the
run method in detail so that's what we
are doing here so this is for executor
and this is for executor service so
let's run this program and yes i mean
nothing because i'm not doing anything
much apart from just doing sis outs here
and that's what you see here the
executor's example and the executor
service exam so this was about executor
and executor service now let's deal with
another interesting uh class of
of called future which i said that i
will also talk about so for that i have
created a separate demo because it
deserves a separate demo it's a very
interesting class so let me just make it
full screen yeah so i've created a class
called future demo which has a public
static void main method and again i'm
doing the
executor service initialization but this
time i'm using a new single thread
executor now what does this does this
this will basically create an executor
which will use a single worker thread
operating from an unbounded queue
remember even if this single thread
terminates due to let's say a failure
during the execution before the before
the graceful shutdown a new one will
automatically be spawned and will take
its place if the execution is still
pending so that's the power of single
worker thread from an unbounded queue
that's what i've used here based on your
use case you can use other ones as well
like i mentioned earlier then uh i have
the executor service object with me and
similar to the previous example i'm
going to call the submit method and
inside this submit method i need to
provide the runnable class implementable
interfaces implementation and that
implementation will basically be of the
public void run method and this is what
i want to do in my run method where i'm
sleeping the thread for 10 seconds
thread.sleep method takes milliseconds
values as the parameter so this is 10000
which means 10 seconds so i'm sleeping
this thread or pausing this thread for
10 seconds and then returning a string
called completed this is what i am doing
in the executor service dot submit
implementation the result of it is going
to be a future object remember the
result of the submit task is going to be
a future object so i store that future
reference here and then at line 20 i'm
using the same feature of a future
object to ask java to check if this task
is done and the way you do that is just
by calling is done so till the time
there's a negation condition till the
time the task is still in progress
because this means future is not done
because i've put a negation then just
print this out there where you say the
task is still in progress it's still not
complete and you pause this particular
thread remember this was a different
thread if you you pause this particular
thread for 500 millisecond or basically
half a second and you again check this
condition if it's still not done you
print this again pause for half a second
again check this till the time feature
dot is done becomes true when future dot
is done becomes true that means that
this particular task is completed now
you see i mean generally when we execute
the programs the execution happens
sequently sequentially that after line
17 the control will automatically flow
to line 20 and before the control can
reach line 20 everything above line 17
has to be completed that's that's
basically synchronous programming for
you but when you talk about asynchronous
programming using the power of executor
service and future objects we can do
something here which will go into a
separate thread and then you can
continue your execution here so this can
be in a different method altogether
where you submit something and this is
basically checking the status of this
task understand this very well this is
very important concept that it's not a
it's though it's a sequential execution
after line 17 line 20 is getting
executed but line 20 is not waiting for
everything above line 17 to be finished
it will continue that's the power of
asynchronous programming so here we are
checking this and once the feature the
future dot is done says true then we say
task completed we and then you probably
would like to fetch the result of this
particular task right and for that
future provides a method called future
dot get this is going to pick the future
object state and whatever you are
returning from here will be returned
here and then i'm printing the result so
if everything went fine this result
should say completed because what i'm
returning from this future object and
always remember to shut down your
executor service to release the thread
pool which you created here i've also
put a catch block here because i'm using
the thread.sleep method which will ask
you to handle an interrupted exception
and then there is an executor service
exception which is execution and a
timeout exception as well there are
other interesting methods as well on the
future class future object sorry which
is like future.cancel where you can
cancel explicitly a future task which is
currently in progress you can check the
status of it by calling is done which
i've used here you can also call is
cancelled to check if the user or some
other process explicitly cancelled the
execution of the submission of the
executor service task so hope this is
you are able to understand the flow of
it that these block and these block will
program will execute them but they will
run in different threads so let's see
what happens now i'm going to run this
particular program and if i bring this
here you see the task still in progress
keeps getting called so we submitted the
task here and now this block is getting
executed this block kept getting
executed so this task did not finish
right the thread dot sleep was this this
thread this whole thread was sleeping
for 10 second but line 20 did not wait
for 10 seconds it continued execution
and it kept checking the future object
10 times at least or till the whole 10
second sleep was taken away and one of
once that once this thread woke up it
returned completed feature dot is done
became true and it came out and it said
task completed so that's what we get
here and at the end in the result you
get completed which is which is what you
returned from here so this is the power
of asynchronous programming please like
i mentioned please do read about more
about these classes and how they work
and what is the paradigm of asynchronous
programming it does make debugging a bit
hard at times but it's a very
interesting concept to be used in
concurrent applications let's get
started with regular expressions or
regex in java you may hear people
calling it as regex or regex doesn't
matter you can call it anything as as
you want till the time you have the
concept understood in the right way i'll
just call it as regex so when we talk
about regex let's understand why do we
need them and what are how java actually
provides support for that so the basic
idea behind regular expressions is is to
find a pattern in a in a text corpus if
you have lot of strings available if you
have any kind of text any kind of string
and if you would like to find a
particular pattern saying okay does this
whole text paragraph contains any
character or contains any number or
contains any special characters or
contains characters after numbers or
numbers after characters so if you would
like to find those kind of patterns in
in your text corpus then you can then
that concept is called regular
expression finding and java provides the
support for that particular regular
expression finding through a package
called java dot util dot regex package
so this is the package which you would
need to use when you want to do any kind
of regular expression finding in that
text now you may want you may be
thinking that why do i need to use this
i already have the string handling
methods right you can do substring you
can find a particular character in the
string etc but that is limited because
it only and only provides string methods
ways to manipulate and find and replace
strings but regex is generic you can
literally find any kind of character in
your string it can be a special
character it can be a square bracket it
can be a multiply sign it can be a
divide sign it can be like i said
integer uh capital letters small case
letters so any kind of pattern you would
like to find
java.util.x can be used to find that
kind of pattern now this package is very
interesting and it provides lots of
classes and again this is a very very
very big topic and very complex topic so
we will just scratch the surface of it
and like i always say whenever you would
like to read more about it go back and
read the documentation currently the
documentation i've opened is for version
8 but when you are reading it you can go
for the latest java edition uh
documentation so with that let's talk
about some of the interesting classes
which we will be dealing with and we
must know when we talk about regex in
java so i already explained what are
regular expressions let's go to the
interesting classes the first class
which we need to know about is the
pattern class so pattern class or an
object of the pattern class will
basically be representing a compiled
regular expression so you write your
regular expression in a certain way
regular expression has its own language
i would say to write the pattern for
example if you would like to write a
pattern saying that find a
check if this particular text paragraph
has the characters first then the
integers then the characters then this
particular special character so that is
your pattern you write that pattern then
you need to compile that pattern to
compile that pattern you can use the
pattern class this this class generally
does not provide any kind of public
constructors to you so you cannot
initialize the pattern object explicitly
but to create a pattern you first you
need to basically call the static
methods static method named as compile
so compile is the method which you need
to use to compile your regular
expression which will then return the
pattern object once you have compiled
your written your pattern and you
compile your pattern the next class
which you need to know about is the
matcher class matcher class will provide
that particular engine framework which
will understand and interpret the
pattern and then will try to find that
pattern on the text paragraph which you
are supplying and it will result in true
or false if it finds that pattern it
will say true if it's not finding the
pattern it will say false so that's the
basic idea so you need to you need to
know about the pattern class and you
need to know about the matcher class so
it also does not the matcher class also
does not provide any kind of public
constructors and you obtain a matcher
object by calling the matcher method on
the pattern object so once you created a
pattern object just call the matcher on
that particular object and that will get
you a matcher object and it then you can
use that object to find the patterns in
that particular text corpus there is
also a dedicated exception which is
called pattern syntax exception which
will be
thrown whenever you have written the
regular expression syntax incorrectly
like i said it has it has its own
language so you need to write the
expression in a way regular expressions
are supposed to be written and supposed
to be understood i will touch upon that
in a while but that's that's the basic
idea about the three classes now when
when you would like to find a pattern it
can be a string pattern it can be some
characters it can be some predefined
characters some quantifiers you can also
create sub groups within the regular
expression so there is a like i said
there is a tons of functionality which
is available in this particular concept
and we will just cover some of the
relevant ones or just just run through
some of these concepts and then i will
switch to a demonstration for example if
we talk about the string literals then
you can do the string matching for
example if you want to find this
particular word or this pattern this is
just a text pattern right so if you
would like to find this particular text
pattern in the text string then you can
write this particular text pattern as a
string pattern inside the pattern object
so that's that's about the string
literals now let's move to some
interesting ones like uh like meta
characters and the meta characters are
very interesting because they have a
special meaning for example if you write
your regular expression like this where
you say cat and then you say dot then
when you are applying this particular
regular expression to find the match
into a string it is only going to find
the match for c a t it is not going to
find a match for c a t dot because dot
is a meta character in regular
expression it has a special meaning it
it does not mean dot but it has a
special meaning and that special meaning
basically means that even though the dot
is not present it will basically mean
that after cat it can be any character
so the meta character dot means any
character which is why you see this
snatch succeeds because it will search
for this pattern which it matches and
after that it can be any character it
doesn't care so even if it's s or d or
whatever it will say true because c80
was found a match so dot means any
character after the pattern you have
specified similarly there are a lot of
other characters special characters or
meta characters like the ones which have
been listed here question mark star plus
dot on and all of these have their own
dedicated special meaning they are not
your your normal uh arithmetic operators
or other operators they have their
special meaning when you are dealing
with meta characters so do read about
them in detail and i will be using a bit
of meta characters in the example as
well then the character classes are also
very interesting uh similar to the
example which i told you before if you
want to find a particular string or a
particular integer into a into a text
corpus then you can use the character
class patterns for example you just put
a square brackets and you write abc this
means that it will try to find exactly
abc in the string if you put a cap in
front of abc then it will try to match
any character or find any character
except a b or c so it's a negation
similarly if you specify small a to z
and capital a to z it means any
character can be there between small
case a to z and capital case a to z a to
z inclusive similarly you can provide
specific ranges like a through d or m
through p so only the characters which
will match the union of this condition
will be returning true and rest of the
if that if this particular uh pattern is
violated then you will get false so
similarly there are you can build lot of
complex combinations and permutations
with these
special meta characters and character
classes do read about these in detail if
you are curious to know about it and
there is tons of materials available on
this on internet which you can read
about to learn more about similarly
there are predefined character classes
as well dot is something which i already
explained which means any character then
you can use slash d to find a digit in a
particular string or a particular text
corpus slash capital d is for non-digit
or you can use the classic negation
condition as well slash s is for a white
space character slash capital s is for a
non-white space character word non-word
so there are a lot of different examples
so i think by now you would have built a
decent understanding of what i'm trying
to tell you is that you can specify
these patterns compile them and then use
the matcher so let's move to a very
simple demonstration it's not a complex
example but very simple example just to
get the point across so i'm creating a
regex string here and this is the
pattern i've specified i'm saying any
character star means any number of
characters so it can be anything here
then the string the the pattern expects
an alphabetical uh string or
alphabetical section after that the
alphabetical section should be followed
by a numerical section and after the
numerical section again it can be any
character so this is my pattern i create
a simple string with this regex pattern
and like i mentioned in the
documentation you call pattern.compile
to compile the regular expression so i
compile the regular expression i get the
pattern object and after again as per
the documentation it said that you can
call the matcher method on the pattern
object to get a matcher object so i say
pattern dot matcher and i provide my
string on which i want to test it so
i've just put a random string where
there are some integers then there is
some alphabets and then again there are
some integers once you have got the
matcher object just call matcher.find
this will return a boolean where you can
test whether the uh the matcher
found a hit in the text corpus or not if
it found a match the match found will be
true and if it didn't found find the
match you will get a false value in this
result so with that understanding let's
run this program so i get the output
match found why did i get that because i
said that start with anything so it
started with anything i don't care what
it is it's an integer or any special
character i don't care after that there
should be some alphabets so there are
some alphabets and right after alphabets
there should be some numbers so again
there are some numbers and after that
there can be any character 0 or more
characters so there is nothing here
that's why you see a match found let's
do an interesting test here let me do
this i put a to z again here so now i'm
saying start with anything have
alphabets have numbers and again after
numbers you should have some alphabet
which is not the case here because you
start with something you have alphabets
you have numbers and after numbers the
string ends there is nothing after that
so let's see what happens now you get a
match not found because this particular
pattern when got compiled and got
applied on this particular string did
not find the string following the right
x pattern which you have specified so
this is a very simple example to show
you how you can build patterns you can
use groups concepts as well to group the
patterns it can get very very complex
and very very nasty so use them very
wisely very carefully
and do read about the documentation and
other examples which i talked about to
get more understanding and more
comfortable with regex let's get started
with nio packages in java now let's
first understand why why do we need this
package and where will be using this
package let's talk about the wear first
you can use the nio package to read from
a file or write to a file now let's talk
about the why because the obvious
question will be that we already have
the i o package in java right where you
can where you can use the classes from
that particular package to read from a
file or write to a file then why do we
need an
another package doing exactly the same
thing as nio so the basic reason for
launching the java.nio package was
providing the multi-threading
capabilities to the io library and we
could not do this in the existing io
library because we had to probably
rewrite and change the functionality of
it that's why java created a new library
called new package called java.nio
package and this package is basically uh
i mean if you if you understand what nio
means here generally as per the popular
perception it means non-blocking io that
you don't want to block your threads
while you're reading to a file or
writing to a file classically niu meant
networking io but as per the popular
perception people know is that know it
as non-blocking i o so the basic idea is
because whenever you are read reading a
file or writing to a file the thread
gets blocked until the whole file is
written or until the whole file is read
so the nio package provides an
improvement over that it provides an
improvement in a way that you can read
the file into a different thread but at
the same time move on to another thread
and rise to a file so you get this
multi-threading capabilities and
non-blocking capabilities out of the box
from the classes provided by java.nio
package so that's the brief about this
package now some of the popular classes
which you will be dealing with and some
of the concepts which you need to know
about niu package are buffers and
channels these this is probably the core
concept of the whole nio package of how
channels and buffers work so let's say
you are trying to read something then
the read operation will be happening
from the channel into the buffer and
similarly the write operation will be
happening in the reverse way which means
to the channel from the buffer so that's
how the buffer and channel work together
that whenever you are trying to write
something you have to first open a
channel create a buffer and then you can
read from the channel into the buffer
and similarly when you're writing to the
buffer you again have to go via the
channel route so channel is that route
basically buffer is basically just a
plain container for the data and channel
is basically representing the connection
to the entities which are capable of
performing the iu operation so think of
channels as as a pipe a
channel literally basically if you if
you understand the english meaning of
channel that's exactly what we mean by
here that it provides just a means to an
end it provides sort of a wire to the
buffer and then you also have selectors
and selection keys classes which
together with selection channels work to
provide the non-blocking i o
functionality there are some other apis
interesting apis as well like careset
and some more but i will not go into the
detail of that because if you know about
buffers and channels and selectors then
we will be able to figure out what
exactly we would like to do with this i
would also like to talk a bit more about
the buffer class so if you go to the
buffer classes operations the popular
operations you will see there will be
the read operation which is for reading
the files basically or reading the
content of the file this works on the
byte stream concept first of all so to
read the bytes from the file you will
call the read method there's also a very
interesting method called flip which i
will be using which makes a buffer ready
for the new sequence of operations so
once you have done something and you
want to let's say you read a particular
file and you have come to the end of the
file now you would like to reset the
buffer and go back to the beginning of
the file then you can use the flip
method for that particular piece to the
uh to bring the current position back to
the position to the zero index or to the
starting of the file so that's about
read and flip and we will have a look at
some of the other methods and there are
a lot of interesting classes in this nio
package do read
read about the documentation and check
out the other methods as well to learn
more about this package but the basics
are like i said channels buffers some
methods of the buffers and there's also
a path class which is used to basically
provide a particular path to a directory
which i will not be covering in this
example but something good to know so
with that understanding let's move to an
example and understand how we can work
around with this an io package so for
that i have prepared an example where i
will be writing a reading from a file
and then writing to a file so i have a
main method here the first section here
basically is about reading from a file
and the second section is about writing
to a file so let's go through all of
both of these sections one by one to
understand what is happening so in the
read section i use the file input stream
class from the i o package i'm still not
using the paths class here just to show
you that both to both of them still can
work together if you want to use the old
constructs so use the same file input
construct to read a file called
source.txt which is present at this
particular location in my directory and
this source.txt has has just a one line
of text nothing more so i i basically
create the file input stream object and
then i create a channel because we are
dealing with files so you create a file
channel if you're dealing with network
socket then you might have a socket
channel so that's also something which
you need to know about that this nio
package is is generic it can be used for
any kind of communication of reading and
writing not specifically to file
handling so we create a file channel
object here by calling
fileinputstream.getchannel
it's that simple once you call that you
will get a reference or the object
basically of the file channel then the
next thing is to create the buffer like
i mentioned that channels and the buffer
are the two main tools through which you
work within an io library so we create a
byte buffer and we allocate some
starting size to it just some some
threshold size so you can put it any
number which you think is practical for
your file and your further use case here
i've put just one zero two four bytes or
one megabyte because my file is pretty
small so i just put that and initialize
the red read buffer and then i call read
channel dot read operation so the file
channel object you created you just call
the read method on this particular
channel and supply the buffer and then
it is going to read the file wire the
channel into the buffer and this read
method is going to return a result to
denote if the file was written
successfully or not i'm just pointing
printing assist out here just a bare
bones is out nothing new here so this
section will be used to read a file so
let's see if i can read the file
successfully and then we'll move to the
right section so i go to run as java
application yeah it says file read
successfully and it read 27 bytes it
means that there were total of 27 bytes
in my in my file which had a single line
of text so it read all of that and it it
completed the execution now let's move
to the right section and i can comment
the read section because we have covered
that so here i'm again creating a file
output stream object because i need to
write something so again using the same
construct of the i o package i have
covered previously in the previous
sessions once you have the file output
stream object created the next thing is
to create a channel so i i again create
a file channel but this time it's the
right channel i again create a buffer
which is the right buffer allocates some
size to it then this is the string which
i want to write to this particular file
so my file my destination file will be
called dest.txt will be present in this
particular location and this file should
have this string written if this whole
operation goes successfully that's my
end goal so to do that i say right
buffer dot put and whatever string you
have created just call get bytes on it
and you get a bytes representation of
the whole string so that's what i've
done here because this put method x
expects byte because if you go inside
this it expects a byte array so that's
what i'm supplying here i'm providing
the uh the byte array by on the string
by calling message.getbyte or any string
object dot get bytes will get your byte
array once you've done that then i'm
calling the flip method remember i
talked about this flip method to
basically reset the index that's
something which you need to do in this
particular case so that the index goes
back to the initial position and the
buffer can be written successfully to a
file uh to a channel basically so once
the buffer is is comp has completed its
operation then i can write the buffer to
the channel and once that is done then
if those if these operations went
successfully then i will see a file
called dest.txt in this particular
directory currently there is no desk.txt
in this directory you can see there are
just three files but there is no
test.txt so let's run this program so it
says file written successfully which was
the last sis out at line 28 but let's
also see what is happening in the
directory so now i see a desk.txt
popping up here it's a 1 kb file and if
i double click on this i see the same
string which is which say this is a test
string which is the same string which i
supplied here so you can see you can use
the nio packages to do the file read and
write and much much more than just read
and write using the nio package but this
is just to get get the point across that
this can be done using the nio or the
non blocking io package as well so that
you get maximum performance on your
machine while you deal with file io
operations let's get started with java
beans so we have been creating java
classes and creating objects of those
java classes to work and manipulate
transfer data call methods create
properties etc and java beans just use
that as the ground work to create a
specification first of all let's
understand that java beans is just a
standard it is just a specification
which has been provided by by java to be
followed while you are implementing
production grade or enterprise grade
applications so it's just a pure
specification set of standards if you
want to read more about this please go
to this particular link which is written
here i mean if you just google java bean
spec oracle then you will be able to
find this particular link you will see a
download option here if you go here you
will get these two specification
documents option so you can just accept
the license agreement and click on this
particular beans 0 1 1 0 1 pdf and you
can read about the whole java bean
specification i have already downloaded
this particular pdf which is opened in
this tab and if you go to the toc here
it's an official sun micro system white
paper basically and if you read about
this this is going to explain the whole
java beans api specifications it's going
to specify the core components of the
java beans component architecture so
it's a specification let's understand
that very well if you go to the table of
contents let's go to the interesting one
which says what is exactly a bean or a
java bean so a java bean is basically a
reusable software component that can be
manipulated in any visual ide like
eclipse or intellij or netbeans etc so
technically a java bean is just a java
class but that java class should follow
three main properties the first property
is that that java class should have
getters and setters to access the
properties second property is that that
java class should have a public no
argument constructor so that anybody can
create an object of it and third is that
the java class should implement
serializable the reason in java being
specified these three conditions which i
said
let's talk about the third one where we
are talking we are saying that it should
be implementing serializable interface
why is that it's because a java bean
would be required to be exported between
applications may be required to be
written to a database or to a file
system or to be converted into an xml or
a json document sent over the network
again being deserialized so this will be
moving across a lot because that's what
we mean by reusable multiple different
software components and applications
might be reusing that bean again and
again and that b needs to travel across
and to enable that that being has to be
serializable because if you can't
serialize it you just cannot transport
that object to another application it's
just not possible this is how java has
been so that's why you need to implement
serializable you need to have a public
no argument constructor and you need to
have getters and setters to access your
properties you can actually read more
about this if you scroll down it will
also talk about the difference between
beans and class libraries remember not
class but class libraries and here it
explains what i just said that a java
bean can have properties it can have
events and it can have methods so
properties are nothing but the normal
attributes which you create inside a
java class nothing fancy the same
attributes are named as properties for
example you may have a foreground
property and then you can have a method
which is just a normal java method which
can be called from other applications or
from an environment and by default all
of the beans public methods will be
exported by exported i meant when you
export this when you serialize and
export this object all the beans public
methods will be exported by default but
then a bean can choose to export only a
subset of its methods if it wants to a
bean can also have events and events
basically provide a way for one object
to notify other objects that something
has happened so something similar to the
to the producer consumer example or the
producer consumer pattern where uh you
can notify other objects threads also
have this particular pattern where a
thread can notify other threads that it
has completed its task and other threads
can start so uh so this is so that's the
property behind event where something
has occurred and then the object can
tell other objects that's that that
something has occurred so that they can
react to that particular event so these
are the three main uh
traits which are properties events and
methods
you can read more about this particular
white paper i will not go into the
details because it's a long white paper
but it's a very well written white paper
which will give you a very good
understanding of how java bean
specification was written what was the
thought process behind it so coming back
to the code if you want to just write it
it can be very simple to write just
write any class and say implements
serializable so it will ask you to
provide a cl version uid so you can
write this here then you can create your
attributes as normal private attributes
you can create public methods to access
and manipulate these attributes in the
forms of getters and setters so these
are the public methods to to access and
manipulate these attributes here we have
a parameterized constructor which will
not be required or which should not be
there when you're creating a java bean
it should just be like this because when
we talk about the public know arcs
constructor as we discussed in the very
first lectures that
you do not need to provide the default
constructor java will automatically
provide a default constructor for every
class so you don't need to write
something like this it's just not needed
because you can write it but it has no
value attached it has no meaning because
this is something exact this kind of
code is already generated by java
compiler when it compiles this
particular class so a public default no
argument constructor implementing
serializable private properties and
public methods and you can have
additional event methods as well which i
talked about just when we were going
through the white paper and that's all
pretty much what a java bean is so you
can see it's it's just a java class but
some additional uh
specifications which a java class has to
follow to be called as a javabean so
before we begin with what exactly is a
java api we will understand what java
is so basically java consists of two
major components that are java runtime
environment and java development kit
so when we get into java's api we might
want to dig a little deep into java's
development kit
so jdk consists of three more major
components that are the java's compiler
java virtual machine and apis now we
will learn each one of them in a bit
more detailed way so at first we have
the java's compiler
so java compiler can be defined as a
software program that is designed to
convert the high level that is the user
return or user readable code into the
computer readable code that is the
machine level or byte code
so this particular byte code will be
transferred to the next state where we
find the jvm
so what is jvm so jvm is an abbreviation
for java's virtual machine so java's
virtual machine is responsible for
processing all the byte codes and
providing an output to the user
next we find our topic for today's
discussion that is the java api so just
like java's virtual machine and compiler
java's apis are the integral software
packages that come with the jdk the
primary intention of api is to establish
communications between different
applications so on my screen you can see
a pictorial representation of java api's
architecture so at first we have the
java's program on the topmost layer so
this particular segment will be having
the user return program and user
language
followed by that we have the interpreter
javas api and the java's virtual machine
which are responsible for reading and
compiling the java's program so at the
last final level we have the application
hardware which is responsible for
interacting to the java's program so
this is how the java aps architecture
looks like now followed by this let's
dive into the next topic
so in the next topic we find the types
of developers using various types of
apis for different jobs
so at first we have the open developers
next we have the internal developers and
at last we have the partner developers
don't worry we will understand each of
these developers in a bit more detail
and along with some examples for a
better understanding
so at first we have the open developers
so open developers are used by top-end
companies so leading companies provide
access to their apis as open source
through authentication via a unique
secret key to keep track and ensure the
legal usage
so basically what happens here is there
might be some big companies like social
media companies or some other companies
which provide the apf they use for their
applications as open source to the
developers so these open developers get
access to their apis through getting
authentication
so they'll be creating a profile they'll
be providing the research details of
their application like what are they
using that particular api for and other
reasons to use those apis then they get
the unique secret key from the owner of
that api
and that's done just to keep track that
the api provided is not misused
so the open developers majorly include
the b2c teams and some of the major
companies that provide the apis for open
developers are twitter and telnets so
one best example is the twitter where
the twitter provides twitter api for the
twitter developer accounts for using
that for any kind of developing things
or some data science applications and
much more
so followed by the open developers next
we have
the internal developers
so you can consider internal developers
as an organization
so the internal developers belong to a
specific organization and work in a
close environment these apis run with a
high security that can establish
communication between the application
and the application hardware
so only the internal developers that is
the developers belonging to that
particular organization have the access
to that particular api
so this particular type of apis
run on a high security level
so internal developers majorly include
b2c teams b2b teams a to a teams and b2e
teams
so some of the major companies that
provide the internal apis are instagram
google mail and google cloud virtual
machines
next we have the partner apis
so the partner developers are similar or
like internal developers but the only
difference is there is a collaboration
between two or multiple companies for
example consider yourself to be linked
with a different company and you both
wanted to create an application so only
you both can have access to that
particular api that you are using to
create your application
so partner developers majorly use the
b2c teams and the major companies
providing the partner apis are microsoft
and fenextra
so with this we finished the first topic
that was what is api and who exactly
uses it and for what purposes now we
dive into the next segment where we
learn the need for java apis
so why exactly we need java apis
now java apis are used for multiple
reasons but the three most important
reasons for which we use java apis are
to streamline the operations improvise
the businesses and finally create some
powerful applications we will discuss
each one of them in a bit more detail
so the first one is to streamline
operating procedures we have multiple
social media applications like twitter
facebook whatsapp etc followed by that
we have multiple delivery applications
such as amazon flipkart then we have the
fnb such as zomanto swiggy etc so all
these applications are running smooth
and hassle free because of the
significant improvement in the
implementation of java apis by using
java's apis users are provided with
multiple options on the screen so this
kind of approach makes the functionality
very simple and easy to use
followed by this the next important
requirement is
to improvise the business
introducing apis to the public leads
many companies to release private data
to generate new ideas fixing existing
bugs and receive new ways to improvise
operations the twitter developer account
is an example for api that gives
programmers private api keys to access
twitter data and develop applications
followed by that we have the third one
which is to create the powerful
applications
online banking has changed the industry
forever and eps offer the customers
ability to manage their finances
digitally with complete simplicity so
this is made possible only by the use of
apis
now followed by this we will dive into
the next topic where we understand the
types of java apis
so basically there are four different
types of apis in java
they are public private partner and
composite we will discuss each one of
these apis in a bit more detail
at first we will deal with the public
api
so what are public apis public means
open so public or open apis are java's
apis that come with the jdk
and they do not have any strict
restrictions about how developers use
them
so followed by the public apis we have
the private apis
so the private or internal apis are
developed for a specific organization
these particular apis will be accessible
through the authentication by only the
employees belonging to that particular
organization
so followed by private apis we have the
partner apis
so similar to private apis even partner
apis are having some authentication
process to use so
the only difference is here instead of
one organization we might have two or
multiple organizations and the employees
belonging to that particular group of
organizations will be able to access the
apis and implement them or use them
followed by partner apis we have the
last one which is the composite api
composite apis are microservices and
developers build them by combining
several service apis now that we have
covered the different types of apis let
us now discuss the categorization of
java apis based on the services that
different varieties of apis in java
provide
so data and api services are another way
to categorize java apis other than the
previous type which is the public
private partner and composite apis are
also classified based on their data
manipulation capabilities and the
variety of services they offer so this
type of categorization
has four different types which are the
internal api services external api
services crud operations and user
interface services we will understand
each one of them in a bit more detail at
first we will understand internal api
services
internal api services are developed to
offer organizations services specific to
that particular organizations
these services include only complex data
operations and internal processes
followed by internal api we have the
external api external api are open
source apis that developers integrate
into existing application or website so
internal apis are something similar to
private apis and externals apis are
something similar to
public apis next we have the crud
operations so cred apis provide data
manipulation operations over various
data storage units such as software and
service that is sas and relational
database management systems such as
rdbms using standard data storage unit
connecting tools like database
connectivity that is jdbc etc
next we have the user interface services
user interface service apis are open
source apis that allow developers to
build user interfaces for mobile devices
computers and electronics
now let's examine the rules and
protocols that java apis must
follow
so that brings us to api service
protocols
the rules and protocols guide the
different functionalities of java apis
so different apis have different service
protocols let's consider an example for
restful api service protocol as an
example
so for a typical restful api developers
must follow the following rules
for a typical restful api developers
must follow these rules
stateless uniform interface client
server cache layer no worries we will
discuss each one of these protocols in
detail first we will discuss stateless
so what exactly is stateless
so since the restful api follows client
server architecture by default it is
recommended that restful api services to
be stateless all the time
next we have the uniform interface the
entities in a restful api are server and
clients
applications that run on global scale
need uniform client and server interface
through hypertext transfer protocol or
http and uniform resource identifiers
uri will allocate the required resources
next we have the client server
the client server model used in the
restful api should be fault tolerant
both the client and server are expected
to operate independently the change is
made at the client and should not affect
the server and vice versa
next we have the cache including a cache
memory allows the application to record
intermediate responses and run faster in
real time a restful api also includes
the cache memory and next we have the
layer
a restful api is built using layers
layers of api are loosely coupled or
independent from each other each layer
contributes a different level of
hierarchy and also supports
encapsulation next we will go through
some frequently used apis
so this is the list of most frequently
used apis in real time so we have web
api facebook 4j twitter 4g android api
java advanced imaging java data objects
and you can also see the acronyms for
them in the right column so some of them
have no acronyms and some of them have
acronyms for example we have android api
as google java advanced imaging as jei
data objects as jdo etc so moving into
the next slide we have a few more apis
so we have restful apis
java media frameworks java per system
apis java speech api java 3d java usb
for windows etc and similarly on the
right column we have their acronyms so
for java media frameworks we have jmf
for restful apis we have nothing and
java 3d we have j3d java speech api as
js api and few others so followed by
this we will advance into the next topic
where we will discuss about the
advantages of using java's apis
now using java's apis will help you with
multiple advantages now we will discuss
the most important advantages of using
java's apis
so the first one we have the extensive
sql support apis in java enable a wide
range of sql support services in users
applications through a component-based
interface
next we have applications apis in java
provide effortless access to all of an
application's major software components
and easily deliver services
next we have efficiency
java's apis are highly efficient because
they enable rapid application
development also the data that the
application generates is always
available online
next we have the automation api allows
computers to automatically upload a
download update and delete data
automatically without human interaction
followed by that we have integration
java apis can integrate to any
application and website and provide a
fluidic experience with dynamic data
delivery
followed by that we have scope
java's apis make websites application
and information available to a wide
range of users and audience
followed by that we have customization
java aps enabled developers and
businesses to build applications that
personalize user interface and data
and finally we have the adaptability
java aps are highly flexible and
adaptable because they can easily accept
feature updates and change to frameworks
and operating systems let's get started
with spring framework so spring
framework is the most popular web
application framework available out
there today and all of the big companies
from netflix to whatnot use spring
framework to build the modern day java
applications so before we go any further
let's understand why do we need a
framework so let's understand this with
the help of a diagram so let me just
open a blank paint page and let me show
you what i mean by a framework and why
do we need this so we built simple
applications so far but if you have to
build a enterprise grade web application
you will have a front end probably where
you will have what you see in the
browser so you will have the html the
javascript or or any other
java enterprise edition classes like jsp
servlet etc then you will have a backend
where your java classes are present
which contains the business logic so the
business logic and then you have a
database where you have the you store
the basic basically the whole data so
you have these three different layers we
also call this a three tier architecture
so you cannot build all of this by just
using the core java classes which we
talked about you need to
do more integrations you need to use
more different programming languages and
concepts to build a complete enterprise
grid application and if you try to build
all of this by yourself then it's going
to take a lot of time and lot of effort
that's why we have frameworks which
basically create provide the structure
to create these three layers so that's
why we have this frameworks and in the
frameworks spring is the most popular
framework it provides the structure to
write all these these three layers one
of the reasons i did not talk about the
the java enterprise edition technologies
like servlets and gsps because nobody
works on them today even if you learn
about servlet it's good to know the
conceptual overview of servlets but
nobody today builds applications on jsps
and servlets that's the reason i did not
talk about it because today we have
sophisticated front-end frameworks like
angularjs or react.js or amber js and
what not and it is hydrating at a very
fast speed so there is literally
practically no need for a java developer
today to learn about gsp because i can
bet you on that you can take it in
written for me nobody is going to build
the gsp app based applications in 2021
everybody is going to use some sort of
front-end framework to build that and
then you have a back-end in the back end
you have the exact core java classes
like i just explained so you will be
using the java beans and you will be
basically using the pure java concepts
of collections and and etc to write the
backend logic using the java classes and
then you will need a jdbc connection to
write to a database as well so you would
need a database as well and spring
provides connectors and
specifications to support all of these
three layers that's the reason so
generally when you talk about a web
application let's talk about web
application because java primarily is
used in web applications so in a web
application you basically see a browser
window where you load a particular page
but what happens behind the scene this
browser has some html and some js maybe
and this code is basically calling some
endpoint
this end point is present in the backend
layer so this end point is present in
the backend layer that end point
transfers the control to the business
layer where you have your core business
logic return and then the business layer
transfers the control to the data layer
or some people also call it dow layer
this dow layer then talks to the
database that's how a web application
works and that's what that's the
architecture you will mostly be
following whenever you are building any
enterprise grid application in any
organization so spring provides support
for all of these parts this obviously is
written by angular and react and other
frameworks but this is this whole
section is basically presented or
supported by spring so with that let's
understand a bit more about spring
framework so if you go to the spring
official website it talks about some of
the value propositions spring is used
heavily like i said it's used everywhere
it's very flexible framework there are a
couple of concepts which string provides
which is around inversion of control and
dependency injection and i will talk
about these concepts in a while uh
when we'll talk more about the spring's
components it makes uh it's quite
productive and quite fast as well so
it's very fast to build application on
on spring it has a whole dedicated
security module as well so it's quite
secure by design and the spring
community is huge so you can find lot of
support on internet let's learn bit more
about the spring's core components or
core technologies so if you talk about
these strings core components these are
the springs core components so you have
a testing module you have you have a
core module first of all inside the
techno in the core components you have a
core module which has ioc containers
resources events i'll talk a bit about
that it has a it has its own testing
component so it provides very good
support for testing applications it has
a data access component the data access
component is used to provide connections
utilities to the database because like i
mentioned your application will be
talking to the database and spring
provides a complete dedicated component
to be used whenever you are dealing
whenever you're talking to the database
it also provides a web servlet component
uh to uh provide support for spring mvc
which i will be covering in the next
session web sockets and stomp and
messaging frameworks etc it also
supports reactive or asynchronous
programming if you want to do that it
provides a lot of integration
capabilities in the integration modules
if you want to do jms or jmx or email or
tasks scheduling etc and it also
provides language support to support
internationalized internationalization
of the applications so
it it has a lot of different components
but we will focus on this core component
which is of the interest here so let's
talk about that the first thing which
you need to know about spring is its
support for inversion of control and it
provides that support by creating an
inversion of control container what do
we mean by inversion of control the
basic idea is let me
take any random example and i will be
able to communicate the idea behind this
so let's go to any simple example which
i have already covered let's go to
method calling for example so we had a
student class we created a student class
simple student class three properties
constructor and public getters and
setters and then i created a main class
and i initialized the student object so
to the responsibility of creating the
student object lies with the student
class itself student class have to be
explicitly initialized to be having an
object of the student so this creates a
problem because when you're dealing with
uh enterprise grade frameworks you might
need to create lot of objects on the fly
whenever the
end point is talking to the business
layer
if i take the reference of this
architecture if the endpoint is talking
to the business layer classes business
layer classes are talking to the data
access layer classes so when the
business layer classes needs to talk to
the data access layer classes the data
access layer classes needs to have an
object because that communication
happens between objects only so who
creates those objects if every time the
data access object has been has been
called and if we provide
if we pass that responsibility to the
dao class to create the object or every
time the endpoint talks to the business
class we ask the business layer to
create the objects it becomes a lot of
painful process because every time you
will be doing this new student
everywhere you need a student object
which is very painful process so what
spring says it says okay involved the
control of creating the object so let's
not give the responsibility of creating
the object to the class let's give that
responsibility to the framework so the
framework will be responsible for
creating the objects of a class and it's
not the class who will be responsible
for creating its own objects so
generally outside the framework a class
is responsible for getting its object
but with spring spring involves this
responsibility that's why we call it
inversion of control the control is
inverted it's reversed and now it's the
frameworks responsibility to create the
objects you will also hear about a
concept called dependency injection a
lot in context of ioc and dependency
injection is an implementation of the
ioc concept so using springs dependency
injection mechanism you can inject the
object of any class into any class once
you do that spring dependency is going
to use the inversion of control concept
and create the object that's about ioc
and di or dependency injection then the
other modules like resources will
provide a way to refer different files
and properties if you want to then you
have a validation module as well which
will provide different validation
constructs because once you receive the
data you might need to run a lot of
validation right and writing the
validation by yourself can be very
painful so it provides a validation
framework as well by providing the
validator interface you can use this
particular framework to write the
validation rules checking the name not
empty etc similarly it also supports an
expression language if you want to use
that so the expression language support
is wide very wide in fact you can create
an expression parser and you can do the
expression language evaluation using the
a spring expression language similarly
it also provides support for
aspect-oriented programming now again
all these concepts of validation and
spring expression language and resource
support the you probably would need
hours of reading to learn about these
concepts and i'm just running through
them just to tell you about these
concepts and do read about why do you
need resources why do you want to do
validation why do you need an expression
language what is aspect-oriented
programming read about all of those
concepts because they are not related to
java they are generic concepts which
will be applicable to any programming
language so any enterprise application
you build in any programming language
you would need to do the validation you
would need to do the resource reference
management you would need to have an
expression language you would need to
have aspect oriented programming support
so this is just to tell you that that
java does provide an aop or aspect
oriented programming support as well and
it has a lot of
apis available for that along with that
it also provides very good logging
capabilities because you definitely need
to log all the actions which the
framework or your objects are taking so
this was a very quick lightning overview
about spring i understand it's not
possible to cover all the concept of a
framework as sophisticated and as smart
as spring in in 10 to 15 minutes lecture
so treat this as an introduction session
and like i said read more about all of
these components i just explained the
core because this is this is sort of the
main building block of spring framework
and then you have other supporting uh
components as well so do check out the
documentation there are tons of examples
available in fact in the springs
official website itself if you go to the
spring guide section if you go to the
learn and you go to the guide section
there are awesome getting started and
topical guides and tutorials available
so for example how to build a restful
web service how to schedule tasks how to
consume a restful web service how to
build a simple java project with maven
how to upload files with string how to
do messaging with readers which is
basically a caching framework how to do
messaging using spring to rabbit mq
rabbit mq is a messaging framework so
there are tons of examples available
here very good documentation and very
robust documentation do check out the
examples to learn more about this let's
get started with mvc and the
implementation of mvc using spring so
before we go any further let's first
understand what do we mean by an mvc
application so in the previous lectures
i discussed about the three-tier
application where you had a presentation
layer you had a business layer and then
you had a database layer which is
talking to the database and that's how
we built a three-tier application which
can also evolve into an n-tier
application but when when the web
development started the most popular
concept which came out was
m v c m stands for model v stands for
view and c stands for controller so the
idea was that these three components
together can render a web application
and how they render the web application
is basically that the controller is
going to receive the request which is
coming from the web browser then the
controller will have the knowledge of
where the business logic for that
particular request will be residing so
the controller is going to invoke the
model the corresponding model which is
required to execute the business logic
of the request and the controller will
also have the knowledge of what response
page to be sent back to the user so we
are talking about the response page here
not response remember that because it's
a web application so the model view
controller architecture basically was
designed uh to keep in mind that you
have a web application where a request
is coming from and you need to process
some business logic and then you need to
return back with a page response which
is going to be displayed on the web
browser of the client machine so that's
why we had these three components as
model view and controller controller
taking up the request then
finding the right model for it which can
execute the business logic and then also
finding the right view for it which can
render the business logic processed by
the model so that's a quick overview
about model view controller or mvc
architecture do read about it in detail
to understand how this works but like i
mentioned that mvc the most popular mvc
implementation is provided by spring
spring is the most popular mvc framework
and the way spring
implements it is something which i have
drawn already here so let's understand
how this works so first the request
comes from the web browser and spring
has
the very first welcome servlet which is
called dispatcher servlet any request
which is coming to the spring enabled
web application will first hit
dispatcher servlet and once the request
comes to the dispatcher servlet the
dispatcher servlet has all the knowledge
of all the controllers of all the view
resolvers which i will talk about in a
while and of all the views as well it
also has knowledge about handler
mappings which again i will just discuss
now so the basic premise is that
dispatcher servlet is the component
which has knowledge about literally
everything happening in your application
and that's why dispatcher servlet is the
first servlet or the first component
which receives your web request so once
the request comes here first of all it
looks at the path and finds out the
right handler for it the right
controller for it and the way it does
that by using the handler mapping
component or handler mapping logic which
is provided out of the box by spring
framework so the handler mapping logic
will tell the dispatcher servlet which
particular controller is going to
process the request which is coming
because every request will have a
different controller return so whatever
the type of request is whatever the path
of the request is based on that the
dispatcher servlet is going to find a
particular controller once the
controller is found like i mentioned
earlier the controller will have
knowledge about the right model to
invoke for that particular request model
is nothing
but basically a java class holding the
business logic for this particular
request so it will invoke that java
class and get all the business logic
processed and then it is going to return
a model and view object
view is here simply pointing to the ui
response which you are going to send
back to the user it can be a jsp page it
can be an html page it can be any other
view technology so anything which is
which is used to render a web
application on a web page is view and
controller is going to send both the
model and view information back to the
dispatcher servlet the dispatcher
servlet will take the view part of it
and go to another component which is
again provided by spring which is called
view resolver the view resolver will
have the knowledge to see which
particular actual jsp or template to
invoke for the view value coming from
the controller so based on the value
which is returned by the controller a
view resolver is going to return the
right page mapping and once the
dispatcher servlet knows the page
mapping it is just going to invoke that
page by calling the view component so
dispatcher servlet handler mapping
controller view resolver and view these
five components together help render a
web mvc application in the spring
framework so that was about the theory
of how spring works now let's move on to
uh example to understand how this works
in action so here i have already built a
spring mvc application and if you're
wondering how to build that there's an
easy way to do that using spring
initializer and that's also the
recommended way actually if you go to
the documentation of spring you will see
that it recommends creating a new
project from scratch using the spring
initializer utility which is provided by
spring out of the box so just go to web
a web browser and ta and type start dot
spring dot io you will get this page
where you can specify what type of
project you want to create so it is
going to create the basic skeleton for
any spring application automatically for
you it's probably like i said it's
probably the fastest way to get started
with spring so we will choose a maven
project maven is again a dependency
management tool which is used to
download any kind of jars for your
application so we are going to use a
maven project and we want to create a
skeleton for a java application we are
going to use the latest released version
of spring or spring boot which is 2.4.2
it says spring boot here but don't get
confused with it we are going to use
just the mvc classes and not the spring
boot specific logic yet then you provide
your group artifact id and the name for
your jar you provide a description you
can provide a welcome package name
whatever suits you and then how you
would like to run your application
whether you would like to package your
application as a jar file which is a
java archive or you would like to run it
as a web archive which is a var file so
you can choose either packaging mode and
it is going to add appropriate
dependencies inside the project to
support the packaging of jar or the
packaging of var then you can also
choose a java version so you can see
there are three java versions listed
here which are 8 11 and 15 so whichever
java version you are working on you can
choose that particular version and once
you have set all with everything just
hit generate once you do that it is
going to create a project here and then
you can import this project just as a
normal project inside the eclipse ide
and that's exactly what i've done for
this initial project which is showing a
very basic hello world sort of example
for how spring mvc will work so this
whole structure will automatically be
created for you and like i said it was a
maven project and in every maven project
you will have a pom.xml if i double
click on this it is going to open this
xml and it will list down all the
dependencies which my project needs to
have let's understand the dependencies
as well so this project is currently
using the properties of 1.8 but that's
and that's fine you can obviously
definitely change this value i just kept
it as 1.8 for now because i'm not using
any new functionality yet in the
dependencies section you will see all
the dependencies or all the jars which
are required by the spring application
to run successfully the first dependency
we see here is about daimy leaf and
daimy leaf basically is a view
technology similar to jsp or similar to
servlets
technically where you can supply use
this daimy leaf templates which are
basically just htmls with some dynamic
values and you can use these dimeylife
templates to render web pages for your
spring mvc application if you want to
use some other view technology you need
to include the dependency of that view
technology here instead of dye my life
so that's about that then you need to
include the spring boot starter web the
spring boot starter web is going to
enable your application to become a web
application then this is this is a this
is basically a good to have dependency
which you can have in your project which
will help you deploy the project at
runtime automatically without restarting
the server because the web application
will be running on a server on a web
server basically or an application
server technically because it needs to
run somewhere so that it so that clients
can access it that's how a web client
architecture work or the server client
architecture works so this dependency
will allow you to deploy changes
dynamically at runtime without
restarting the server then this
dependency is for tests if you're
writing any unit tests and then you have
a plugin which will allow to run this
particular project with a single command
which we will see in a while so that's
about the dependency tour now let's look
at what is in the src main java in the
src main java i just have two classes
one is the main class which will have a
public static void main method and this
is the entry point of the spring
application and then i have a controller
class i already talked about what
controller is but i will come back to
that in a while let's understand the
rest of the files as well the next one
is src main resources where you will
have your view technology data available
like i mentioned it is using diamy leaf
templates currently and basically like i
said they are technically htmls with
some dynamic data so i've created a
templates folder under src main
resources which will automatically be
generated by spring initializer and then
under templates i have placed an html
file it's a pure html file with the only
difference is this value so this is what
the dynamic value means which which is
supported by dima leaf templates
otherwise this is pure html it's just a
paragraph with a header and this is the
dynamic value which i am populating it
also has application.properties which
has nothing but you can use this
particular file to supply environment
specific properties for the development
environment or the testing environment
or the real production environment if
you have any unit tests those will go
here under src test java and this is the
system library already provided
supported by eclipse itself and i
already talked about the palm.xml you
also see couple of more files created by
springboot if you want to use that you
can use that to run the run the program
from the command line as a utility
otherwise you can just use ambient
spring boot command which i will show
you in a while there's also a gradle
folder which you can ignore probably we
don't need this because we are just
using maven and we are not using gradle
gradle is another dependency management
tool very very similar to maven so you
can ignore this folder right now so
that's the structure and now let's come
back to the controllers remember i told
you that controllers are the ones which
receive the request so from the
dispatcher servlet which i talked about
here after the dispatcher servlet the
request comes to the controller so once
you hit a particular url then you need
to create a controller for that url
mapping remember that you need to create
a controller for almost every url
mapping you are having in your
application there should be some mapping
to some controller somewhere so i've
created a greeting controller and the
way you specify or you make a simple
class as a controller is by putting the
add the red controller annotation this
is the annotation which is supported by
spring and you can put this annotation
on top of any class and that class will
be treated as controller by spring and
the moment the moment you put this this
class will also be registered with the
dispatcher servlet and like i mentioned
the controller's main purpose is to
receive the requests the web requests
which are coming from the client and the
way you can receive the requests to a
controller by providing the exact url
mapping so if somebody runs this web
application and says slash greeting then
this particular method should get
invoked and how you define that is with
the get mapping annotation use the get
mapping annotation to provide the url
path whenever somebody invokes this url
path this method would be getting called
and when this method is getting called
at that same time this url can also
accept some query parameters we call
that as the request parameters in in the
spring language so you can use the
request parameters as an annotation
to provide a placeholder for the
variable for which the value will be
supplied in the url so slash greeting if
if you call this url something like this
then it will work because you have a
variable called name which is which is
being parsed as a query string because
you have used the request paramentation
so we'll see an example of that when
once we run this application and how we
can supply the query string but you use
the request param annotation to supply
the query string parameters to the url
you can mention if the parameter is
mandatory or non-mandatory if the
required equal to true was there then
this parameter would be mandatory you
can also supply a default value if
somebody is if the client is not
providing this query parameter at all
would you like to set any default value
if yes you can supply the default value
here and then you just give a
placeholder name like i said then the
second argument which your your methods
which are intercepting the request
should have is the model argument and
remember i told you that the controller
will have what should have the knowledge
about the model and from here that
knowledge comes you this particular
method will expect you to provide a
model argument as well so if somebody
calls this application and provides the
urls with slash greeting this particular
method will get invoked and then the
code inside this method will be getting
executed so it's a very simple code
right now but this is where your whole
logic will go remember that but here i'm
just saying model dot add attribute name
with the value which is coming from the
query string parameter that's all i'm
doing here and
remember i told you that the model will
hold the business logic so here this is
the business logic where whatever query
string parameter which is coming from
the request param i'm capturing that and
i'm adding that value with the variable
name in the attributes of the model so
my model is set and after that i need to
return the view so that this particular
file name will be intercepted by the
view resolver here if you remember we
talked about the view resolver so when
we return
greetings as a string that string goes
here and then dispatcher servlet looks
out asks the view resolver to find a
particular html matching with this
particular text so view resolver is
going to look at under src main
resources slash templates to see if
there is a file with the name greeting
available or not since we have that file
available the spring is going to render
this particular file supplying the model
attribute value name now remember the
greeting.html had the exact same
variable name so this variable name
should exactly match with this variable
name here if you do if you make a
mistake here this is not going to work
because the model is holding the
business logic and i'm printing that
business logic inside the view using the
dye my lift template syntax which is
dollar curly braces so whenever you have
to print any variable or a model
attribute or any runtime value inside a
dhammalife template then you need to use
the dollar curly braces syntax to do
that so that was about a quick overview
of how this application is is written
right now and that's all the code is
here now it's time to run this
application so one of the simplest way
to run this application would be to
provide a spring at the run
configuration here for the spring
application or you can choose another
way which is to first have a look at the
spring web content application which is
the entry point so once your application
boots up this is the first line of code
which is going to get executed and to
make sure that this code works make sure
that you have the add the red spring
boot application annotation on top of
the entry point class so this is this is
sort of the mandate which spring will
force you to put in front of the or on
top of the entry point class to to treat
this class as the first entry point when
you run the project so to run the
project what we will do that we will
just go to the command line and we will
say mvn spring boot run so let's do that
and let me open the terminal for that so
i have opened a get bash prompt here you
can also open the classic windows
terminal but this is something which git
installs by default if you install git
on your system it's pretty much exactly
the same it's just more unix-like but
it's also just a simple terminal shell
utility to access your file system so i
have gone to the project which we were
working with in the eclipse ide and this
is the path of the project so once you
reach to the path what you would like to
run is just say mvn
spring hyphen boot colon run that's it
and you hit enter once you write mvn
sprinkle hyphen boot call and run you
will see lot of code lot of logs here
where it is going to run all the compile
all the java classes run any tests if
there are any and then it is going to
start the web content application you
can see and once the application is
started you will get this message that
everything is run one of the interesting
thing which you can see here is that it
is also spinning up an application
server automatically for you and that
application server here which is being
used by spring is apache tomcat
technically apache tomcat is a servlet
container and it's not a full fledged
application server but just to get the
point across you can use apache tomcat
as an application server which is being
used here
out of the box by spring if you don't
want to use apache tomcat and you want
to use something else you can do that as
well so now everything is ready and we
can now execute the application to
observe the output so for that let me
open a fresh browser window so that we
don't get any cached response and now i
can just type localhost 8080 and if i
hit entry enter i i get a white level
error page because there is no home page
for tomcat defined but there is a home
page for my application defined in fact
let's try to access the url which we
wrote in the greeting controller the url
was slash greeting so let's copy this
and let's put this here so
localhost8080
greeting and if i hit enter i get the
message hello world let me just zoom
this in a bit so that you can see so you
will see this hello world message here
by putting this url why do we see hello
world let's go back to the controller so
when you call this url this greeting
controller got invoked since we did not
provide any query string parameter the
default value which was world was picked
up and this world value was stored in
the name variable and the name variable
was added as an attribute to the model
and then we were using the greeting.html
and we were printing the name variable
since the name variable was holding the
value world so the message came as hello
world
with an exclamation and that's the
output which we see here now let's try
to supply the query query string
parameter the way you do that is provide
a question mark provide the key of the
query string parameter and the value you
want to put here so let's put simply
code as a value and hit enter so now the
message got changed and now it says
hello simply code so what happened here
is that whatever con query string
parameter we supplied that got passed
here at par as part of the request param
and the value of simply code got stored
in this name key and in turn in this
name variable and then i added the same
value into another name attribute and
added that attribute to the model so now
this name here is storing the value
simply code and then the all the things
work exactly is the same as i just
described it goes to greeting.html and
it prints whatever is stored in the name
attribute coming from the model let's
get started with spring boot and how we
can build a simple application using
spring boot before we go further let's
understand why we need spring boot and
the basic idea of spring boot is to
build restful web services if you want
to know more about what are restful
services please you can read about the
restful concept as a concept what does
rest stand for but the basic idea is
that if you are accessing anything over
http then that particular component can
be built as a restful component and
spring boot is the most popular choice
for building restful web services today
and even in fact micro services which
you might have heard about so you can
build micro services which also run on
https using spring boot so what i'm
showing you right now is the official
guide of spring which you can use to
build an application with spring boot it
will list down all the requisites which
you need in terms of the
jdk installations maven on and how to
complete this guide etc etc you can
again use the same spring initializer
which i talked about in the previous
session you can use this to generate a
spring boot project for you specifically
so all those options are available here
so i've already done that and i'm not
going to repeat what i just did in the
previous session and will directly jump
to an ide where i have created a sample
spring boot application and the
structure here you can see the structure
would look very similar with one change
that in the previous example when we
were dealing with mbc we had an src main
resources folder and that src main
resources folder was having all the web
components or the htmls but since in
restful web services you do not render
the html but you just send back the
response the response can be the
response body can be pure xml or it can
be pure json but you do not send back
and view and that's the main difference
between spring mvc and spring boot that
in spring mvc it will you are required
to return a view technology like in the
in the previous session we sent a dime
leaf template which is basically in html
you can also written a gsp but with
spring boot you do not deal with the
view technology and that's the world we
are living in today when you write
spring boot you do not have to worry
about how this is going to be rendered
on the web page whether it is going to
be rendered using html or whatnot what
you need to take care of using spring
boot is to return the right response
body the exact text of the response and
that's it so with that in mind the
spring boot was born and the structure
apart from that the structure would look
very similar there is a palm.xml here
which will provide all the list of jars
and dependencies which are required for
this particular project so you can see
all the dependencies here pretty much
the similar ones we have a starter web
we have a starters test and we have a
spring boot maven plugin and we have an
application file which is the entry
point again having a public static void
main method so you need to put the at
the red spring boot application at the
top of the class to make it an entry
point if you don't do this spring boot
will not run this class and spring boot
will
even not run your application so what we
are doing as part of this example that
we are just printing all the beans which
are provided by spring that's all we are
doing like i said it's a very
lightweight and the introductory session
so we will keep the logics to minimum
and i'm just getting all the bean
definitions sorting the bean definitions
and just printing them one by one how do
you get the bean definition you get that
with this application context class
which is returned when you run the
application and how you run the
application is basically using this line
where you say spring application dot run
and you supply application dot class
with any command line arguments which
you might want to use once you do this
it is going to return an application
context object to you and the
application context object can be used
to get all the bean definitions by
calling this method which says get beam
definition names so that's the basic
logic which is being run in the main
class now we also have a controller but
this time it's not a web controller but
it's a rest controller so you see in the
previous example we just had written
something like this it was just a pure
controller but here we have become more
specific we are saying that hey this is
not a simple mvc controller but this is
a spring boot controller or technically
a rest controller so spring provides a
separate annotation for that which is at
the rate rest controller so you write
that particular annotation or that on
the top of the controller class which
you are creating and then you provide a
request mapping similar to what we did
in spring mvc but while you return it
you do not return a view technology you
just return the raw response here i'm
just returning a string but you can
return a json object you can return an
xml object or whatever you want to but
not a view technology that's what i'm
doing like like you can see there's
literally nothing i'm doing in this it's
just a simple
string return statement which i have
printed here and that's all the code i
have right now here i just have these
two classes okay so that was all about
what i have written in the project and
now it's time to run the project so i
have just reached to the location on
inside my terminal where the project
pom.xml was present and if i just do an
ls you will see that there is a palm.xml
available here and all the code
directory is also available here so now
i will just run this application and to
run this application i'm just going to
type mvn spring hyphen boot colon run
and hit enter once i do that the spring
application is going to spring boot
application is going to get started and
let's go back to uh the controller and
actually the main app main end point and
see what we were doing there i did a cis
out here which said let's inspect the
beams provided by spring boot and then i
was printing all the bean names and if i
go back to the output i will see the
same line being written here which was
around let's inspect the beans so you
can see that message which says let's
inspect the beans provided by spring
boot and then all the beans which are
available in the application context are
printed here so that's that's the basic
idea which i want to give you that you
can actually build a spring boot
application and you can write your rest
controllers return a string body from it
and once this is run then you can also
run your application for from the web
browser as well so let's try to hit that
particular url which i wrote here so the
url of hello country so for that let me
just open a new cognito window and our
application is already running so if i
just say http localhost 8080 slash i get
this message here which says greetings
from spring boot and this is the message
which we were sending from the rest
controller so this validates our
understanding that we can invoke a crest
controller which is a spring boot rest
controller via the same method but this
time we are not getting an html but we
are just returning this particular
string now you can use the string in any
ways you want so it depends upon the
consumer so that's all i want to cover
as part of the spring boot now spring
boot is a huge huge topic and we can
spend hours and hours talking about
spring boot but since this is more of an
introductory session so i just wanted
the concept to get introduced and
remember the value proposition of why
you would need spring boot the basic
idea is to build restful web services or
build restful micro services that's the
basic idea behind using spring boot in
your applications and also remember the
difference between web mvc spring mvc
application and spring boot application
spring mvc is for building web
application spring boot is for building
restful applications which might not
have a web interface integrated with
them at that moment so that's all i want
to cover for this particular session and
in the next session we are going to have
a look at an advanced java project using
some of the concepts which we might have
learned during this whole journey and
that would be the last session of this
particular tutorial series let's get
started with a demo of a project which
is using spring boot to build a restful
web service so a restful web service is
nothing but any end point which you can
access or you can consume the data from
via an http layer or via a simply a web
layer because most of the web traffic
which we deal with is built on http so
to take an example if you go to any
website where you sometimes see on the
top right corner you see today's weather
so how is that today's weather coming in
it's coming in via a rest web service
the website which you are accessing is
basically hitting an http endpoint uh
which is uh where the where the weather
application is sitting and it asks for
the weather data and the dressed web
application just returns the data and
that's how the website is able to show
you the current weather so restful web
services are everywhere and they are the
most popular way to build applications
today where you just build your restful
web service and you expose an http url
and then the consumers need to just
access that http url to consume the data
from your application and you see this
makes it very easy because there is no
data type restrictions there is no tight
coupling here it's just an http endpoint
so that's the basic idea and we will
look at a project where we will be using
spring boot to build a restful web
service and then we will try to run that
web service to save some data and also
to return some data so here on the on
the package explorer you see i have
created a project called rest service
and let's just walk through the
structure of it and then we'll go into
the details of it so we have an src main
java where i have a package and i have
bunch of classes here and before we go
to the classes let's first also access
the dependency file because every
project needs some dependencies some
jars to execute it for example spring
itself is basically a jar so you need to
include the spring jar in your project
so that your project can become a spring
project and there are generally two
dependency tools one is maven and one is
gradle in this particular project i am
using maven
dependency tool for downloading and
managing the dependencies which are
needed to run this project successfully
and the way you will find if it's a
maven project or if it's a gradle
project for a maven project you will see
a file called
pom.xml pom.xml and if it's a gradle
project you will see a dot gradle file
that's how you can spot whether the
project is using maven for dependency
management or it is using gradle for
dependency management so let's open the
palm.xml since it's an xml file it will
be a bit verbose but
if you just read it piece by piece it
will become easier to understand first
of all since this is a spring project i
need to include the parent dependency
which brings lot of good defaults
sensible defaults from spring boot
automatically and this is the jar name
this is the artifact id which is spring
boot starter parent so any spring boot
project you are starting do include this
parent this parent is basically bringing
all the dependencies from some other jar
and you can make your project as a as a
child of this particular parent so all
these spring
board projects have this as a parent as
a standard practice after that you
provide your own details in terms of
what is the package name how do you want
to see the jar name on what is the
actual name what is the jar version etc
etc you also set the minimum required
java version to run this application and
then you in the dependency sections you
provide all the charts which you need to
run your project successfully both
compile and run your project
successfully so we added the spring boot
starter web on dependency which
basically brings all the dependencies
around making a controller or making a
repository count context component scan
all the interesting features which
spring provides get wrapped up inside
the spring boot starter jar and you can
actually go to the mvn repository and
and have a look at what all classes it
provides it's a lot of classes so i'm
just telling you in a brief that it
provides all the restful functionality
then you have the next dependency as
spring boot starter data jpa which is
going to enable this project to also
have a database and if it has a database
then you need java to talk to the
database and the way spring suggests to
talk to the database is via using the
spring boot data jpl library we will see
this how this library can be used but
basically this provides ways to
represent your java object in the
database and then you need to also add
the actual dependency of the database
and in this case we are using an in
memory h2 database so i'm not using an
external database like mysql or oracle
or post resql because that will just
make more configurations more
complicated i just wanted to keep it
simple and generally you in this h2
database you can easily access by adding
this dependency and it will be an
in-memory database created for you then
i've also added a spring boot starter
test here which will be used whenever
you are writing unit tests and you must
write unit test for your project and
then we need to add the plugin so that
spring boot can run this project that's
all i have in the palm dot xml now let's
move to the interesting part the java
section part let's start from the main
class
so this is how the main class looks like
where you have you just create
any any name with the class and then you
add a public static void main method
inside the public static void main
method you call spring application dot
run and this run method is basically
going to run your application and you
just provide the same class name which
you just wrote here so you just say dot
class and if you're supplying any
command line arguments it can interpret
that command line arguments as well if
you want so you'd always need an entry
point in an application and this is the
entry point which spring boot supports
and this is if you see this code this is
just normal code to make spring be aware
about this class being treated as an
entry point you need to add add the red
spring boot application annotation on
top of the class this is one of the
annotation which is coming directly from
the spring boot library you can see this
import so once you add this then only
spring will be able to treat this class
as an entry point otherwise spring
doesn't know where to start from so when
you run spring it will fi it will try to
find a class with an annotation
springboot application and then inside
the class it will try to find a public
start a static void main method and once
it has found both of them then it will
just run the application so very simple
nothing fancy here and what we are
dealing with here is a student object so
we will try to insert a student object
and we will try to retrieve the student
object so
if you ignore these annotations which
i've added it's just a pure pojo it's
just a plain old java object you create
a student class let's ignore this field
as well for now i'll just come back to
this annotation in this field but this
is just a student class it has three
fields as name age and address an empty
constructor and a parameterized
constructor and some getters
intentionally i have removed the setters
because generally whenever you are
building any enterprise grid application
you would like to keep your objects
immutable means once they have been
created you would not like somebody to
allow to change the values of the object
this just makes programming much much
more easy if you treat all the objects
in your application as immutable that's
why i have not added setters here it's
just considered a good practice so apart
from the standard things which we have
already seen there are two things here
which i want to talk about let's first
talk about this one so accurate entity
is the annotation which is coming from
java x persistent entity persistence
entity and this makes
spring boot save this particular object
into the database this is the annotation
which you need to put on your class so
that springboot knows that this class
represents a table in the database so
you need to add this to make sure that
this represents a table second thing a
table will have a id it will have sort
of a primary key so i've created a new
column called id which is basically
representing the student's role number
or something or maybe a registration
number and here i'm using couple of more
annotations if you see these annotations
are also coming from java x persistence
library and these annotations will
basically allow the a new id to be
created every time you create a student
object so you don't have to specify the
value of this id variable spring boot
will automatically generate a new id
value every time you create a new
student object and how does it generate
you you can provide the generation type
as well so currently i've just said that
set it as automatic but you can set it
as identity sequence or written or
controlled by table you can also see the
explanation of each of these here but
i've just kept it as auto which
basically
let the persistence provider pick any
appropriate strategy for the particular
database in our case the database is h2
so that's about the entity class let's
call this as entity class now let's move
to the repository so you need a
repository class
like i explained in dots in that three
tier architecture you always need a dow
layer or a repository layer to store
your student object into the database so
we have enabled the student object to be
saved but we need a handler which can
save this particular file this
particular object into the database and
the repository classes are the classes
which will allow you to do that so you
create a very simple interface you what
you name whatever you want to name your
interface as and then you say extends
jpa repository the type of the object
and the unique identifier of the object
so the type of the object is student
here and the unique identifier of the
student object is the id which is of
type long so you need to just supply the
types type of the object type of the
primary key or the type of the unique
identifier and this annotation is coming
from spring boot you can see
specifically spring boot data library
which we added so you just need to
create an interface extend it from jp
repository and make sure that you add
this annotation as well spring heavily
uses the concept of annotations and this
will help spring understand that this is
a repository layer class and it will
apply some more metadata to this class
while this class is running in the jvm
so what happens here you just created an
interface you did not provide any method
to create or any method to delete or any
method to get a student object because
all of that is automatically provided by
springboard via the jpi repository class
if we go inside this class and if you
scroll down you'll see the find all
method find all find all by id save all
flush save and flush delete etc and if
you go further up this also extends the
paging and sorting repository which
provides pagination and sorting
facilities but the interesting one is
that pages and sorting repository again
extends a crud repository and if you go
to the crud repository you will find all
the basic methods to save an entity save
multiple entities find an entity by the
id that's why it needed that long type
to make sure this that it can execute
this method you can check the existence
of an object find all the entries find
all by id count them delete them so all
the basic crud functionality so we call
them as crud because the reason it is
called crud because create read update
delete that's the basically the
generic acronym so because uh this cred
repository provides all the methods and
their implementations automatically we
do not need to write any code at all so
that's why spring boot is so awesome and
that's why springboard is very popular
because it's zero code in the repository
and you still get all the crud
functionality so that's about repository
now we have covered the entity class we
have covered the repository class we
have covered the entry point class now
the only thing which is remaining is the
is the
end point the http endpoint which i
talked about and that you can create by
creating any class generally try to
suffix it with the controller so that
your core developers can easily find
this class and make sure that you put at
the red rest controller annotation on
top of it this annotation will allow
string to treat this particular class as
an end point class then you can auto
wire the student repository so if you
remember i talked about the whole
dependency injection and inversion of
control so here dependency injection is
in action so here you are just telling
student controller to auto wire the
student repository and now what will
happen that at run time student
controller or actually spring will
automatically create an object of the
student repository and supply that
object of student repository to student
controller so you as developer do not
have to create an object of student
repository explicitly that's the benefit
and that's how the dependency injection
is working because you inverted the
dependencies now the dependency is just
injected into the class and as a
developer you don't have to take control
of creating the objects it's the spring
which will automatically read the auto
word annotation and will automatically
supply an object whenever it is required
then i have two methods here since we
are talking about http endpoints so i
have represented a post method here and
a get method here the way you will write
a post method is via at the rate post
mapping annotation and then you can
provide the url path on which somebody
should call your point to save something
so for example somebody can call it http
localhost 8080
student slash create whenever they hit
that url the control or that request
will directly hit this particular method
why because you have provided the url
mapping here in the post mapping
annotation so since it's a post method
there would be request body what is the
actual request body which the client is
sending and you can represent its uh
request body with the add direct request
body annotation and you can provide the
type of the request body and here i'm
saying that hey if you want to access
this particular url yes all good but you
need to supply me with a
text representation of the student
object or a json representation of the
student object and then i inside the
method i'm calling student repository
dot save which is going to save the
student object which is coming in so you
see there's a lot going on here i will i
will show you how the student is
represented in the request body as well
and then i will come back to how it got
converted from json to java but this is
how you can store this particular
student object you can hit this api as
many times as you want and keep
inserting a new student object every
time then if you want to fetch a
particular student then you can do that
by supplying the slash student and then
in the curly braces there's an id
written here so basically you can supply
the value of the id of the student so
generally there would be another method
here which would be find all to see all
the students uh and with their id and
then you can pick a particular student's
id supply that student id value here
dynamically that's why at the curly
braces curly braces supports dynamic
value so here it can insert one two
three or whatever the student id you
want to fetch the value for you provide
that value in the student slash id and
all good then some if somebody is
hitting the url with saying localhost
student slash one then student with the
id 1 will be returned from the request
and you need to put admitted get mapping
to make sure that this method is treated
as an http get method and you can
provide the type you can say get student
and here this dynamic value is captured
with the add the rate path variable
because you need to know the id right
whatever id somebody has supplied it in
the url you need to capture that ide and
then use that ide for calling the
repository so that's you can do that by
using the advantage path variable so
here i'm just saying whatever id is
coming in i will store that value inside
this ide once i've done that then i can
again call student repository dot find
by id which is again a built-in method
provided to me by the crud repository i
can supply the id and this actually is
going to return an optional object which
is uh which is an object which may or
may not contain a value so it said just
a types of defensive programming style
so this will return an optional and you
can call a get method to return the
actual student object this will return
an optional of student so option of
student means that this optional object
may have a student or may not have a
student why did spring do that because
the id somebody is supplying that id can
be invalid also right so optional object
three and takes care of that that if
there is no student found then you will
not get a null pointer exception and if
there is a student found you can return
that so it's just a defensive
programming style which spring has
adopted by returning an optional of the
student object rather than directly the
student object but if you're confident
that this particular option of student
object does contain a student object
then just call optional.get which i've
called here which will return the actual
student object sitting inside the
optional object you can read more about
the optional object and its usage from
the official java docs and there are
tons of examples available on it on
internet so this is about the controller
we have covered all the classes now it's
time to run the application so you go to
the command prompt you go to the
particular uh file folder location and
there
you just say mvn spring hyphen boot
colon run so i just hit enter and this
is going to
run the application it's going to split
some logs here and if everything is fine
you will not get an error and you will
just be getting a message saying that
application got started and it's running
on tomcat localhost 8080 with no context
url so this is not a web application
this is a rest full web service right
this is a restful service this is not a
web application so there is no web
interface so how do you access this you
just have an http url so you can use any
of the rest client available on the
internet there are probably hundreds of
different clients available on the
internet you can choose any one of them
i am using advanced rest client which
you can also install as an extension
from the chrome browser itself so if you
just if i just open the chrome browser
and i just say rest client if you just
write this and hit enter you will get
many different options and the first
option you get is from google play
stores app store so you can go to the
app store that basically the chrome web
store not the play store but the chrome
web store and you can just install this
since this is already installed you can
click on launch app and it will open
this interface for you so this is pretty
uh this is not a tutorial for advanced
risk client so i'll just be quick here
you can choose the method type which you
want to hit so let's say you want to do
a post and then you can provide the url
here so remember the url which we put
here in the controller method this has
to exactly match so http localhost slash
student slash create should be the url
so let me just copy paste this one here
okay so the url is good here it's a post
type of method which i want to do and i
want to hit this particular url now i
need to supply the content type and the
body so in the content type you can
choose application json because i'm
going to supply a json object and in the
body this is how the json object looks
like advanced risk client also provides
a nice visual interface to basically
create this json if you are thinking
that json creation is very tough it's
not actually tough it's just curly
braces and then you put key and value
key value comma let me just put an enter
here so that it's more readable so you
just put curly braces starting an end
and then you just put key value you put
a key which is the variable name and the
variables value variable name variable
value and these keys have to exactly
match the students properties so the
student.java had this name age and
address right so it has to exactly match
otherwise this will request will fail so
this is all good now i can send this
particular request when you click send
it is going to hit my spring boot
application which is running on
localhost 8080 it is going to call the
student slash create method it is also
going to convert this json into a java
object because here i am supplying a
java object so it will convert the json
which i'm sending from here to java
object automatically and it is going to
automatically save it here because i've
called the repository.save method so
let's hit send here once i hit send i
get a 200 okay it means everything went
fine and in the response header i get
the object back because i have returned
the object here you see this save method
is going to return the same student
object which you created uh so
everything is good here my object has
been stored here and now it's time to
fetch the object so it has already been
saved into the h2 in memory database and
you can obviously go and connect to the
in memory h2 database and have a look at
it but for simplicity i'm just going to
do this here and let's say the first
object is generally
added as the id 1 by default by the h2
database so let's hit this particular
url when i hit this url it is going to
hit the student controller here and in
the student controller it is going to
hit the get student method which is
having a student id url and it is going
to find the database with that id and if
it finds a student object with that id
it is going to return that so let's
confirm that now let's hit this
particular send button and it's going to
hit a get request with this particular
url springboard is going to find if a
student with the id one exists in its
database
so once i hit send i get a 200 okay and
you see in the response headers i get
the same student object back which i
added let's try with 2 now let's see
what happens i see 2 and i get 500
internal server error because there is
no object stored in the h2 database of
the spring application with the id 2 yet
because we only inserted one object
that's why only one student object is
there and the first id which h2 database
created for it automatically was one so
when you hit for get request with a
student id one you get the object when
you put any invalid value and you hit
this you get a 500 internal server error
you can also make it look nice by not
sending the 500 internal server error
and sending a nice exception from the
back end so from here you can also send
a nice exception that if this object is
not found you can say something like
that or else throw which is again an
optional object and here you can supply
a particular type of exception which you
want to supply instead of just throwing
500 internal server error but that's
just additional thing additional
defensive programming you can do you can
add more and more validations and
constraints into this project as you
build this project in a more complex
paradigm so this is basically what i
wanted to show you that and that we have
created a spring up boot application we
have connected it to a database we
haven't created also an http endpoint
with student controller we ran that
application we used any random rest
client in my case i used advanced stress
client and we first did a post request
we provided the exact url the url has to
exactly match with the controller url
and then the body the request body also
has to exactly match with the student
objects property especially the case of
the names have to exactly match so if
this all this matches then you will get
a response back that the object has been
created if you want to fetch the value
of the object you're going to use the
http get method and you again provide a
url which has to exactly match to some
method in some controller in the spring
boot application which is running on
localhost and if you provide the right
id you are going to return get a valid
result if you provide an invalid id you
are going to get a 500 internal server
error and from here on you can make this
controller as robust and as mature as
you want you can add find all method you
can add update student method you can
add a delete student method you can have
all different kinds of filters like for
example return to me all the students
starting with the name a or return all
the first
students with the role number one and
hundred or between 100 so you can write
as many endpoints as you want and build
this application in
as with as much maturity and as much
complexity as you want in this session
we shall learn what is junit all about
junit is an open source unit testing
framework for java
here the term unit testing framework
comes into consideration
so before moving forth let's check what
is meant by the term unit testing
unit testing as the name suggests is a
way of testing a unit here a unit refers
to the smallest piece of code that can
be fetched out of the system
it can be a line of code a method or a
class
keep in mind smaller the chunk of code
the better it is
if the tested units are small the tests
tend to run faster providing a better
insight into the code and its
performance
unit testing helps in the early
identification of defects it enables the
developers to spend more time on reading
the code rather than writing it
and a successful code helps in boosting
the confidence of the developer
then coming back to junit the framework
is used by java developers to create and
test their codes
it is used for unit testing of the
source code and junit works on the
approach of testing a small part then
coding that and continuing the same till
the end
junit testing helps developers to
develop more reliable readable and a bug
free code
every time a new code is added all the
test cases have to be re-executed to
make sure that nothing is broken
there are graphs in junit that show the
progress of the test
the graphs show green when the test runs
smoothly and it turns red when the test
fails
now when we know about junit let's see
the way to download and install that
into our system
before you go on to install junit make
sure you have jdk and eclipse
installed in your computer system
so
let's go on
first open your browser in the browser
type
download junit
in download.junit we'll get about junit
in about junit when we scroll we find
download and install
in download and install when we go
inside that link we will find two jar
files
here let's download these two jar files
when we click on this download button we
will download jar
after the first jar is downloaded let's
go back to that page and download the
second jar file
after both the jar files are downloaded
let's go to the location
here we can see two of our jar files are
downloaded
let's copy these jar files
go to our documents and here in the java
libraries where all the java libraries
are stored let's paste
them after we have pasted these files
we shall open our eclipse
as soon as our eclipse opens we will
first create a project here new then we
shall create a java project
in java project let's name it
junit
installation
click on next
and finish
here
then in this java project
right click on it
and go to the build path option in the
build path option go to configure build
path
here go to the tab libraries
and this side go to add external jars
in add external jars you will get the
location of our two jar files and if you
don't get them you can browse to the
location where you have stored them or
to the location of java libraries
then select these two files
and open them
you will see the two jar files appear
here
then click on apply and close
now come back to junit installation that
is a project right click on it
and click on refresh
then right click on the src folder
go to new and create a package
let's name the package to be
junit install
and click on finish
in this package
create a new class
and we shall name the class
junit
install
and click on finish
now let's create a method over here
in the method
we shall type
public void my
junit
install
and system dot
out
dot print ln
welcome
to my
junit
welcome to my junit
testing
now i will add a library over here
library
test
i can see a error now when i hover over
this library
i can see it says import test
so now when i click on it the error is
gone
now we shall run our test and since we
are testing with junit we shall click
here
go on run as junit test
here we shall click on ok
and then we can see in the console it
shows welcome to my junit testing as we
had placed it over here
here on the left side you can see the
junit report
you can see runs one out of one and
there is no or zero errors and same
there are zero failures
so here in the space provided you can
have as many number of tests as many
bunch of code you want and with the help
of junit you can test any particular
part of the code
we will be going through some of the
project ideas related to java
programming language
so the first project that we will deal
today is the online career management
system so this particular project motto
is to deal with the career management
system
the system will be used for day-to-day
activities like buy written booking
delivery and non-delivery and
self-pickup etc
it is not easy to build this particular
project all alone as the technicality of
the project is a little complex for a
single programmer i would suggest you
that you get a team with you and also
look out for some automation in the
process by developing the relevant
software
robotic process automation is the new
normal in today's life the web enabled
interface allows the user to log in from
anywhere in the world and track their
career and also view the customer rating
the system is designed to integrate with
financial accounting to eliminate
duplication of data entry and is also
scalable to grow along with your company
the system needs to be built with
user-friendly screens rich in
functionality and features and finally
the major part it should maintain a high
level of data integrity
so with that abstract discussed now
let's look into the features offered by
this particular online courier service
as discussed in the abstract this
particular project should be providing
the features of order and dispatch of
the product information regarding the
customer delivery executive and followed
by the delivery executive we should be
also having a payment window which
manages the accounts and bill reports
so having said that let's now move into
the software requirements
so the software used in this particular
project is the programming language that
is java database is the microsoft access
and some convenient rpa tools and
finally the ide the id for this can be
anyone which has a good support for java
the most preferable one would be the
eclipse and then comes the intellij
netbeans and many more now creating this
kind of a project will give you a
valuable experience based on building a
fully fledged e-commerce website or an
application
i mean this is how the world's leading
applications like amazon flip cards or
matteo etc are basically planned and
have reached greater heights today this
kind of project on your resume could
make a huge difference and who knows
tomorrow you might even get into one of
those companies and start working on
their projects or build a company of
your own
followed by the online career system we
have the online voting system now
thinking apart from getting a job or
starting a new company of your own this
is something that we all need today in
this pandemic situation especially in
the current scenario the internet has
brought all the east to our living room
it has replaced physical banking to
internet banking ordering food online
buying movie tickets
buying clothes and household items to
consult your doctor for minor issues
bill payments and many more
yet for quite a long time going to
polling booth and standing in a long
queue to cast a vote has been persistent
and it has been challenging for the
government to motivate common people to
participate in the election system and
cash their vote just because there is no
other way to do such thing as such an
online voting system but all the credit
can be achieved by software engineers
who can make it possible soon for
everyone to cast their vote to their
respective candidate as their own choice
with an unmatchable ease
this can be done just by click on their
fingers
this is an advanced java project
developed to show online voting
functionality followed by the abstract
we will get into the technicality of
this particular project so the first
phase of this particular project has the
admin phase where the admin has the
right to manage the candidates manage
the voters and their profiles and
passwords and finally election results
followed by the admin we have the voter
or the user of this particular
application the voter or the user gets
to
register himself or herself into the
application followed by that he can use
the login and logout options and next we
have the profile and password
managements so followed by that we have
the option to choose the positions to
vote and finally to cast the vote now
this particular project is an advanced
level java project developed to show
online voting functionality it showcases
the use of java servlets html and css
again coming into the ide the ide for
this can be anyone who has good support
for java the most preferable one would
be eclipse and intellij
followed by the online voting system we
will now continue with the online
healthcare management
named as the corporate medicare
management this e-healthcare management
system is a web-based project developed
in java
the main aim of this particular project
is to provide effective management of
data related to staff and patients in
hospitals or clinics
the features offered by this particular
project should be as follows it should
optimize bed occupation the project
should improve the use of operation
theaters avoiding the cancellation of
operations to know how much emergencies
affect the administration of the
hospital departments or services which
include cancellation of operations
to optimize the allocation of human and
material resources to warts and shifts
to detect the influence of certain
diseases in the hospital services and
finally to find clusters of patients
the software requirement for this
particular project are as follows
we need dhtml for the front end
and java as the programming language
and data mining tool which is weka and
oracle for the database
javascript for the scripting language
and finally tomcat as our server the
e-health care management system is a
web-based application that assists the
management of staff doctors and patients
in an easy comfortable and effective way
here the concept of data mining plays a
vital role to develop an effective
health care management system
the proposed application aims to create
a friendly working environment for any
healthcare centers to overcome the
drawbacks in the existing system of
healthcare management
this system is very reliable and
flexible from all aspects so new
features and modules can be easily
integrated into the system in the future
followed by the e-healthcare management
system we have a new normal online
banking
not interesting and arousing for a
normal person but for a hardcore
programmer it is as exciting as a roller
coaster ride in an amusement park
because this is how the major national
and multinational banks implement their
banking facilities in a wide range so
that their customers could experience
the ease of banking at their fingertips
one such type of project on your resume
could bring major highlight to the
recruiter especially if the recruiter is
from a banking or financial based
company
online banking system project is a model
internet banking site this project
should enable the customers to perform
basic bank transactions by sitting at a
corner of their home or office through a
phone or laptop the customers can access
bank's website for viewing their account
details and perform the transactions on
account as per the requirement bank
employees can log in and add customer
and account information to perform
transactions with internet banking with
internet banking the break and mode
structure of the traditional bank gets
converted into a click and portal mode
thereby giving the concept of virtual
banking a real shape thus today's
banking is no longer confined to
branches
e-banking facilities banking
transactions by
customers around the clock globally the
features you can offer through this
particular project are
home page for online banking site
creation of new accounts login and log
out
manage profiles and passwords view the
balance of the account deposit the
amount into the selected account whether
amount from the selected account
transfer the amount from one account to
another close the account so the
software requirements for this
particular project are java programming
language and and javascript for
scripting language and oracle for
database and tomcat for server
so followed by the online banking
project we have the online examination
project
online exams are normal for us nowadays
but this is totally limited to high-end
exams like ced gre cat etc the
requirement for this particular project
is increasing day by day because of the
current scenarios
many schools and colleges have now
turned towards the online education
system and are looking forward to
hosting online exams for student safety
online examination is a simple project
developed to provide an online platform
for faculty and students to conduct
online examinations and their
evaluations
this particular project has two parts
first is the admin part
admin has the right to add students
create one-time login
adding questions receive answers and
finally to evaluate followed by the
first part we have the second part which
belongs to the students
so the students can log in update their
profile and password select answers for
the mcqs write answers to questions and
finally closing the session and log out
this particular project can be made a
grand success by making use of simple
java servlets and java programming
languages and server like apache tomcat
followed by the online examinations we
have the smart city smart city java
project can be a web-based software
developed to store the details of a
particular city the main purpose of the
project is to help tourists and other
visitors to a city by providing
information about hotels transportation
facilities air ticket booking shopping
details city news etc the smart city
java project serves the visitors as a
guide of the city and hence the project
is called as city guide project in java
using this project the details of the
city can be accessed from anywhere at
any time the implementation of the city
project promotes tourism and business
effectively
hotels can be searched more easily from
anywhere with the help of this online
software students can look out for
academic institutes located in the city
you can view the complete map of the
city using this project
followed by the abstract we have the
features of this particular project the
features offered in this particular
project are login update profile and
password search for the options select
an option like booking a ticket or hotel
or anything like
transportation etc and finally selecting
that particular option booking that
option and payment window finally the
confirmation of the order
this particular project can be fulfilled
by using the following software tools as
mentioned below
they are the java programming language
tomcat server scripting languages like
javascript etc and database
as oracle for interactive data storage
this could be escalated to another level
by following
designed drones that can act like a corp
act as a tourist guide for the people
touring the city a drone that has
capability to take pictures videos of
suspected activities and store it for
future reference a drone can intimidate
a cop if any suspected activities are
detected
there can be many drones in the city
with different functionalities and
finally you are required to implement
the functionality of the drone
to the users to interact with the drone
users could be travelers or comps or
travel agents or cab agents
the code for all these projects are
provided in the description box below
followed by the smart city we have the
bug tracking system
the bug tracking system is a web-based
application developed by java
programming language for software
companies
the main aim of this project is to
manage the errors or bugs that occur
during the software development phase
and cycle after the implementation of
this project the employees can update
the issue details solve the issues and
update the system for any location with
internet access
below are the features of this project
and source code of this project is
linked in the description box below
coming into features the software is
applicable in managing the bugs that
occur during the development of software
and tracking the older issues it
facilitates searching the facility to
bug history and solution
the system is fully secured and
authentication method is adopted to
manage security it stores the old debug
reports so that they can easily be
solved when they reappear the
application helps the project manager in
evaluating the works of the employees
and finally the proposed software is
capable of auto update when the latest
version is available
so the software requirements for this
particular project are
programming language which is java
web-based applications such as jdbc jndi
servlets jsp and oracle database or
access database as the database
followed by that the server deployment
is red hat jboss es etc and the client
side scripting as the javascript and the
ide for this particular project would be
eclipse with all the my eclipse plugins
and finally the user interface can be
designed using html and css
so with this we can move ahead into the
next project which is the facial
recognition
the face recognition with opencv is an
open source computer vision library that
has tons of modules like object
detection face detection and augmented
reality
the major features that this particular
project offers are managing the user
faces facilitate face identification
easy login and log out store face ids
identify suspects with just images
enhanced way to find cyber criminals so
followed by the features now we should
look into the software requirements to
build this particular project so the
programming language we need for this
particular project is java and followed
by the programming language we need the
apache and framework
mingw64 and finally the cmake framework
so followed by the facial recognition
project we have the next project which
is the vehicle recognition
so java and pr is a number plate
recognition software which implements
algorithmic and mathematical principles
from artificial intelligence machine
vision and neural networks
so the features offered by this
particular project are high level
language for numerical computation
interactive environment for iterative
exploration mathematical functions
built-in graphics functions for
integrating matlab and many more so this
particular project can be fulfilled by
using opencv and java programming
language along with some natural
language processing
algorithms so followed by vehicle
recognition project we have our last
project which is the speech recognition
system so speech recognizer converts
audio to text
java x dot speech dot recognition
package defines the recognizer interface
to build speech recognition plus a set
of supporting classes and interfaces
so the features or stages in this
particular project are to create a
speech recognizer allocate resources
load and enable grammar attach result
listener commit changes and finally
provide the process results
so this particular library is readily
available in java and you can code this
project using the java programming
language and an id such as eclipse we
all know that java is one of the most
sought programming languages in the
current id industry there are multiple
multi-million dollar companies which are
using java till today
so this video is completely dedicated to
help out the java developers and the
beginners in java programming language
to crack the most frequently asked java
interview questions
so without further ado let's begin with
our interview questions at first we will
start with the beginner level interview
questions
so in the beginner level interview
questions the first question we have is
what is jit
so the answer for this question is
jit is an abbreviation for java in time
compiler it increases efficiency of the
interpreter by compiling the byte code
in the runtime
jit or just in time compiler compiles
code to machine level directly for
higher speeds of code execution
so basically just in time compilation is
a feature added to the interpreter of
java so this involves conversion of the
code directly to machine level during
the compilation stage this improvises
the speed of execution of a java program
now after the first question the second
question in the docket is
what is a class loader
now let's discuss the answer for this
particular question
so basically class loader is the first
file to load when you execute any java
program so the java class loader is the
integrated part of java virtual machine
so the functionality of class loader is
to load the class to the java virtual
machine while it is demanded to execute
a class
java has both strap extension and
application type of class loaders so the
third question in the docket is
what are the memory allocations
available in java so the answer for this
particular question is
java provides multiple types of memory
allocations but the five major types of
memory allocations which are most
frequently used are class memory heap
memory stack memory program counter
memory native method stack memory
so the next question in the list is
will the program run if i write static
public void main so basically we write
public static word main but in case
imagine if i write the program as static
public void main will the program
execute properly so the answer for this
question is yes because java does not
follow any specific rule for the order
of specifiers you place in your program
so when you execute the program with
such pattern in your specifiers then the
program will compile successfully also
it will run successfully
so the next question we have is
what is the default value stored in
local variables
so in c programming language when you
declare a local variable or a global
variable or any type of variable
then the first value which is stored
inside that variable will be a garbage
value unless you initialize the variable
with a personalized value for example if
you declare a variable i equal to 0 then
you are storing a value in that variable
i that is 0. if you just declare it as
int i then the value stored inside that
i variable will be a garbage value so
similarly when you declare some kind of
local variable in java then what will be
the default value stored inside it
so the answer for this question is
neither the local variables or the
global variables or any primitives or
any object references do not have any
kind of default value stored in them
so followed by the fifth question we
have the sixth question
so what would be the output of the
following code segment is the sixth
question so this might happen sometimes
so basically what happens is your
interviewer will throw a question at you
which has a code segment so all you need
to do is decode that code in your mind
and provide the output so this would be
the code that we will be dealing with
so you can see
our question has two printf statements
the first one has hundred plus hundred
plus a string which is simply learn and
in the second printf statement we have a
string that is e-learning company plus
hundred plus hundred so what will be the
output of these two printf statements
so the answer for this question is
really simple
so we'll be having 200 simply learn as
the first output and e-learning company
1 100
0 as the second output why
let's check out the code segment once
again
so when you see the code segment once
again so the first printf statement has
100 plus 100 plus simply learn so jvm
here understands 100 as an integer value
and the plus symbol as an addition
operator here so followed by the
addition operator we have another
integer value so what jvm does is it
adds the two numbers hundred plus
hundred so followed by that we have
another plus symbol here so followed by
the plus symbol we have a string value
so here the jvm considers the plus
symbol as
a concatenating operator but not as an
addition operator so that's why the
first two numbers got added and the
result was 200 and the next two values
were concatenated so it became as 200
simply learn similarly in the second
printf statement the jvm encountered
with a string value so it considered the
plus symbol as a concatenating operator
similarly it happened with the second
plus symbol as well so that's the reason
we had elearning one zero zero one zero
zero as the second output
now followed by the sixth question we
have the seventh question
what is an association
so the answer for this question is an
association can be defined as a
relationship that has no ownership over
the other so to understand this
definition we can consider a simple
example
consider a person associated with
multiple banks so consider person x who
has got accounts in bank a bank b and
bank c
and similarly a bank is associated with
person x
that is a bank a bank b and bank c are
associated with a person x but no one
has ownership over the other a person x
who is an account holder with all the
three banks that is a b and c does not
possess any kind of ownership over the
three banks similarly
banks a b and c who has the customer
which is the person x
but the banks do not possess any kind of
ownership over the customer
so the relationship between the person x
and the banks abc can be considered as
an association
now followed by the seventh question we
have the next question that is the
eighth question
define copy constructor and java so the
answer for this question is as follows
a copy constructor in java is a
constructor that initializes an object
through another object of the same class
a copy constructor in java is really
helpful because when you want to copy a
complex object that has several fields
or when we want to make a deep copy of
an existing object then the copy
constructor is the one which will help
you out in this situation
so followed by the eighth question we
have the ninth question
what is a marker interface
so the answer for this question is
an empty interface in java is referred
as a marker interface
serializable and cloneable are some of
the popular examples of marker interface
so basically a marker interface is just
another interface but normally in
interface we provide some signatures so
these signatures belong to particular
methods so
in normal interface we just have method
signatures but not the complete
implementation or at least we'll be
having some variables but in a marker
interface we do not have any kind of
data manipulating method signatures any
data members nothing they have special
functionality unlike a normal interface
so followed by the ninth question we
have the tenth question
what is object cloning
i guess the word object learning is
completely self-explanatory yet the
answer for this question is it is an
ability to recreate an object completely
similar to the existing object this
process is known as object cloning in
java
java provides a built-in function or
method that is the clone method to clone
an existing object offering the same
functionality that of the original
object
so followed by the 10th question we have
our 11th question why is java not
completely object oriented so this
question might be a little confusing but
it's true java is not completely object
oriented but what's the reason yes i'll
explain you why java is not completely
object oriented
so the answer for this question is java
is not considered as 100 object-oriented
programming language because of the data
types it uses
it still makes use of eight or more
primitive data types which are end flow
double and few others so this is the
only reason why java is not considered
as completely 100
object oriented programming language so
the next question is
define wrapper classes in java
so the answer for this question is
in java when you declare primitive data
types that is the end flow double etc
then the wrapper classes are responsible
for converting them into objects or
reference types just as we discussed
before
java is not 100 object oriented
programming language just because of the
primitive data types it uses so when you
include such primitive data types then
wrapper classes are the ones which
convert them into objects or reference
types for the ease of compilation and
execution of programs without any issues
so followed by this question we have the
next question
define singleton classes in java so the
answer for this question is in java when
you make the constructor of a class as
private then the particular class can
generate only one single object this is
the reason why such type of classes are
called as singleton classes
so followed by that we have our next
question that says define package in
java so if you use some of the popular
ides that is the integrated development
enterprises such as intellij or eclipse
then you might be familiar with projects
packages source files and then the class
file so basically you create a project
first and inside the project you will be
having your source folder and then you
will be creating your own package using
the source folder and inside the package
you will create a class file and inside
the class file is where you write your
java program so here the question is
define package in java
so the answer for this question is as
follows
package is a collective bundle of
classes and interfaces along with
necessary libraries and java files the
use of packages helps in code
reusability so basically when you create
a specific package inside that package
you will store all the class files that
you will be using in your java program
so not only class files in case if you
use any kind of connectors or any kind
of jar files or any kind of dependencies
for your java program you will include
all those inside the package so that the
requirements and the class files are
bundled together and
this helps out in code reusability
making sure that the
program files or the java files or any
dependencies are not juggling between
one package to the other or one file to
the other so using a package is
basically a good practice
so followed by this we have our next
question
can you implement pointers in java
program
so if you remember
c programming language we had pointers
there
so we use pointers to directly access
the memory
so similarly can you use pointers in a
java program this is a little tricky
question for beginners but basically
it's really simple
now the answer for this question is
no because java virtual machine
personally takes care of memory
management implicitly so java's major
motto was to keep programming simple so
accessing memory directly through
pointers is not a recommended action so
the answer is a big no you cannot
implement pointers in java program
so followed by that we have our next
question
differentiate between instance and local
variables
so the answer for this question is
really simple instance variables are
declared inside a class and the scope is
limited to only a specific object inside
which an instance variable is created so
followed by the instance variable we
have the local variable so the local
variable can be anywhere inside a method
or a specific block of code also the
scope is limited to the block of code
where the variable that is the local
variable is declared
now followed by the 16th question we
have our next question
explain java string pool so the answer
for this question is a collection of
strings in java's heap memory is
referred as java's string pool so for
example you wanted to create a new
string
consider your name so your name might be
some xyz so if you wanted to create xyz
string then you provide that particular
code to your jvm so what does jvm do it
will not directly create that particular
string first it will search for the xyz
string in your string pool if that is
already existing in your string pool
then it will provide a reference to that
particular string in case if xyz is not
there
then the jvm will create a new string
that is the xyz string
so followed by this we have our next
question that is
what is an exception
so the answer for this question is an
exception in java is considered as an
unexpected event that can disrupt the
normal flow of the program
so for example just consider that you
are going to write a program for
division operator
so after you finish your program your
evaluator might want to test your code
to the extreme levels so instead of
providing a proper number imagine that
your evaluator is providing a wrong
input such as special symbols sometimes
0 or any other sort of input so if this
kind of input is provided to your
program then your program might crash so
you can avoid this kind of crash by
using exception handling so basically
you can use try and catch blocks so you
can embed your code inside the try block
and say to your program that if any kind
of wrong input such as special symbol or
0 is provided by the evaluator then send
a message saying wrong input or divide
by zero exception so this kind of
approach will provide an output but this
kind of approach will avoid your program
from crashing so this is how exceptions
are handled in real time so followed by
this we have our next question
what is final keyword in java
so the answer for this question is the
term final is a predefined word in java
that is used while declaring values to
variables when a value is declared using
the final keyword then that particular
value of that particular variable will
remain constant throughout the execution
of program so sometimes if you include a
normal variable and
provide an operation on that particular
variable then the value of that
particular variable will change after
the execution of program but when you
declare the same variable using
final keyword then no number of
operations or any kind of manipulations
applied onto that variable will not
change the value of that particular
variable so that's the speciality of
final keyword in java so followed by
that we'll dive into the next question
that is
what happens when the main method is not
declared as static
so the answer for this question is
when the main method is not declared a
static then the program may be compiled
perfectly but ends up with a serious
ambiguity and throws a runtime error
that says
no such method error
so when you basically declare a main
method
don't forget to specify the static
keyword
so with this we finish the beginner
segment of questions followed by the
beginners segment we have the next
segment that is the intermediate level
segment
so the first question in the
intermediate level is
what is jdk and mention the variance of
jdk
so the answer for this question is
so jdk is basically an abbreviation for
java development kit
this is a combined package of jre that
is the java runtime environment and
developer tools used for designing java
applications and applets
oracle has the following variants for
java development kit so the first one is
the jdk standard edition which is
normally used by beginners and
intermediate developers next after the
jdk standard edition we have the java
development kit for enterprise
so this particular enterprise edition is
used by professional java developers for
developing java based applications and
frameworks
now the last one is the java development
kit micro edition
now followed by 21st question we will
dive into the next question that says
brief access specifiers and types of
access specifiers in java so the answer
for this question is as follows
basically access specifiers are
predefined keywords used to help a java
virtual machine to understand the scope
of a particular data member or data
manipulating method within a class or
outside the class so in java we have
four types of access specifiers the
first one is public access specifier so
when you declare a data member or a data
manipulating method as public then that
particular data member or method can be
accessible by any class or object
throughout the package
followed by that we have the private
access specifier so unlike the public
access specifier when you provide the
private access specifier then the
accessibility of that particular private
data member or the data manipulating
method will be provided to specific
classes and specific objects only
and finally we have the protected access
specifier so the protected access
specifier is a bit more secure than the
private access specifier so the access
for this particular protected data
member or protected data manipulating
method could be a little more difficult
to access unless you are going to
implement everything which is present in
that particular package so basically if
you are trying to access the protected
data member or protected data
manipulating method
of a different package then you need to
first import the package into your
existing package so that's how the
protected access specifier works
practically so finally after the major
three axis specifiers we have the
default access specifier so default
access specifier will be provided by the
java virtual machine so in case if you
declare a variable or a data
manipulating method without using any
specific access specifiers that are
public private and protected then jvm
implicitly considers the default access
specifier so there is no much of a
difference between the public access
specifier and the default access
specifier both have the same
functionality and accessibility so
followed by this question we enter into
the next question that is
can a constructor written a value
so the answer for this question is as
follows
yes
a constructor can written a value it
basically returns the current instance
of a class implicitly you cannot make a
constructor written a value explicitly
but
automatically it returns the instance of
a class
so the next question is explain this
keyword in java so in java we do have a
keyword which is called as this so what
does the keyword this mean in java is a
question
so the answer for this question is the
term this is a special keyword
designated as a reference variable so
the term this keyword is used to refer
to the current class properties like
data manipulating method instance data
member and constructors so followed by
the 24th question we have our next
question that says
explain
super keyword in java so the answer for
this question is as follows
the term super is a special keyword
designated as a reference variable so
similar to this keyword even super
keyword acts as a reference variable but
the difference is super keyword is used
to refer to the immediate parent class
object so followed by the 25th question
we have our next question
that is explain method overloading in
java so basically method overloading and
method overriding etc are the concepts
of polymorphism so now let's have a
correct answer here
so the process of creating multiple
method signatures using one method name
is called as method overloading
so for example consider that you wanted
to include an addition operation in your
program that performs addition operation
so the first method will be having the
name add and inside the method
parameters you will be having two
integer types of parameters similarly
you wanted to perform another addition
operation with the same name add so here
you will provide the method name
completely same to the first method but
inside the parameters there is a
difference you are adding
three parameters here
so when you pass the values to the add
method
then which method to be overloaded
that's the confusion right so should i
overload or should i execute the first
add method or the second method so this
completely depends on the number of
parameters you pass if you are passing
two parameters then the first method
will be executed if you are passing
three parameters then the second method
will be executed so this is how the
method overloading happens in java
so
the process of method overloading can be
achieved by using two different ways the
first way is to change the number of
arguments so that's what exactly i've
discussed before now the second way is
varying the written type of the method
so with this let's enter into the next
question
can we overload a static method
so as discussed before the values of the
variables or data manipulating methods
will not be changed when we have used
the keyword static in front of it so the
question is can we overload a static
method
now let's discuss the answer for this
the answer is no java does not support
overloading of static method
the process worked through an error
reading static method cannot be
referenced so followed by this we have
our next question
so the next question is define
late binding the answer for this
question is
binding is a process of unifying the
method call with the methods code
segment
late binding happens when the methods
code segment is unknown till the method
is called during the runtime
so followed by this we have our next
question define dynamic method dispatch
so the answer is the dynamic method
dispatch is a process where the method
call is executed during the runtime the
overridden method is called through a
reference variable of superclass so this
process is called as runtime
polymorphism
now we have our next question
why is delete function faster in
linkedlist than an array
so basically linked list and array are
the java collections or in other words
it's also considered as data structure
so to answer this question you need to
understand the analogy of linked list
and array so basically an array is a
complete memory block of consecutive
memory locations so consider that your
memory location starts from 100 and your
array has 10 locations so it's a
complete reserved block of from 100 101
102 to 1.9
so you have 10 memory blocks so in case
if you wanted to add a number or a
delete a number then you had to make
changes to the complete memory block but
when you come into linked list
you have
the memory blocks used from the memory
heap so basically what you do here is
you basically connect the nodes through
addresses
so in case if you wanted to eliminate a
number then what you do is just to
manipulate the addresses so the address
of the consecutive node will be changed
so that's the only change what you make
so now
this is the reason why the
delete function or any kind of
manipulation function is faster in
linked list compared to array
so now let's have a brief answer on this
delete function is faster in linked list
as the user needs to make a minor update
to the point of value so that the node
can point to the next successor in the
list
now followed by this we have our next
question
give a briefing on the life cycle of a
thread
so the life cycle of a thread includes
five stages which are as mentioned below
newly bound state runnable state that is
it provides the jvm with a feedback that
i'm ready to run now followed by that
the running stage where the threat is
actually running followed by that the
block stage so basically the thread will
be blocked for some reasons for some
intermediate output or something if the
thread is waiting for an input from
another source or
something similar so that's where the
blocked state comes to existence and
finally the dead state once after
everything is processed the threat is
eliminated by gvm
now followed by this we have our next
question that says
explain the differences between
the operators provided here
so the operators might look similar but
they are different now let's understand
about these operators in a much better
way through the answer so the answer for
this question is although they look
similar but there's a huge difference
between them so the first operator which
looks like two greater than symbols
performed the operation of right
shifting so when you provide a binary
number or binary value then the bits
will be shifted towards the right and
the second symbol or the second operator
which is having three greater than
symbols is used to shift out the zero
filled bits so this is the functionality
of these two operators now followed by
that let's have the 33rd question
brief the life cycle of an applet
so the answer for this question is the
life cycle of an applet basically
involves the following stages the first
stage is the initialization stage next
is the start stage third is the stop
stage fourth is destroy and finally we
have paint
now the next question is
why are generics used in
java
so the answer for this question is
compile time type safety is provided by
using generics in java so this approach
allows the users to catch unnecessary
invalid inputs at the time of
compilation
generic methods and classes help
programmers to specify a single method
declaration a set of related methods or
with a single class declaration a set of
related types
so followed by this we have our next
question
explain
externalizable interface
so the answer for this question is the
externalizable interface helps with the
control over the process of
serialization the externalization
interface incorporates read external and
right external methods so we have
listened to a new term here which is
serialization so what exactly is
serialization
serialization is a process of sending
your java code or java project from one
computer system to a different computer
system so basically if you wanted to
execute some kind of java program from a
different location then you serialize
this particular code to a different
location where you actually want to
execute and this particular process of
transferring your code is called as
serialization
now the next question is explain daemon
thread so the answer for this question
is the daemon thread can be defined as a
thread with least responsibility the
demon thread is designed to run in a
background during the process of garbage
collection in java the set demon method
is used to create the demon thread in
java programming language
so we have our next question now explain
the term enumeration in java
so the answer for this question is
enumeration or enum is an interface in
java enum allows the sequential access
of elements stored in a collection in
java now the next question is
why is java considered as a dynamic
programming language
so the answer for this question is java
was designed to adapt to an evolving
environment java programs include large
amount of runtime information that is
actually used to resolve access to the
objects in real time so this is a reason
why java is considered as dynamic
programming language
now followed by this we have our next
question
can you run a code before executing the
main method
so the answer for this question is
yes we can execute any code even before
the main method
we will be using the static block of
code in the class when creating the
objects at load time of the class any
statements within the static block of
the code will execute it once while
loading the class even before the
creation of objects in the main method
now the last question in the
intermediate section is how many times
the finalized method is called
so the answer for this question is the
finalized method is called by the
garbage collector so for every object
the garbage collector calls the finalize
method just for once
now with this let's enter the advanced
segment of interview questions based on
java
so the first question in the advanced
segment is
can the keywords this and super
be used together
so the answer for this question is
no
this and super keywords should be used
in the first statement in the class
constructor so the following code
segment will give you a better idea
so you can see that we have used the
keyword super and this in the class
constructor that is the first class
constructor
now this is how you can use super
keyword and this keyword together in
case if you wanted to use so with this
let's continue with the next question in
the advanced level
so the next question says explain jsp
page so the answer for this question is
jsp is basically an abbreviation for
java servlet page so the java servlet
page consists of two types of text the
first is the static data and the second
one is java servlet page elements
now the next question is
explain
jdbc so the answer is jdbc is an
abbreviation for java database connector
jdbc is an abstract layer used to
establish connectivity between any
existing database and to a java
application
next question is
explain the various directives of jsp
so the directives are instructions
processed by jsp engine
after the jsp page is compiled into a
servlet directives are used to set page
level instructions
insert data from external files and
specify custom tag libraries directives
are defined between the following
symbols
so these are the symbols that are used
to specify the directives in a jsp page
the different types of directives are
shown as below there are three types of
directives they are include directive
page directive and tagleb directive so
include directive includes a file and
merges the content of the file with the
current page
the page directive is used to define
specific attributes in the jsp page like
error page and buffer the taglib
directory is used to declare a custom
tag library which is used in the jsp
page
followed by that we have the next
question
what are observer and observable classes
so the answer for this question is
objects that subclass the observable
class maintain a list of observers when
an observable object is updated it
invokes the update method of each of the
observers to notify that the observers
that it has changed its state
the observer interface is implemented by
objects that observe observable objects
might be a little confusing but you need
to read this answer once again you can
pause it and you can read this answer
once again so that you can get a brief
understanding of this
followed by that we have the next
question
what is session management in java so
the answer for this question is
a session is essentially defined as the
dynamic stage of a random conversation
between the client and the server the
essential communication channel includes
the string of responses and requests
from both sides typically the most
popular way of implementing session
management is the employment of a
session id in the communicative desk
course of the client and the server
the next question is brief about spring
framework spring framework is basically
the framework of frameworks now the
answer for this question is spring is
essentially defined as the application
framework and inversion of control
container for java basically the chief
purpose of spring framework is to create
enterprise applications in java
also it is especially useful to keep in
mind that the central features of the
spring framework are essentially
conductive to any java application
so the next question is explain jca in
java so the answer for this question is
jca is basically an abbreviation for
java cryptography architecture so jca
provides a platform that gives
architecture and apis for encryption as
well as decryption
jc is used by the developer to combine
the application with the security
measure it also helps in performing the
third party security rules it uses the
hash table encryption message digest etc
to implement the security so the next
question is
explain jpa in java so the answer for
this question is
jpa stands as an abbreviation for java
persistence api
the jpa is enabling us to create the
persistence layer for desktop and web
applications
jpa deals with the following
java persistence api query language java
persistence criteria api object mapping
metadata etc
so the last question in our list is
explain the different authentications in
java servlets
so the answer for this question is
authentication options available in
servlets are as follows the first one is
basic authentication so the basic
authentication consists of username and
password provided by the client to
authenticate as the user the second one
is form based authentication
in this particular type of
authentication the login form is made by
the programmer by using html
followed by that we have the third type
of authentication that is digest
authentication
digest authentication is similar to
basic authentication but in this the
passwords are encrypted using hash
formula
this makes digest more secured and
lastly we have the client certificate
authentication the client certificate
authentication requires that each client
accessing the resource has a certificate
that it sends to authenticate itself
this requires ssl protocol now with that
we have come to an end of this advanced
java full course if you have any queries
regarding the topics covered in this
tutorial or if you're in the need of the
codes executed in this particular
tutorial then please feel free to write
us down in the comment section below and
they will be happy to resolve all your
queries until next time thank you stay
safe and keep learning